COMMITTEE AND I WILL. TO SCHOOL
OVER THE PROTOCOLS THAT WERE
FALLING TODAY OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO COPE
WITH NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES ROOMS LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS. AND
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
A MINUTE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING TELECONFERENCING SERVICES
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 877-226-8150 TWO. AT.
877-226-8150 TWO AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO THREE FOUR EIGHT
ZERO TWO FOUR THAT'S. TWO THREE
FOUR EIGHT ZERO TWO FOUR FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY THE MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION PRESSED IS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN TAKE A
SHORT WAY. ARE LUNCH RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT.
IN QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AND AT
THAT TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTE
IT AND YOU'LL BE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE THAT YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR YOU HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THE HEARING. THE
HEARING OF ALL BILLS. ON OUR
SCHEDULE TODAY. AFTER THE
INITIAL WITNESS AND THE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION. WE WILL THEN BE
LIVING COMMENTS TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES PER SIDE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED. FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICES OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS. MUTED AND THAT
APPLIES FOR IN THE CHAMBERS
WALL WALL OUR EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS AND- CLOSE TO THE SAME
MANNER AS CUSTOMARY THERE WILL
BE SOME. BLOCK TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE CHOOSE
AND TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED. PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. TODAY WE HAVE TWENTY
BILLS ON OUR AGENDA. BUT WE
HAVE SOME DATES AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX HAS BEEN PULLED
PULLED BY THE OFF AUTHOR BE
WE'VE RE SCHEDULED FOR NEXT
WEEK AB TWO SIX EIGHT HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR MADE IT TO
YOUR BILL. FIVE BILLS ARE
CONSIDERED THOSE ARE A. B. T.
N. O. SEVEN AB FIFTY SEVEN AB
SIX FIVE THREE A. B. NINE TO
FIVE IN A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY
TWO AND ONE BILL AB THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE- BITES A CINNAMON
CHAO IS VOTE ONLY. BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESENTATIONS WELL WE
CAN'T STEPS OF CORN YET SO I
WILL CALL OUR FIRST- AUTHOR.
FOR IF WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS SO WHEN YOU'RE
READY YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR
TESTIMONY ON AB. ONE TEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR HI GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR IT AB ONE
TEN WHICH REQUIRED CALIFORNIA'S
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT THE EDT. TO CROSS
CHECK UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
CLAIMS AGAINST INCARCERATION
RECORDS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. OVER THE COURSE
OF THE PANDEMIC- WE'VE ALL
WATCHED WITH WITH HORROR AND
OUTRAGE AS HAVE MANY OF HER
CONSTITUENTS ON THE MYRIAD WAYS
IN WHICH CALIFORNIA'S
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT HAS FAILED
CALIFORNIA- ONE OF THE MOST
EGREGIOUS EXAMPLES OF THIS HAS
BEEN THE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN FRAUDULENT CLAIMS
THAT HAVE BEEN PAID OUT ADD TO.
CART SHOULD INMATES WERE NOT
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE THESE
BENEFITS FIVE THE STATE AUDITOR
POINTED OUT IN A RECENT AUDIT
REPORT THAT HE D. LET
THEMSELVES ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE TO THIS TYPE OF
FRAUD BECAUSE THERE WAS NOT A
REGULAR AND CONSISTENT PROCESS
FOR CHECKING UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE CLAIMS AGAINST INMATE
RECORDS. AT THIS BILL IS GOING
TO CLOSE THAT CRITICAL GAP IT
IS A SIMPLE AND COMMONSENSE
STEPS TO STOP FRAUD AND ENSURE
WE'VE GOT THE RESOURCES TO
DIRECT TO CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
MOST AT NEEDS OUT WITH THAT
HAPPY TO WELCOME. I ASSISTANT
JUST ATTORNEY. YOUNG FOR
TESTIMONY. BURKE IF MISSION
THANK YOU FOR CALLING HER.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LESLIE YOUNG ORANGE COUNTY
ASSISTANT DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN
CHARGE OF MAJOR FRAUD ON BEHALF
OF DISTRICT ATTORNEY TODD
SPITZER I STRONGLY URGE AN AYE
VOTE ON AB ONE TEN. IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
SPENCER DIRECTED THE MAJORITY
OF OUR FRAUD UNITS RESOURCES BE
USED TO INVESTIGATE AND
PROSECUTE FRAUDULENT
APPLICATIONS FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS BY INMATES IN
CALIFORNIA PRISONS. OUR OFFICE
UNCOVERED MILLIONS IN
FRAUDULENT UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS PAID TO THE INMATES
COCONSPIRATORS IN ORANGE COUNTY
ALONE WE FILED MULTIPLE FELONY
CHARGES AGAINST EIGHT
INDIVIDUALS IN THESE GAMES. BUT
DESPITE NUMEROUS BANK SEARCH
WARRANTS AND OTHER
INVESTIGATIVE EFFORTS TO
FRAUDULENTLY DIVERTED FUNDS HAD
VANISHED ALTHOUGH WE ANTICIPATE
OBTAINING RESTITUTION ORDERS ON
BEHALF OF THE EDT. THE REALITY
IS THAT MOST IF NOT ALL OF THAT
MONEY WILL NEVER BE RETURNED TO
TAXPAYERS. DURING OUR EXTENSIVE
INVESTIGATION WE LEARNED THAT
THESE EIGHT SUSPECTS ARE JUST
THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG OF A
RAMPANT STATEWIDE FRAUDULENT
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS THE GAME
INVOLVING STATE PRISONER
APPLICANTS. HAD A MECHANISM
THAT IN PLACE TO BLOCK THIS
MONEY FROMDISTRIBUTION TO
INELIGIBLE PRISON INMATES.
UNTOLD MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
BENEFITS WOULD HAVE BEEN SAFE
GUARDED AND THOUSANDS OF HOURS
OF INVESTIGATIVE RESOURCES
DEVOTED ELSEWHERE. AB ONE TEN
IS A COMMON SENSE SOLUTION TO
THIS PROBLEM AND IT'S
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL IN
MINIMIZING THE LOSS OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TO FRAUD. UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS MUST BE AVAILABLE TO
HELP OUT OF WORK CALIFORNIANS
NOT TO ENRICH INCARCERATED
CRIMINALS AND THEIR ASSOCIATES
WE THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION AND
STRONGLY URGE AN AYE VOTE. ON
AB ONE TEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THAT WAS THE PRIMARY WOULDN'T
SINCE SUPPORT NOW WILL GO TO
THE CHAMBER BUT BEFORE WE DO
THAT- COUNTY KILLING ITSELF
QUORUM. BRADFORD PRESENT EFFORT
HERE CHAU BOTH HERE TROUBLED
HERE COM LONGER KAMLAGER HERE
SKINNER WINNER ACCORDING TO. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT AND- EVEN
BEFORE WE SEE IF THERE'S ANY
TESTIMONY HERE IN THE CHAMBER
LET'S DISPENSE OF. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE CAN DO THAT IF. YOU
CAN GET A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. IT'S BEEN PROPERLY
MOVES ACCOUNT SO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON CONSENT CALENDAR
THE FIRE FILE FIVE ITEMS THAT
WE HAVE THERE. BRADFORD HI
BRADFORD AYE CHOI BOGUE I KNOW
BOAKAI COM LONGER AYE UNLOCKER
AYE SKINNER WINNER. BELIEVE THE
ROLE OPEN ON THE CONCERN KELLER
NOW WILL GO TO FORTY TWO OLD
THREE AND SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
THIS IS HERE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF AB ONE
TN. SHINO ONE MOVING NOW WILL
GO DOWN. TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM
AND IT'S JUST. IS EMPTY AND
LONELY IS A- RIGHT NOW LET'S GO
TO. AND SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
NOW WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF. AB ONE TEN.
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
CHECK POINT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THE END ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE AT
CURRENTLY THREE PEOPLE QUEUED
UP TO GIVE COMMENTS LINE ONE
HUNDRED FOR YOUR BIKE IS OPEN.
I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT. AB ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ACTION. THE BILL
WE'RE IN AB ONE TEN. ALAINA ALL.
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
LUCIA MUTCHLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
ONE CAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALL. BLIND OF ONE HUNDRED
THIRTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR NUMBERS ROBERT MUCH OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN STRONG SUPPORT IS
BUILT UP THE DRESS YOU ACROSS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE. ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO. LINE ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
WE LOST ONE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME.
CREEP BROWN NOW WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO HARM
FORMAL OPPOSITION LISTED HERE
ON THIS BILL. WILL GO TO THE
CHAMBERS- ANYONE PRESENT HERE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION AB ONE CHAN. ALL
RIGHT THOSE GROUNDS TO THE
MICROPHONE SOMEBODY'S MOVING TO
NOW WILL LOOK. ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. NO ONE THERE AS WELL NOW
MODERATE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES INTO THURSDAY MORNING Q.
IN OPPOSITION OF AB ONE TEN.
FOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
AB ONE TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO COMMENTS
COMING THROUGH AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE IT BACK TO
THE COMMUNITY BRING IT BACK TO
HIS OR ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS AS IT RELATES TO AB
ONE TEN. CINECOLOR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN APOLOGIES FOR
COMING IN A LITTLE LATE- I SO I
DO I HAVE AND WE SAW A TO THE
CHAIR WE SAW A SIMILAR BILL. ON
EIGHTY D. FRAUD- IN SB THIRTY
NINE GROW BY BELIEVE- AND SO.
IN MY READING OF THIS BILL IT
SEEMS LIKE THIS BILL GOES
FARTHER THAN SB THIRTY NINE IN
TERMS OF ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION OF THOSE FOLKS WHO
ARE INCARCERATED AND SO
WONDERING IF THE AUTHOR CAN
SPEAK TO THE NEED FOR THAT
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO BE-
COLLECTED AND SHARED BECAUSE I
THINK IN THIS COMMITTEE THERE
WAS A LOT OF DISCUSSION AROUND
WHAT WAS APPROPRIATE- FOR-
FIVE. FEET EIGHTY TO COLLECT-
AND TO SHARE WITH CDCR AND VICE
VERSA. HELLO AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION YES I AM PLEASED
TO SAY THAT STOPPING YOU I
FRAUD IS BOTH A BICAMERAL AND
BIPARTISAN PUSH ARE WHICH I
THINK IS A GOOD THING. IN TERMS
OF AS THE ADDITIONAL DATA
THAT'S BEING COLLECTED WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON THAT
AMENDMENT AND- THE REASON THAT
WE ARE COLLECTING AS ADDITIONAL
DATA ELEMENTS REALLY TO ENSURE
THAT WE- DON'T CATCH ANYONE IN
A CERTAINLY IN THE SNACK RIGHT
THE ONE OF THE- THINGS WE WANNA
MAKE SURE WE AVOID. IS THAT WE
DECLINE A CLAIM INSURANCE CLAIM
FOR SOMEBODY THAT'S A VALID
CLAIM MEANT AND CITIES
ADDITIONAL DATA ELEMENTS WILL
ENSURE THAT ODD THAT THE CROSS
CHECK IS ACCURATE WHEN IT'S
BEING IMPLEMENTED- A COUPLE OF
OTHER. THINK DISTINCTIONS AS
WITH SENATOR GROVES BELL FIVE
WE ARE GOING TO BE UPDATING I
THE FIVE WE'RE GONNA BE SHARING
INFORMATION EVERY THIRTY DAYS
RATHER THAN EVERY NINETY DAYS
AND AGAIN THAT'S TO ENSURE
THAT. ITS CURRENT RIGHT IF
SOMEONE IS NO LONGER
INCARCERATED IN ELIGIBLE FOR
THESE BENEFITS WE WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THEY GET THEM ON IN
ADDITION WE WILL BE AUTOMATING
THE PROCESS. OR WILL DOUBLE BE
ASKING EIGHTY D. TO AUTOMATE
THE PROCESS BY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE WHICH I THINK IS
IMPORTANT AS WELL TO ENSURE.
DATA DATA INTEGRITY AND
SECURITY. THANK YOU- SO I'M
PROBABLY NOT GONNA BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY I
THINK THAT- I HAVE REAL
PROBLEMS WITH CDC ARE I DON'T
THINK THAT'S- AS A SURPRISE TO
ANYONE. AND CREATING THESE
KINDS OF- COLLABORATIONS WHERE
CDCR INTO BECOMING AN ADJUNCT-
EDT AGENCY IS CONCERNING FOR ME
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE NOT A FEW
MONTHS AGO CDCR- LISTED SOMEONE
IS BEING PRESENT AND ALIVE WHO
HAD BEEN DECAPITATED IN THE
CELL FOR MULTIPLE MULTIPLE
HOURS AND SO OFFICIALLY BE THAT
CAN'T EVEN. ACCURATELY IDENTIFY
SOMEONE AS BEING ALIVE OR NOT
TO THEN ASK THEM TO TAKE ON
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES
LIKE SIFTING THROUGH THIS KIND
OF INFORMATION- IS REALLY
CONCERNING TO ME JUST BECAUSE I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE
APPROPRIATE CHECKS AND BALANCES
IN- CDC. AND I'M MUCH MORE
INTERESTED IN FIGURING OUT HOW
WE CAN HAVE EDT DO ITS JOB
PROPERLY RATHER THAN ATTACHING
IT TO ALL OF THESE OTHER-
DEPARTMENTS. IN AN EFFORT- TO
MAKE SURE THAT CLAIMS GET OUT-
THAT ARE LEGITIMATE TO THOSE
PEOPLE WHO DESERVE IT. AND I
ALSO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THIS
FALSE NARRATIVE THAT MOST OF
THE FOLKS WHO STOLE MONEY WHERE
PEOPLE WHO ARE INCARCERATED I
JUST PULLED UP AN ARTICLE- THAT
MENTIONS OVER A HUNDRED IN ONE
PARTICULAR CASE. OVER ONE
HUNDRED OF THE FOLKS WHO- WERE
INVOLVED IN THIS WAR FOLKS WHO
ARE CURRENTLY INCARCERATED AND
WITH THE VICTIMS OF IDENTITY
FRAUD. IN FACT YOU HAD FOLKS ON
THE OUTSIDE WHO WERE THE REAL
PERPETRATORS USING THE
IDENTITIES OF FOLKS WHO WERE
INSIDE AND COLLECTING MONEY IN
THEIR NAME- AND THEY HAD
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO DO WITH
IT BUT WE HAVE ALLOWED THIS
NARRATIVE. TO COME OUT AND
SPREAD THAT SAYS ALL THE FOLKS
WHO ARE INSIDE WITH THE
MAJORITY OF THE FOLKS WERE
INSIDE WERE THE MASTERMINDS
BEHIND THIS. AND IT'S- THEY
HAVE NO WAY. OF SAYING THAT
THAT IS FALSE BECAUSE NO ONE
BELIEVES THEM ANYWAY BECAUSE
THEY'RE IN PRISON. AND I WANT
US TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO MAKE
GOVERNMENT WORK BETTER. WITHOUT
CREATING SCAPEGOATS OUT OF
FOLKS WHO ARE ALREADY YOU KNOW
IN PRISON- AND I WOULD LIKE FOR
US TO FIND SOME ADDITIONAL
SAFEGUARDS TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
WITHOUT REALLY SORT OF-
CONTINUING TO. SHARE PRIVATE
INFORMATION- BECAUSE WE CAN'T
FIX AN ISSUE THAT WE SHOULD BE
FIXING WITH ANY D. D. AND SO
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN MAKE IT A LITTLE CLOSER- TO
THE GROVE BILL THAT WE ACTUALLY
SPENT QUITE A BIT OF TIME
DISCUSSING IN THIS COMMITTEE-
BECAUSE IT SEEMED TO ME THAT
THAT BILL MADE. STRUCK THE
RIGHT BALANCE IN TERMS OF
REQUESTING INFORMATION AND
HAVING THE CHECKS AND BALANCES
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE MAY BE
DISCUSSED BEFORE THIS GETS TO
THE FLOOR- THAT. I'D LIKE TO
SEE THAT HAPPEN. THANK YOU FOR
THOSE COMMENTS SENATOR LET ME
JUST RESPOND TO IT BECAUSE A
COUPLE OF THE POINTS YOU'RE A
STATE I THINK ONE OF THE MOST.
IMPORTANT POINT YOU RAISE IS
THAT YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IN MANY OF THESE CASES. THE
INMATES NAMES WERE BEING USED
TO FILE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
CLAIMS NOT BITE AND MAKE
THEMSELVES BUT BY ORGANIZED
FRAUD RINGS THAT WERE. OUTSIDE
TO. THE INMATES WERE THEMSELVES
VICTIMS AS YOU SAID IT IDENTITY
THEFT AND SO THAT. IS ALSO.
WHAT THIS BILL WILL PREVENT. IS
ENSURING THAT. WHETHER IT'S
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
INCARCERATED OR SIMPLY
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE NAMES ARE
BEING UTILIZED THAT WE'RE NOT
PAYING OUT FRAUDULENT CLAIMS IN
THE NAMES OF INCARCERATED TO
CALIFORNIANS- AND THEN THEY THE
SECOND POINT THAT YOU MENTIONED
AROUND CDC OURS. S. DATA DATA
MANAGEMENT AND OTHER ISSUES I
THINK THAT'S ALSO AN IMPORTANT-
AN IMPORTANT POINT AND MY TEAM
AND I'VE BEEN WORKING REALLY
CLOSELY WITH AT LEGAL AID AT
WORK AND WITH THE ACLU ON ODD
AND HAVE INCORPORATED THEIR
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE SRIKING THE RIGHT
BALANCE THAT WE DO TO YOUR
POINT HAVE APPROPRIATE CHECKS
AND BALANCES IN PLACE SO AS YOU
MAY BE AWARE THAT CHAD EARLIER
IN THE PROCESS THEY WERE OPPOSE
I THINK THAT THAT THIS BILL.
INTO THE GROWTH VEHICLE NOT
SURE WHERE THEY ARE ON HERS
BUT- BECAUSE OF THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE HAVE TAKEN THE WORK
WE'VE DONE BY THE HAVE HAVE
MOVED TO A NEUTRAL POSITION ON
NOT. ON THE SPOT. I WOULD HOPE
THAT THE IS WHAT SOME OF YOUR-
AS WELL- NEED ADDITIONAL QUICK
COMMENTER CONCERNS AS IT
RELATES TO THIS MATTER. I TO
JUST WANNA THIS STATE MY
CONCERNS ARE WITH CDC ARE BEING
ABLE TO CONDUCT THIS
INVESTIGATION AGAIN I THINK THE
REAL CHALLENGES WITH A STATE IT
WOULD EIGHTY D. BUT WE WOULD
HOPE THAT YOU TAKE TO WORDS- BY
SENATOR COM MARTYR. AND AS IT
MOVES FORWARD FIND A WAY TO
COLLEGE. HONI THE END TO WE CAN
BE A LITTLE BIT MORE SPECIFIC
IN. ACHIEVING THE GOALS H. I
KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO REACH
YOUR WITH THIS MEASURE SHOW
WITH THAT NOTE- WE HAVE A TO
PASS A RE REFER TO LABOR-
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT.
AND RETIREMENT AND WE'RE
SEEKING A MOTION ON AB ONE TEN-
SO MOVED IT'S BEEN MOVED.
CANCEL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
AB ONE TEN AB ONE TEN TO PASS
TO LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RETIREMENT BRADFORD ON BRADFORD
I'D CHOI BOGUE I TROUBLE GUY
COM MARKER. KAMLAGER NOT VOTING
SKINNER WINNER LOU THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD
ON THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WE'RE WAITING FOR ANOTHER
AUTHOR SHARE AND WE GET A
MOTION ON A. B. THIRTEEN NINETY
ONE BY SOMEONE CHAO. THIS IS
JUST VOTE ON. WE CAN GET A
MOTION FOR ALMOST ALMOST.
PICTURE WE HAVE A MOTION AGAIN
THIS IS VOTE ONLY- AND I WILL
LIST THE AMENDMENT- THE AUTHORS
AGREE TO TAKE AMENDMENTS THAT
CLARIFY THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS CAN ADOPT
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS AND
STANDARDS RELATED TO THE
PURCHASE USE AND REPORTING A
MILITARY EQUIPMENT BY LOCAL LAW.
ALEXI I'M SURE THAT'S TRUE YES
I AM I'M- I'M- I'M SORRY I'M
I'M RETIRED I KNEW THAT DIDN'T
SOUND RIGHT AND I'VE DONE THIS
THIS BILL THE TO A MOMENT OR
DISK IN CAN LAST WEEK YES OKAY
EVEN ME THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
TAKE SOME ADDITIONAL MOMENTS TO
REMOVE ALL THE OPPOSITION. AND
THEY'LL TAKE IT IN NEXT
COMMITTEE YES AND ARE. TAKEN
LAST WEEK ARE IN PRINT. IT GOES
TO THE FLOOR BUT THEY'VE AGREED
TO TAKE SOME MOMENTS ON THE
FLOOR WITH SOME OF THE OTHER.
BUT THEY TOOK THE MOMENTS WE
TALKED ABOUT LAST WEEK. I'M
SORRY I'M LOOKING AT CHIU SAID
JOBS. ALL RIGHT. CAN TO CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON. AB
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE AB THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE. BRADFORD ON RED FOR
DIETRO BOKE I PROVOKE AYE
COMMAGER AYE UNLOCKER AYE. WITH
THE MEASURE HAS ENOUGH VOTES
BUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO. GROSS
AB T. N. OLD THREE BY SENATOR
THàNH I MEAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ THANK L. A. M. THANK
YOU TERRY AND MEMBERS AB ONE
ZERO ZERO THREE WILL MAKE
INTENTIONAL THEFT OF WAGES TIPS
OR COMPENSATION BY EMPLOYERS
PUNISHABLE AS GRAND THEFT.
RIGHT NOW IF AN EMPLOYEE STEALS
OVER NINE HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS
FOR THEIR EMPLOYER DID LIKELY
END UP GOING TO JAIL. BUT NOT
THE OTHER WAY AROUND FOR FAR
TOO LONG BUSINESSES HAVE GOTTEN
AWAY WITH COMMITTING WAGE THEFT
INTENTIONALLY AND STEALING FROM
THE WORKERS ALL WHILE FACING
NOTHING MORE THAN A SLAP ON THE
WRIST A SMALL FINE. HOWEVER
WAGE THEFT IS A SERIOUS CRIME
MINIMUM WAGE VIOLATIONS ALONE
COST THIS COUNTRY FIFTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
COMPARED TO TWELVE BILLION
LOSSES FROM ROBBERIES BURGLARY
AND AUTO THEFT COMBINED THIS IS
HARDER MONEY THAT BELONGS TO
WORKERS MONEY THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN MADE. THE DIFFERENCE FOR
FAMILIES DECIDING BETWEEN
BUYING GROCERIES OR PAYING
OTHER BILLS. BUT TO BUSINESS
IT'S SOMETIMES JUST A WAY TO
SAVE MONEY INCREASE THEIR
PROFITS WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
EMPLOYERS MAKING ACCIDENTAL
PAYROLL MISTAKES WERE TALKING
ABOUT PLAYERS MAKING CALCULATED
RISKS TO STEAL. BECAUSE IT'LL
RESULT IN MINOR FINES OR CIVIL
PENALTIES WHICH CAN BE ACTUALLY
LESS THAN PAYING THE WORKER
WHAT THEY'RE OUT. WITH THE
CONSEQUENCES COMPANIES FACE ARE
LESS SEVERE THAN THE CRIME
ITSELF IT'S NO WONDER THE
COMMISSION WAIT SEVEN OFF IS
OFTEN A BUSINESS DECISION TO
BASED EMPLOYERS BOTTOM LINE.
THIS BILL WILL DETER BAD ACTORS
FROM COMMITTING WAGE THAT TO
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT PROSECUTORS
CAN GO AFTER EMPLOYERS WHO
INTENTIONALLY STEAL FROM THE
WORKERS. THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAMBER AND
HAS- THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HAS REMOVED ITS OPPOSITION.
TODAY I HAVE THE CHAIRMAN- FOR
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
PEDRO NAVA CALLING INTO
TESTIFYING SUPPORT. MR NUMBER
WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON NOT SHERMAN BRADFORD
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M PAID
ANOTHER GERMAN A LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE ZERO ZERO
THREE THE COMMISSION IS AN
INDEPENDENT BIPARTISAN
OVERSIGHT AGENCY CHARGED WITH
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS TO
IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF STATE
GOVERNMENT IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WE
ISSUED A REPORT EXAMINING THE
INSIDIOUS UNDERGROUND ECONOMY
WHERE LAWBREAKERS CHEATING CUT
CORNERS TO GAIN UNFAIR
ADVANTAGE. THIS ACTIVITY HURTS
EVERYONE LONG TERM BUSINESS
OWNERS STRUGGLE TO STAY AFLOAT
AS COMPETITORS BENEFIT FROM THE
GLORY LOST INNOCENT WORKERS ARE
HARASSED AND DEMOTED THE FILING
UNFAIR WAGE CLAIMS AGAINST
UNSCRUPULOUS BOSSES AND
CALIFORNIA LOSES BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN TAX REVENUE BECAUSE
OF IT. YET PEOPLE PARTICIPATE
IN THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY
SIMPLY BECAUSE THE CRIME
ACTUALLY DOES PAY IN OUR REPORT
ENTITLED LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD BUT CALIFORNIA'S
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY OUT OF
BUSINESS WE FOUND THAT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF LABOR CODE
VIOLATIONS DO NOT INCENTIVIZE
VOLUNTARY COMPLIANCE THE
REWARDS OF BREAKING THE LAW
OUTWEIGH THE RISK TO CHANGE
THIS WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
ASSESS EXISTING PENALTIES. FOR
WHITE COLLAR CRIMES AND MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS TO ENSURE THAT THE
REWARDS OF BREAKING THE LAW DO
NOT OUTWEIGH THE PENALTIES
IMPOSED IF CAUGHT BREAKING IT
AB ONE ZERO ZERO THREE WE
pRECOMMENDATION BY MAKING AN
EMPLOYER'S INTENTIONAL FELT OF
WAGES PUNISHABLE AS GRANTS UP
WHEN COLLECTIVELY GREATER THAN
NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS
ON BEHALF OF THE LOOPER
COMMISSION I RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- SHERRY NOW WITH TO
THE HEARING ROOM TWO THIRDS
ANYONE HERE AND FORTY TWO OR
THREE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT WE HAVE A WITNESS HI
KEEL STORED ON BEHALF OF SUMMER
STEPHAN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TEN OF THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL IN THE HEARING ROOM
LET'S GO TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM
IN TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE
THERE. MODERATE WILL GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES INTO IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN SUPPORT- AB T. N. O.
THREE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB
TEN OH THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE. ZERO. AN ONLINE AT
NINETY SEVEN YOUR MIKE IS OPEN.
INVESTORS ARE MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WHICH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION AND SCORE.
PICTURE THIS. AND MEDICARE
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. VERY INTERESTED TIME
NOW WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION AND
WILL FOLLOW THE SAME PROCEDURES
ARE I THINK THE LEAD. OUR
POSITION IS STEVE COLL LOCKER
AS THE CORRECT- IF HE'S READY.
YES THIS IS STEVE CATHOLICA CAN
YOUR RESEARCH TO TALK I'M SORRY
YES WE CAN. THAT'S OKAY I
MISPRONOUNCE IT THE FIRST TIME
ALSO- MY NAME IS. MY NAME IS
STEVE CATHOLICA REPRESENT THE
INDEPENDENT PHYSICAL THERAPISTS
OF CALIFORNIA WHERE MORE THAN
SIX HUNDRED MEMBER STATEWIDE
YOU ARE EACH OF SMALL BUSINESS
PEOPLE EMPLOYING AND PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE TO MANY THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS. WE UNDERSTAND
AND SUPPORT THE GOAL OF FAIR
WORKPLACE NO ONE TRULY GAINS BY
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF OTHERS WE
LIKE MANY OTHER BUSINESSES ARE
BEGINNING TO EMERGE FROM THE
HAVOC OF CODE ARE PROBABLY
NINETEEN OR STRUGGLING TO FIND
STAFF WILLING TO COME BACK TO
WORK. RAPID SMALL BUSINESSES
APPEAR TO. BEAR THE BRUNT OF AB
TENTH- THREE. AS OUR LETTER
STATED OVERSIGHT OF CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY AND SYMBOL
CONSEQUENCES ARE NECESSARY FOR
STATE START. HOWEVER IT'S OUR
POSITION AT THE GROWING RABBIT
TO THE LABOR LAWS- PLACING A
BARRIER SUSPICION BETWEEN
EMPLOYEES AND THEIR EMPLOYER
BEFORE THE RELATIONSHIP HAS
EVEN BEGUN. AS CALIFORNIA
BEGINS TO EMERGE FROM THE
STRANGLEHOLD OF COVERED
NINETEEN. DIED HAS TRULY.
COOLEY AND DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPOSED IMPOSED ON SOCIETY IT'S
OUR POSITION BUT THIS IS NOT
THE BEST TIME FOR COMPLICATING
WHAT IS ALREADY COMPLICATED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU RIGHT NOW WILL MOVE TO THE
HEARING ROOM- THERE'S WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION OF CHANNEL ALL
THREE HERE AND FORTY TWO OR
THREE. SHE NINE WILL GO TO
OVERFLOW ROOM AT TWENTY FORTY I
SEE NO ONE THERE AS WELL MARIE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES INTO
THIRDS WITNESSES IN Q. AND
OPPOSITION OF TEN ON THIRD. OR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TEN OH THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THIS
TIME. YOUR HONOR ALL RIGHT
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. IS THERE ANY MEMBER
HERE WITH A QUESTION ON AB TEN
OH THREE. ARM MIGHT BE A LUCKY
DAY IS FOR. NO COMMENT- I JUST
WOULD COMMENT ON THE FACT THAT-
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
WE KNOW THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS
WHO. DELIBERATELY TO- YOU KNOW
MANIPULATE AND TAKE THE WAGES
OF OUR WORKING PEOPLE IN OUR-
AND DOES DENY THEM WHAT IS DUE
LEóN AND IT'S NOT BY ACCIDENT
WE NOTES THE TIMES ACCIDENTAL
MISTAKES HAPPEN AND BOOKKEEPING
BUT ARE. THERE SOME FOLKS WHO
TRULY- WORKED AT THIS DELIVER
RELIEF TO- TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
MANY OF OUR FRONT LINE A HARD
WORKING EMPLOYEES- SO I COMMEND
YOU FOR THIS AND IF AT THAT.
PART TIME WOULD YOU LIKE TO
GIVE A CLOSE I JUST NOTE-
GIVEN OPPOSITION THAT WAS NEW
TO ME- THIS DOESN'T ADD ANY.
ADDITIONAL BURDEN TO BUSINESSES
THAT'S BASICALLY. EAT FOR
ACTUALLY AS CREATE A PROSECUTOR
MORE LESS RESTATES THE LIVE
SOMEBODY INTENTIONALLY STEALS
MONEY IT IT'S NOT. YOU KNOW A
PAGA CLAIM ARE HAVING SOME
MISTAKE. ACTUALLY STILL THE
MAIN EXAMPLES THAT WE HAD
PREVIOUSLY IN COMMITTEE- THERE
WAS A GUY WHO BY HIS EMPLOYER
WAS TOLD TO PUT INTO DIFFERENT
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS. AND
WHEN IT REACHED EIGHT HOURS- HE
WOULD PAY ON SECOND SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER SO HE WOULDN'T
HAVE TO PAY OVERTIME. THAT'S
INTENTIONAL WAGE THAT THAT IS
SOMEBODY TRYING TO- FORCING A
WORKER TO BREAK THE LAW IN
ORDER THAT THEY CAN PAY THEM
LESS THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
MINOR VIOLATIONS OF. LABOR LAW
THAT ARE UNINTENTIONAL AN
INCONSEQUENTIAL- AND I HAVE TO
RESULT OBVIOUSLY MORE THAN NINE
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS SO. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE ABOUT.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION TO THE COMMITTEE
ON LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT- TO HAVE A MOTION
THIS BILL. REMOVED IT'S BEEN
PROPERLY MOVED BY SENATOR
MITCHELL BALK. CANCEL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON AB TEN OH
THREE AB TENO THREE BRADFORD
ARE REDFORD I'D CHOKE I TROUBLE
GUY COME LONGER SKINNER WIENER
BELIEVES THE RULES COMPLY
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU SEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ THE
KEYONE MAKER CENTER. ART NOW
WE'RE GOING TO IT'S A MOVEMENT
CHIU AND HE HAS AB. FORTY
EIGHTY ONE. WHEN YOU'RE
PREPARED THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
A LET ME FIRST START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR ENGAGEMENT ON THIS BILL
AND I WANT TO JUST MENTION I'M
HAPPY TO- EXCEPT THE MOMENT
THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF. AND THE NEXT
COMMITTEE TO CLARIFY THAT THIS
BILL WILL NOT BE PREEMPTING ANY
LOCAL ORDINANCES. IN THIS AREA.
AB FORTY ONE WILL ESTABLISH
TRANSPARENCY BETWEEN LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR POLICE
DEPARTMENTS WITH REGARD TO THE
USE OF MILITARY EQUIPMENT. AS A
FORMER PROSECUTOR I KNOW THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN CALIFORNIA
OUR OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY. BUT IN A POST
GEORGE FOR A WORLD. WE NEED TO
CONSIDER HOW EQUIPMENT AND
TACTICS IMPACT THAT PARTNERSHIP.
OUR STATE HAS LED THE NATION IN
THE AMOUNT OF MILITARY WEAPONRY
OUR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
PROCURED. TO THE TUNE OF
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THIRTIES HAVE SHOWN A
SIGNIFICANT LINK BETWEEN THE
LEVEL OF SURPLUS MILITARY
EQUIPMENT AND WEAPONS OBTAINED
BY POLICE DEPARTMENT. AND THE
NUMBER OF POLICE SHOOTINGS.
THIS PAST YEAR CALIFORNIANS SAW
AN ALARMING RANGE OF EQUIPMENT
IN ACTION DURING PEACEFUL
PROTESTS WHEN POLICE SPRAY TEAR
GAS FOR MILITARY GRENADE
LAUNCHERS AND SHOT RUBBER
BULLETS. FROM ARMORED VEHICLES.
THE DECISIONS OF HOW TO DEPLOY
THIS SENSITIVE EQUIPMENT WERE
LEFT UP TO INDIVIDUAL OFFICERS
AT THE SCENE WITHOUT UNIFORM
PROTOCOLS. THIS BILL ASKS OUR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO WORK
WITH LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
GOVERNING BOARDS TO COME UP
WITH APPROPRIATE MILITARY
EQUIPMENT POLICIES THAT CAN BE
DELIBERATED AND APPROVED IN A
PUBLIC SETTING. THE PUBLIC HAS
A RIGHT TO KNOW WHEN AND WHY
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT BELIEVE
THEY NEED MILITARY CALIBER
EQUIPMENT. ESPECIALLY WHEN
PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE USED TO
PURCHASE AND MAINTAIN THAT
EQUIPMENT. AND AT THIS POINT
I'D LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESSES. YOUR TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES YOU HAVE ERICA SAYS
SPECIFICALLY IT SUCCESS WITH US
I'M SORRY. AND BRIANNA SWIFT
FULLER. I THINK WE HAVE CASEY
SHORT IN PLACE OF FIVE MRS
BENNIS. DR. WITH THE READY WILL
ALLOW THEM TO BEGIN WE'LL GIVE
YOU THREE MINUTES EACH.
HOPEFULLY THERE ON THE ALL DAY
I THANK YOU EVERYONE- I WAS
GOING TO LET YOU KNOW MY NAME
YOU CAN SHORT I AM THE FOUNDER
AND CEO OF THE NONPROFIT WE
STAND UNITED SAN DIEGO AND
ALSO- A MILITARY VETERAN OUR
MILITARY POLICE. I HAVE SERVED
THE UNITED STATES ARMY FOR OVER
TWELVE YEARS NOW I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE AND
THE TECHNOLOGICAL IMPORTANCE.
OF MAKING SURE THAT THERE ARE
LAWS IN PLACE TO STOP THE USE
OF MILITARY BY THREE. PEOPLE
PROTEST ACTUATION AS BEING BOTH
BY ORGANIZER TWO ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PROTEST INTELIGO
HISTORY. AND AMAZED AT. WITH
THE USE OF THE MILITARY WEAPONS
ADDED BECAUSE- WHOLE ENTIRE. OF
ANGER OF PEOPLE THAT WERE
ALREADY TURNING INTO WHETHER
WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO PEOPLE OF
COLOR ABOUT THE CRIME IN THE
UNITED STATES. I'M ASKING YOU
ALL TO PLEASE PRACTICE FOR THIS
BILL. ABOUT THE USE OF MILITARY
GRADE WEAPONS. WITHOUT ANY TYPE
OF BEARING OR ANY TYPE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. THANK YOU Q. IS
THERE ARE CERTAIN WITNESS. IN
SUPPORT. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN AREA. EARLY STAGE NAME
OR THE AFTERNOON. THANK YOU HI
MY NAME IS BRIANNA'S LIFE WORK
A GOOD AFTERNOON- COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO FOR
INVITING ME HERE TODAY I AM AN
ATTORNEY WITH BECAUSE NOBODY OF
THE NEEDLE AND I AM HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF WOMEN CONDITIONER
CALIFORNIA AS A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF. AB FOUR EIGHT ONE.
CALIFORNIA POLICE AGENCIES HAVE
BEEN MILITARIZING FOR DECADES
WITH LITTLE TO NO OVERSIGHT-
ONE PROGRAM THE TEN THIRTY
THREE PROGRAM. CALIFORNIA
POLICE HAD ACQUIRED HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
SURPLUS MILITARY EQUIPMENT
INCLUDING MINE RESISTANT AMBUSH
PROTECTED VEHICLES. UNMANNED
GROUND VEHICLES ASSAULT RIFLES
AND NIGHT VISION SNIPER SCOPE.
OTHER FEDERAL PROGRAMS DON'T
REQUIRE ANY REPORTING BUT A
CATALOG WITH EVERYTHING FROM
ARMORED VEHICLES NIGHT VISION
GOGGLES. WHO IS THE ENEMY
POLICE ARE TRYING TO COMBAT. A
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN STUDY
FOUND MILITARIZED POLICE FORCES
WERE MOST OFTEN DEPLOYED IN
BLACK COMMUNITIES EVEN AFTER
CONTROLLING FOR PRIMARY AND
SEVERAL STUDIES FOUND
SIGNIFICANT CORRELATION BETWEEN
INCREASED POLICE MILITARIZATION
AN INCREASED POLICE TELLING.
ALL THIS HARM THERE IS NO
BENEFIT. STUDY SHOW POLICE
MILITARIZATION FAILED TO REDUCE
CRIME FAILED TO ENHANCE OFFICER
SAFETY AND FAILED TO SUPPORT A
PUBLIC TRUST AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AB FOUR EIGHT ONE
PRESENTS AN EASY FIX. POLICE
AGENCIES ALREADY REPORT
INFORMATION ABOUT PLANNED
PURCHASES DURING THE ANNUAL
BUDGET REVIEW PROCESS. THIS
BILL SIMPLY REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
DETAIL ABOUT THE EQUIPMENT
THOUGHT AS WELL AS THE USE
POLICY BEFORE POLICE CAN BRING
THE MOST EXTREME FOR LIKE
EQUIPMENT INTO OUR COMMUNITY.
THIS IS A MINIMAL ASK OF OUR
PUBLIC SERVANTS. POLICE MAY
CLAIM THEY NEED THIS EQUIPMENT.
JUST SAYING THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE PUBLIC
SHOULD HAVE A VOICE IN THE
PROCESS. AB FOUR EIGHT ONE IS A
COMMON SENSE SOLUTION TO
ADVANCE RACIAL JUSTICE REDUCE
POLICE VIOLENCE AND INSERT
BASIC TRANSPARENCY MEASURES.
ALL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
INCLUDING THOSE HEADED BY
ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE SUBJECT
TO OVERSIGHT. THE BASIC
PRINCIPLE OF GOVERNMENT MUST BE
IMPLEMENTED WITH REGARDS TO
EQUIPMENT ORIGINALLY MEANT FOR
THE BATTLEFIELD. I RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHT ONE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK
YOU NOW WILL MOVE BACK TO THE
HEARING ROOM TWO THIRDS
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
EIGHTY ONE HERE AND TWENTY
FORTY TWO OLD THREE. SEEN ON
MOBILE WILL NOW GO TO THE
OVERFLOW ROOM OF TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NO ONE THERE AS WELL.
MODERATOR WOULD NOW GO TO PHONE
LINES TWO THIRDS WITNESSES IN
CHIU SUPPORT OF. FOUR EIGHTY
ONE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
EIGHT ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE. ZERO AND THAT LINE ONE
HUNDRED ELEVEN YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. WHITE. ONE HUNDRED
ELEVEN. REPORTER WE ALL COVERED
IN IT'S STRANGE WHAT IF. OUR
COUNTRY THAT- MODERATOR CAN YOU
CHECK INTO THIS INDIVIDUALS
GIVEN TESTIMONY WE CANNOT HEAR.
ALL WHITE. I'M SORRY THAT WELL
LET'S TRY TO LOCATE THE- AND
NOISE- INTERRUPTIONS ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. FIND YOURSELF WHICH A
LOT OF. ALL RIGHT I WENT AHEAD
AND- MUTED THEM- LINE ONE
HUNDRED YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. BY
AN EIGHTY NINE YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
INCENTIVES ANTHONY MARCHING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR EIGHT ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE-
BLIND. ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER
ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
FORTY ONE THANK YOU. YOU CANDLE
LIGHT. ONE HUNDRED FORTY FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE NUMBERS
THIS IS JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF
OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU. ONE ONE
HUNDRED FORTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE NUMBERS REBEKAH
MARKETS ON BEHALF OF THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN AND SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHTY ONE. BLIND ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON AUDIBLE CHAIR AND
ERIC MORSE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
ALL TO MAKE INDIA MARKET WHAT
THE COLOR WE'RE COSPONSORED AND
STRONG SUPPORT AB PORT ONE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. BLIND.
ONE HUNDRED FORTY SIX. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MICHAEL RAT
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN THE COUNTY OF
SANTA CLARA AND SOME MORE.
BLIND. ONE HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN.
REMEMBER IT OFF ON THE HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE. ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON NECESSARY
ON BEHALF OF THE NATION'S
TRUSTED IN STRONG SUPPORT. IN A
LIGHT. ONE HUNDRED. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. AND
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU NOW WILL GO TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE- ONE
LEAD WITNESS COREY SHELVES ALL-
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION WILL PROVIDE HIM
WITH THIRTY MINUTES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CORY SO THEY'LL ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO A BEFORE ANYONE.
AS A PRACTICAL MATTER THE
ACQUISITION OF MILITARY SURPLUS
PROPERTY OFTEN REQUIRES BIDDERS
TO RESPOND QUICKLY WITHOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE
LEGISLATIVE BODY REGARDING EACH
PURCHASE. EVEN IF THE BILL ONLY
APPLIES TO THE FIRST TIME
AGENCY SEEKS TO ACQUIRE CERTAIN
EQUIPMENT AB FORTY ONE STILL
SEVERELY DISADVANTAGES
CALIFORNIA AGENCIES IN THEIR
ATTEMPT AT A PARTICIPATION.
ADDITIONALLY THE DEFINITION OF
QUOTE UNQUOTE MILITARY
EQUIPMENT IN THIS BILL. WHICH
INCLUDES QUOTE MILITARY
SUPPLIES AND EQUIPMENT THAT
READILY MAY BE USED FOR
MILITARY PURPOSES REMAIN
EXCEEDINGLY FAST AND ALMOST
ASSUREDLY INCLUDES ITEMS
COMMONLY USED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. BE ON VEHICLES AND
FIREARMS. HOWEVER EVEN IF THE
MEASURE LACKED THOSE
DEFICIENCIES IN TERMS OF WHAT
EQUIPMENT INCLUDED WE REMAIN
OPPOSED. THE BILL INTERFERES
WITH THE ABILITY OF
INDEPENDENTLY ELECTED
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS TO
ACQUIRE EQUIPMENT AT A COST
SAVINGS FOR DEPLOYMENT FOR
REASONABLE LAW ENFORCEMENT
PURPOSES. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
GOVERNOR BROWN VETOED SB THIRTY
ONE THIRTY ONE A SIMILAR BILL
THAT DID NOT GO SO AS FAR AS
THIS TO REQUIRE GOVERNING BODY
APPROVAL. ANDIN HIS VETO
MESSAGE SHE STATED QUOTE THE
CURRENT LIST NOT ONLY INCLUDES
ITEMS ARE CLEARLY MILITARISTIC
AND STYLE. BUT MANY THAT ARE
COMMONLY USED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT DO NOT MERIT
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS FOR THE
ACQUISITION. IN MY VIEW THIS
BILL CREATES AN UNNECESSARY
BUREAUCRATIC HURDLE WITHOUT
COMMENSURATE PUBLIC BENEFIT MY
CANNOT SIGN IT. FOR THESE
REASONS MISTER CHAIR CS IS A
MUST RESPECTFULLY POSING BEFORE
ANYONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NOW WILL GO TO THIS HEARING
ROOM ARE THERE IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WAS TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR EIGHTY
ONE. RT COMMITTEE TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. NOW ALL RIGHT I CAN
SEE PART- AND TWENTY FORTY IS
THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
WHICH YOU KNOW WHEN THEY'RE NOW
LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES-
MODERATOR AND SHIFTERS ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION TO FORTY ONE. FOR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO A. B.
OR EIGHT ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AN ONLINE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE YOUR BIKE IS
UP. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
COLIN WITH ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION ACTUALLY TRYING TO CALL
IN TO GET SUPPORT SB FOUR EIGHT
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU CAN
LINE. ONE HUNDRED FORTY. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURKE BRANDED UP ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS ON THE V.
FORTY ONE SIR CALM WATER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- THROUGH THE
CHAIR DO IT ARE THERE ANY OTHER
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS THE ONLY PERSON
I HEARD ON THE PHONE WAS THE
GENTLEMAN FROM THE SANTA CLARA
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS BUT THEN
ALL OF THE OTHER FOLKS WHO ARE
LISTED IN SUPPORT FOR NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS. AND JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS SO I DIDN'T KNOW
IF THERE WERE ANY- FOR. LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT WERE IN
SUPPORT OF IT. AND THE REASON
WHY I ASK IS BECAUSE IT DOES
SORT OF- MOVE INTO THE SPACE OF
LOCAL CONTROL- SO JUST ENOUGH
YOU'VE GOTTEN ANY FEEDBACK FROM
THEM. SULUR SO WE HAVE NOT
GOTTEN THERE'S NOT SPECIFIC
FEEDBACK EITHER WAY BUT WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT PROVIDES
REAL LOCAL CONTROL TO
COMMUNITIES TO DECIDE WHAT
MILITARY EQUIPMENT- THEY WANT
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES SO AGAIN
THIS BILL. CREATES A PROCESS
FOR LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN A
TRANSPARENT WAY IN A PUBLIC
FORUM TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT ABOUT
WHAT IS PERMISSIBLE AND WHAT IS
NOT- AND- AND THAT'S
EFFECTIVELY WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT. THANK YOU IN ADDITION
SENATOR- TROUBLED. M. THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD AND I DO HAVE A
QUESTION BECAUSE I ALONG WITH
US IN A CALM LONGER OF ALSO
GOING IN THINKING ABOUT THE
LOCAL DESERT JURISDICTION AND
CONTROL. THE SENSE THAT. SH HOW
WOULD YOU RESPOND TO THE NOTION
THAT THAT SHERIFFS WERE
ELECTED- SHOULD HAVE THAT
CAPACITY- AND OF COURSE. AND I
UNDERSTAND YOUR YOUR- INTENTION
AS FAR AS CREATING A PROCESS
BUT- COULD NOT ALREADY BE IN
PLACE- IS NOT ALREADY SORT OF
AN OPTION FOR LOCAL JEUGD
JURISDICTIONS INCLUDING THE
CITY COUNCIL COUNCILS AS WELL
AS- THE SHARES IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT. AND THEY ARE
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND THE FOOD
THEIR COMMUNITY ELECT TO GUIDE-
IN IN VERY SPACES INCLUDING
THIS PARTICULAR ONE. SO LET ME
MENTION A COUPLE OF ASPECTS OF
THIS BILL- SO FIRST OF ALL THIS
BILL DOESN'T PROHIBIT ANY TYPE
OF MILITARY EQUIPMENT FROM
BEING OBTAINED BY ANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SO IF A LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY WANTS ANY
MILITARY TANK ANY MILITARY- ANY
FIREARM ANY OTHER SORTS OF
EQUIPMENT THEY CAN DO THAT- AS
LONG AS THEY HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THE GOVERNING
BODY- AND THERE'S A PUBLIC
PROCESS FOR THAT ADOPTION. WITH
REGARDS TO SHARE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THEY
ARE ELECTED LIKE ALL ELECTED
OFFICIALS. BUT WE ALSO HAVE A
PROCESS BY WHICH THE PUBLIC
THROUGH SAY THE BUDGETARY
PROCESS OF A BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WERE CITY COUNCIL.
WEIGHS IN ON WHETHER THESE ARE
EXPENDITURES THAT THAT MAKES
SENSE AND WHAT THIS BILL SAYS
IS THAT LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
SHALL CONCENTRICALLY HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION WITH A LOCAL
GOVERNING BOARD TO SAY THIS IS
THE TYPE OF EQUIPMENT. THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO USE WE WOULD LIKE
TO PURCHASE I AND TO HAVE THE
PUBLIC CONVERSATION AND IF. IF
THE CITY COUNCIL OR THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AGREES WITH THAT
THEY WOULD SET UP A PROCESS
BEFOREHAND SO THAT WHEN THE
OPPORTUNITY COMES UP FOR A
SHARE OF FOR A LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AGENCY TO PURCHASE
THAT EQUIPMENT FROM THE
MILITARY THEY CAN DO THAT SO.
WHAT WHAT WE ARE SAYING THOUGH
IS- WE'RE NOT NECESSARILY
PROVIDING UNLIMITED BLANK
CHECKS WITH ZERO TRANSPARENCY
ANSWER ACCOUNTABILITY PERCENT
OUT TO BE A PUBLIC PROCESS SO
THAT'S EFFECTIVELY WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT. AND RIGHT NOW
WITH CURRENTLY SAY AS YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER WITH- THAT.
COUNTIES AND SHERIFF'S THEY
DON'T OR LET'S JUST BE WITH THE
COUNTY PART OF IT. WITH REGARDS
THE COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
YOU'RE IN. YOUR OPINION THE
REASON THIS IS NECESSARY
BECAUSE THERE MIGHT NOT BE
AWARE OF WHAT CURRENTLY
ABSOLUTE IMPOSES THE ACT.
REALLY YES THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
WE ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THERE'S A PROTEST AND WEAPONRY
IS PULLED OUT. THE PUBLIC IS
SURPRISED THAT THEY DIDN'T KNOW
THAT THERE WERE THESE TYPES OF
ARMORED VEHICLES- THAT HAD BEEN
PURCHASED BY DEPARTMENT OR-
THAT A SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT MAY
HAVE CHOSEN. TO MAKE A DECISION
TO BRING IN EQUIPMENT OUT
WITHOUT THEIR KNOWLEDGE AND
THERE ARE NO. THERE OFTENTIMES
HASN'T BEEN A PUBLIC
CONVERSATION NOT ALL THE TIME
BUT BUT IT HAS HAPPENED. NOR
HAVE THERE BEEN ANY POLICIES ON
HOW CERTAIN TYPES OF MILITARY
EQUIPMENT SHOULD BE USED SO
PART OF WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT
IS ENSURING TRANSPARENCY
AROUND. WHAT'S PURCHASED BUT
ALSO PROVIDING SOME GUIDELINES
ON WHEN CERTAIN TYPES OF
WEAPONRY- HOW THEY CAN BE USED.
INTERESTING OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION SURVEYS ON THIS
MEASURE ARM ASSIGNMENT I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU ARE WE SHOULD
GET MORE I WISH IT WOULD BAN
THE PURCHASING OF THIS TYPE OF
EQUIPMENT AND COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE AS WHEN YOU'RE
SUPPORTER STATED THE ONLY PLACE
YOU SEE THIS TYPE OF MILITARY
EQUIPMENT IS IN BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES ARE IN POOR
COMMUNITIES I MEAN WHEN'S THE
LAST TIME YOU SEEN PARA
MILITARY. EQUIPMENT IN BEVERLY
HILLS ARE AROUND A OR A LOS
GATOS AREN'T ANY MORE INFLUENCE
NEIGHBORHOODS BUT WE CLEARLY
SAW LAST YEAR DURING ALL THE OF
THE GEORGE GEORGE FLOYD PROTEST
THE NUMBER OF BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE CONFRONTED BY SUCH
WEAPONRY WHERE DO WE SEE IT
EVEN ON JANUARY SIX WHEN THEY
STORMED OUR NATION'S CAPITAL
YOU SAW NO PARA MILITARY
EQUIPMENT BEING ROLLED OUT THIS
STOP THAT RIGHT IS NOW. ANGRY
MOB BUT WE SEE IT ALL THE TIMES
INDUSTRY TO LOS ANGELES AND- I
SEE NO NEED FOR IT AND- I'LL
LET YOU SEE LOCAL POLICING A
NUMBER TO HAVE CONFIDENCE AND
TRUST IT YOU SHOULD TREAT
PEOPLE IN APPROACH PEOPLE IN A
IN A HUMANE WAY A ROLLING TANKS
INTO POOR COMMUNITIES. ARE IN
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES OUT
IS A MESSAGE THAT OF RISK OR
KNOW I JUST. I'M I'M GET ON MY
SOAP BUT I YOU BRINGING THIS
FOR AND I- RE THINK WE NEED
TAKE HEED FROM WHAT YOU'RE TO
DO AND I ASK WHY DO WE NEED TO
PURCHASE A STEP OF WHEN WE GO
UNTIL LOCAL CAN WHO WERE NOT
ARM TO LEVEL OF YOU SEE AND
MORE TIME BATTLE SO- AFTER PER
TIME WILL LOOK. FOR MOTION ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU APPRECIATE
YOUR- THANK YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE AT IT AGAIN APPRECIATE
pTHE DISCUSSION ON THIS AN EGG
AND I AGAIN WANT TO REITERATE-
TO THE CHAIRS POINT THERE IS
NOTHING IN THIS BILL THAT BANS
ANY TYPE OF MILITARY EQUIPMENT
AS MUCH AS I THINK THERE MAY BE
COMMUNITIES THAT WILL WANT TO
IT SIMPLY SAYS THAT BEFORE A
POLICE DEPARTMENT OR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY OBTAINS HIS
EQUIPMENT. TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THE
APPROPRIATE GOVERNING BOARD ON
THE CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH
MIGHT BE PROCURED THE POTENTIAL
USES FOR THIS BECAUSE AGAIN AS
A TEACHER POINTED OUT WHEN
WE'VE SEEN THIS PAST YEAR THE
MILITARY GRENADE LAUNCHERS THE
ARMORED VEHICLES THAT SURPRISE
COMMUNITIES WHEN THEY ARE
BROUGHT OUT- IT IT PICKED A LOT
OF QUESTIONS ABOUT THE USE OF
SCARCE PUBLIC FUNDS AND- AND
THE APPROPRIATENESS OF HAVING.
A DISCUSSION HAVING
ACCOUNTABILITY HAVING
TRANSPARENCY THAT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT- WE HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION TO- TO. GO THAN
FINANCE WE'RE SEEKING A MOTION
ON AB FORTY ONE. IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SEN RECALL LONGER
COUNCIL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
A. B. FOUR EIGHT ONE AB FOUR
EIGHT ONE BRADFORD HI I PROVIDE
CHOI BOGUE NO FOR BOTH NOW CALM
LONGER. I AM I RIGHT. THANK IN
OUR WINNER. WE'LL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR UP TO MEMBERS
THANK YOU. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON
CHOOSE. WE HAVE A J. A. B.
SEVEN THREE ONE BY FAR QUE HAN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN YOU'RE
READY YOU MAY PROCEED. NUMBER
THE FIRST ONE I THINK IT'S A
FOR ALL THEIR WORK IN EXCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON
THIS BILL AB SEVEN THIRTY ONE
IS A GOVERNMENT EFFICIENCY
MEASURE THAT WILL REQUIRE
COUNTY SHERIFF'S TO COMPILE AND
SUBMIT DATA ON RECIDIVISM
REDUCTION PROGRAMS PROVIDED TO
INMATES IN COUNTY JAILS AND THE
SUCCESS RATES OF THESE PROGRAMS
IN REDUCING RECIDIVISM SINCE
REALIGNMENT WAS ENACTED IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THE ANNUAL
STATE BUDGET HAS FUNDED COUNTY
BASED PROGRAMS THAT AIM TO
REDUCE RECIDIVISM. THERE
THEY'VE BEEN CONDUCTED FOR A
DECADE INFORMATION ON THE
SUCCESS OF THESE RECIDIVISM
PROGRAMMING IS FRAGMENTED AND
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND IT IS
SIMPLY ILLOGICAL TO INVEST
EIGHT DOLLARS AND WE HAVE NO
IDEA IF THESE PROGRAMS ARE
ACTUALLY HELPING TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM OR IMPROVE LIVES IN
MARCH AN AUDIT OF ALAMEDA
FRESNO LA COUNTIES BY THE STATE
AUDITOR FOUND THAT COUNTIES
LACK PLANNING AND OVERSIGHT FOR
REALIGNMENT SPENDING IN OUR
HOLDING EXCESSIVE REALIGNMENT
SURPLUSES WHICH COULD BE USED
TO IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY AND
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR THE
INCARCERATED POPULATIONS. IS
INCUMBENT UPON THE LEGISLATURE
TO BRING FULL TRANSPARENCY TO
THESE PROGRAMS WE'VE SPENT OVER
SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN STATE
FUNDED HAVE VERY LITTLE
INFORMATION ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS
INVESTMENT. EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY
ONE OCURRE STANDARDIZED
EVALUATION OF RECIDIVISM
REDUCTION PROGRAMS AND PROVIDE
VALUABLE INFORMATION ABOUT
SUCCESS. THE DATA FROM THE BILL
WILL ALLOW US TO INVEST IN
PROGRAMMING THAT ACTUALLY WORKS
WITH ROBUST REPORTING INFORMED
LEGISLATION CAN BETTER MAINTAIN
PUBLIC SAFETY. REDUCE THE DIRE
IMPACT FOR INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS AND REDUCE LOCAL
CORRECTION OF COST SAVING THE
STATE MILLIONS IN TAXPAYER
DOLLARS. MY OFFICE IS ACTIVELY
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
TO DEVELOP CLEAR REPORTING
METRICS WILL GIVE WHICH WILL
GIVE THE LEGISLATURE THE
INFORMATION WE NEED. AS WELL AS
PROVIDE CLARITY FOR COUNTIES
AND HOW TO GATHER AND SUBMIT
THE DATA. TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS DEREK MORGAN OF THE
ELEVATORS AT BAKER CENTER AND
EXTORT OTON FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION. I
WILL GIVE YOU BOTH THREE
MANAGED FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. YOU
MAY BEGIN IN WHATEVER ORDER YOU
FEEL MOST. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
THE CARE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S DEREK
MORGAN AND ON BEHALF OF THE ALL
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS I
AM PLEASED TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS
BASIC ACCOUNTABILITY. AND
TRANSPARENCY. THREE YEARS AGO
THE ELEVATOR CENTER LED A LOCAL
GRASSROOTS CAMPAIGN THAT HAD A
VERY SIMPLE APPS ALAMEDA COUNTY
SUPERVISORS. APPROVED A
FINANCIAL IN THE FORMS ON IT
SANTA RITA JAIL. WATCH THE
CAMPAIGN IN RESPONSE TO SEVERAL
DISCREPANCIES WERE NOTICING AND
COUNTY JAIL SPENDING AS WELL AS
AN ALARMING RATE OF CIVIL SUITS
ALLEGING MISTREATMENT AND
ABUSE. FOR EXAMPLE THE JAIL
POPULATION HAD DECREASED BY
NEARLY HALF OVER THE COURSE OF
A DECADE. YET DURING THAT SAME
PERIOD THE SHARES BUDGET
INCREASED BY OVER 80% PUBLIC
RECORDS ALONG WITH DIRECT
COMMUNICATIONS WITH PEOPLE
INSIDE THE JAIL BASED VERY
SERIOUS CONCERNS OVER HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSES. LACKED AND THE
STREET BUT- EVEN DURING THE
HEIGHT OF THE PANDEMIC WALK
COUNTY FUNDS WERE ON LIFE
SUPPORT BECAUSE THE SHERIFF'S
BUDGET INCREASE. FIFTY BY OUR
JAIL XPANDING INHUMANE
ISOLATION POLICY WHERE PEOPLE
GET LESS THAN THIRTY MINUTES A
DAY TO BE OUT OF COUNTY JAIL
CELL. AMID THE LAWSUIT TO MORE
PEOPLE IN CUSTODY JUST THIS
YEAR THE DOJ INVESTIGATION INTO
JANET YEAH COUNTY JAIL FOUNDED
PATTERN OF. UNCONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO BUSINESS. HUMAN RIGHTS
ABUSES AND TO DIAL UP SERVICES
ESPECIALLY TO THOSE
EXPERIENCING MENTAL ILLNESS.
BURKE COUNTY OFFICIALS NEVER
APPROVED OUR REQUEST FOR JAIL
AUDIT AND TO DATE WE STILL
DON'T KNOW HOW TO DEAL SPENDING
A FUN. HOW CAN WE ACCEPT THIS.
I HIGHLIGHTS GENERALLY TO JAIL
IS A CLEAR EXAMPLE OF A JAIL
WITH VERY LITTLE TRANSPARENCY
OVERT FONG. BUT IT IS IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THIS IS A PROBLEM
ACROSS THE STATE. SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR INCARCERATED
PEOPLE ARE ESSENTIAL LIFE
SAVING INVESTMENT IN VALUABLE
TAX DOLLARS INTO PEOPLE WHO
WILL EVENTUALLY RETURN HOME TO
OUR COMMUNITY. THIS BILL
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS ON
THE BEST USE OF FUNDING AIMED
AT SERVICES TO SHOW
EFFECTIVENESS IN REDUCING
RECIDIVISM. FOR THESE REASONS
BILL BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS. OF COURSE. EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE AND WE URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO PASS THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NEXT DOOR DOES NOT BE
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDER ASSOCIATION AND
PARKING IS A VERY SIMPLE BILL
AND AT THE TOP OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE PUBLIC WHAT
THEY'RE SPENDING TAXPAYERS
MONEY ON AND WHAT RESULTED THAT
SPENDING THAT HAS BEEN PROVIDED
WE MAKE SURE THAT FUNDS
DESIGNED TO HELP REINTEGRATE
CALIFORNIANS ARE SPENT ON
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
DESIGNED TO DO THIS. AND THAT
WE KNOW THE RESULTS OF THAT
PRETENDING THAT THIS IS SIMPLY
AND REQUESTED THE SHERIFF'S BE
TRANSPARENT WITH HOW THEY'RE
SPENDING FIND DESIGNATED FOR
THAT PURPOSE. AND FOR THAT
REASON YOUR SUPPORT. RIGHT
BAGGINS OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES
SUPPORT NOW WILL GO BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
AT THERE'S ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF. AB SEVEN THREE ONE
NOW IS THE TIME I SEE NINE NOW
WILL GO TO. OVERFLOW ROOM IN
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE
THERE AS WELL. NOW MODERATE
WILL GO TO OUR PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN THREE ONE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN THREE ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE END
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE
ZERO. WHY NOT ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON NECESSARY ME ON
BEHALF VANISHING JUSTICE STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE ONE
LINE. ONE HUNDRED. HELLO THIS
IS LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE
TO WITNESS IN OPPOSITION WE
SHOULD BE A ONE LEAD ARE WITH
US IN OPPOSITION COREY CELLS
ALL WILL GIVE HIM THIRTY
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CORY CELLS
L. ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION.
AGAIN RESPECTFULLY OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. SHERIFFS ACROSS
THE STATE PROVIDE EANINGFUL
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING TO
JAIL INMATES WITH THE DESIRE TO
ENHANCE FORMERLY INCARCERATED
PERSONS REENTRY INTO SOCIETY.
AND TO REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT PEOPLE RE OFFEND
UNFORTUNATELY THE BILL IMPOSES
VAGUE AND BURDENSOME DATA
COLLECTION REQUIREMENTS WITHOUT
ANY GUARANTEE OF FUNDING TO
COVER THE BILLS COSTS. THE BILL
REQUIRES SHERIFF'S REPORT QUOTE
DATA ON EACH OF THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM PROGRAMS THEY
PROVIDE AND MAINTAIN THEIR
COUNTY JAIL FACILITIES ONE
QUOTE. THE SCOPE OF WHAT IS
SOUGHT BY THIS LANGUAGE IS
UNCLEAR AND LIKELY DEAL
DISPROPORTIONATE SAYS FROM THE
FIELD. WE IN THE BILL THE BILL
FAILS TO DEFINE THE TERM RE
OFFEND AND SUCCESS. OF THOSE
TERMS RELATED TO RECIDIVISM AND
OFFER PROGRAMS. ADDITIONALLY
THE BILL COULD BE INTERPRETED
AS REQUIRING COUNTY JAILS TO
ASCERTAIN FROM CORK'S OTHER
JAILS STATE PRISONS- INCLUDING
THOSE ENTITIES AND OTHER STATES
ABOUT INFORMATION PASSED TO
SUBSEQUENT ARRESTS OR
CONVICTIONS TO DETERMINE IF A
PERSON HAS RECEVIED. THIS WOULD
BE VERY EXPENSIVE THE PROBLEM
EXACERBATED BY THE FACT THE
BILL PROVIDES NO FUNDING BUT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS. THAT EVEN
IF THE BILLS ENACTED AS WRITTEN
THE DATA THAT COMES FROM THIS
BILL WILL VARY BY COUNTY. AND
WILL UNLIKELY BE USEFUL IN ANY
ATTEMPT TO MEASURE SUCCESS OR
BENCHMARK PERFORMANCE AGAINST
STANDARDS ARE OTHER COUNTIES
BECAUSE THE TERMS ARE DEFINED.
AND THE DATA THAT ARE
REQUESTED. JUST AREN'T CLEAR-
AND SO AGAIN WE UNDERSTAND- THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT WITH THE BILL-
BUT RESPECTFULLY WE DON'T
THINK- EVEN IF ENACTED THIS IS
GOING TO YIELD USEFUL
INFORMATION- AND SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU. GREAT NOW WILL COME
BACK TO FORTY TWO OR THREE
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO. SB SEVEN THREE I'M AB SEVEN
THREE ONE. YOU MAY TEST. MY
NAME IS SERGEANT CHILE'S
CHRISTIAN SALMON COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND WE
HAVE A SURE OF JOHN MCMAHON BUT
WE DO NOT OPPOSE THIS BILL BUT
WE DO SOME OF THE OF LETTER OF
CONCERN. AND OUR CONCERN
CONCERN FOR DOCUMENT AND I
LETTER THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION ARE
CONCERNED HERE IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE C. NINE WILL GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM A TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NO ONE THERE AS WELL.
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. SEVEN THREE
ONE. FOR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION
TO A. B. SEVEN THREE ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND
OUTLINED ONE HUNDRED FORTY YEAR
MIKE IS A. OUR MEMBERS BRENDAN
UP ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF'S IN OPPOSITION.
NEXT WITNESS AT AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
RIGHT WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS CENTER CALM WATER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT
TO THANK GOD FOR BRINGING THIS-
BILL FORWARD IN REFERENCING THE
AUDIT THAT- I ACTUALLY ASKED
FOR LAST YEAR THAT REVEALED
THE- MISUSE OF FUNDS IN THOSE
THREE COUNTIES AND IT WOULD IT
HAPPENED ACTUALLY BECAUSE
ADVOCATES- AN ENTITIES WITHIN
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HAD
BEEN ASKING FOR SIMILAR
INFORMATION AND HAD BEEN UNABLE
TO GET IT- I. DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THE GOAL OF THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IS TO MEASURE.
COUNTIES AGAINST OTHER COUNTIES
IT IS TO LOOK INDIVIDUALLY AT
WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH IN EACH
COUNTY AND TO FIGURE OUT HOW.
TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE BEING USED
AND IF THEY ARE BEING USED IN A
WAY THAT IS BEST MOST
CONSTRUCTIVE AND MOST EFFECTIVE
AND MOST EFFICIENT. WE
CERTAINLY CAN'T YOU KNOW. WE
CAN'T FIX WHAT WE CAN'T
MEASURE- AND I WE HAVE TO BE
HONEST ABOUT ALL OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT WERE ASKING- TO
BE WITHIN OUR JAIL SYSTEM- AND
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE DOING
THE WORK THAT WE WANT THEM TO
DO SO THAT'S- HOW I LOOK AT
THIS BILL. I JUST LISTENING TO
SOME OF THE TESTIMONY OF SOME
OF THE FOLKS IN OPPOSITION I
ACTUALLY SEE THIS IS KIND OF
BEING HIGHLY INDIVIDUALIZED PER
COUNTY AND WOULD HOPE THAT- YOU
KNOW- SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS
WOULD BE OPEN ABOUT. YOU KNOW
THE INTENT OF THE BILL AND THE
KIND OF DATA- THAT THEY'RE
LOOKING TO COLLECT SO I'M AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME I'D BE
WILLING TO MOVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SENATOR
OR CULTURAL BOOK. AT THE CHAIR-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- KIND I HAVE A
QUESTION WITH REGARDS TO SO- I
REPRESENT THE SCRIPT THE COUNTY
OF SAN BERNARDINO AND
RIVERSIDE- AND I'M AS AS WELL
AS LITTLE LITTLE PORTION OF LA.
BUT I WAS CURIOUS TO KNOW YOUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT FROM
SEVENTEEN KNOWN WHERE YOU ARE
IN THAT. IN IN ADDRESSING THOSE
CONCERNS. YOU SENATOR FOR THE-
SO I EAT YOU KNOW I COULDN'T
AGREE MORE WITH- MISTER SAYS I
LOVE IT SOME SHERIFFS TO
PROVIDE PROGRAM IS WORKING
REALLY GREAT AND WE WANT TO
KNOW IS WHICH PROGRAMS THOSE
ARE. AND SO WE HAVE. ASKED YOU
NOT RECEIVED ANY SPECIFIC.
DEFINITIONS THAT THEY WOULD
LIKE AND BUT I WILL SAY AGAIN
ON THE RECORD THAT WE INVITE
THAT CONVERSATION IF THEY HAVE
CLARIFYING LANGUAGE WE ARE OPEN
TO IT AS I MENTIONED IN MY-
OPENING REMARKS THIS BILL. I'M
IN SIMILAR FORM WAS PASSED AND
SENT TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
LAST YEAR AND WAS VETOED AND WE
ARE WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO FURTHER
CLARIFY DEFINITIONS ALTHOUGH. I
DO ARE WANT TO REITERATE MY
GRATITUDE TO THIS COMMITTEE AND
HELPING US TO FIND RECIDIVISM
WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY CRITICAL SO.
I INVITE THE SHERIFF TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION WITH
US. THANK YOU I'M AT THIS TIME
I AID DUE TO CONCERNS THAT- MY
COUNTY STAFF ON THIS ISSUE I.
WILL BE STAYING OFF ON AND
RESPECTIVELY STAYING OFF ON
THIS BILL AT THIS TIME. I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THE
CONVERSATION HOPEFULLY. YOU
FOLKS COULD FIND THAT. GROUND
WHERE- IT COULD BE SUPPORTABLE
BY BY MY COUNTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- I'M FINE THANK YOU
TO I THINK THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE MEASURE I DON'T SEE HOW
ANY COUNTY WOULD BE OPPOSED TO
PROVIDING. OF FACTS AS SOON
CENTER COMMERCE'S YOU CAN'T FIX
WHAT YOU CAN'T MEASURE SHOW-
COMPILING THIS DATA. WHAT WE'RE
GETTING FOR THE BANG FOR OUR
BUCK I THINK MAKES SENSE WE ALL
TALK ABOUT REHABILITATION WE
ALL TALK ABOUT- ANTI RECIDIVISM
SOUL IF YOU SEE IN YOUR PROGRAM
TO WORK AND DEMONSTRATED THE
PROOF IS IN THE BUTTON SO. IT
SHOWS THE DOT AND THAT'S ALL
THIS IS ASKING SIGN ACTUALLY GO
BEYOND IN THE WERE YOU ARE
TODAY JUST TELL US WHAT. WE'VE
BEEN INVESTING NOW TO WORKING
SO ON THAT NOTE- WE'RE SEEKING
A MOTION AT THE WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR COM AUGER. WE
HAVE A FEW. OF US TO FIFTH. AS
AMENDED AS AMENDED YES DO FOR
US AS AMENDED. TO
APPROPRIATIONS. OUR COUNCIL
PLEASE CALL GIRL AB SEVEN
THIRTY ONE. I MEAN IF SEVENTY
SEVEN THERE AND BRADFORD HI
I'VE HEARD I'D SHOW BOOK. A
TURBO DEVOTING COM LAGER I AM I
RIGHT. WE'LL LEAVE THAT MEASURE
ON CALL AND- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. ALL RIGHT NEXT UP
IS TO OUR MEMBERS- ALL WE HAVE
IS CALLED MISTER KALRA. THE
RECOGNIZE YOUR VECTOR. HE'S
PRESIDING A. B. TWO FIVE SIX.
THE PODIUM GEORGE WHEN YOU'RE
READY MISTER CAR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. DEAR MR SURE
MEMBERS LAST YEAR THIS BODY
TOOK A PROFOUND STEP FORWARD IN
ADDRESSING INSTITUTIONALIZED AN
IMPLICIT RACIAL BIAS IN THE
CRIMINAL COURTS BY EMPOWERING
DEPENDENCE TO OBJECT TO CHARGES
CONVICTIONS OR PUNISHMENTS.
BASED UPON RACE ETHNICITY OR
NATIONAL ORIGIN BY PASSED THE
CALIFORNIA RACIAL JUSTICE ACT.
ADDITIONALLY THE ACT OVERTURNED
A MORE THAN THIRTY YEAR LEGAL
PRECEDENT ESTABLISHING THE CASE
MCCLOSKEY WE CAN'T. KNOWN AS
THE MCCLUSKY DECISION THE US
SUPREME COURT HAD FOR TOO LONG
REQUIRED CALIFORNIA QUEMADA
PENDANTS IN CRIMINAL CASES TO
PROVE INTENTIONAL
DISCRIMINATION WHEN CHALLENGING
RACIAL BIAS IN THE LEGAL
PROCESS. THIS INSISTENCE ON
PROOF OF INTENTIONAL OR
PURPOSEFUL DISCRIMINATION
ESTABLISH A LEGAL STANDARD THAT
WAS NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO ME. IN
DISSENT JUSTICE WILLIAM BRENNAN
WROTE BUT THE DECISION WAS
DRIVEN BY A FEAR OF TOO MUCH
JUSTICE. LAST YEAR'S AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY TO THE CALIFORNIA
RACIAL JUSTICE ACT OVERTURNED
THE MCCLOSKEY PRESIDENT AND
ESTABLISH CALIFORNIA AS THE
FIRST STATE IN THE NATION TO
PROHIBIT THE STATE FROM SEEKING
OR OBTAINING A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION OR FROM IMPOSING A
SENTENCE BASED ON RACE.
ETHNICITY OR NATIONAL ORIGIN IN
ALL CASES. AB TWO FIFTY SIX IS
THE NEXT STEP TOWARDS EQUAL
JUSTICE ALLOWING THOSE WITH
PAST JUDGMENTS RENDERED PRIOR
TO JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THE ABILITY TO USE THE
PROTECTIONS OF THE ACT TO
PETITION THE COURT TO SEEK
POTENTIAL REMEDY INVOLVING
RACIAL BIAS IN THEIR CASE.
MAKING THE ACT AVAILABLE TO ALL
IS NOT ONLY THE MORAL THING TO
DO BUT IT IS ALSO ROOTED IN THE
FACT THAT CALIFORNIA HAS SEEN
SOME OF THE WORST RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN TERMS OF
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS AND
SENTENCES IN THE COUNTRY. FOR A
BLACK PERSON OVER EIGHT TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO BE INCARCERATED
THAN A WHITE PERSON. THIS IS
ONE OF THE WORST DISPARITIES IN
THE COUNTRY FAR WORSE THAN ANY
SOUTHERN STATE. BUT THE
INTERDEPENDENCE ARE MORE LIKELY
TO BE CONVICTED RATHER THAN TO
BE ACQUITTED FOR OTHER CASES
DISMISSED. BOTTLER DEFENDANTS
ARE MORE LIKELY TO RECEIVE A
FELONY VERSES A MISDEMEANOR
CONVICTION. COMPARATIVELY
DEPENDENCE BLACK MEN CONVICTED
OF A FELONY OR 42% MORE LIKELY
TO BE SENTENCED TO PRISON. FOR
THE WHITE MAN CONVICTED OF A
FELONY. THE MOBILE MAN
CONVICTED OF UNDER 33% MORE
LIKELY TO BE SENT TO PRISON.
THE TROUBLE. TRIP IN CONCERT
PEOPLE COLORED MUCH HIGHER
RATES THAN THE GENERAL
POPULATION. NEEDS TO BE
RECKONED WITH ON THE MECHANISM
MECHANISM TO RETRACTABLE ROOF.
AND THE CALIFORNIA RACIAL
JUSTICE ACT. SHOULD BE AFFORDED
TO ALL THOSE PASSENGERS. WITH
PASSENGERS THIS IS. ADDING
RETROACTIVE RELIEF TO THE ACT
AB TWO FIFTY SIX ALSO CONSIDER
THE WORKLOAD CONCERNS FOR THE
COURTS. BY SETTING A JUSTIFIED
REASON FOR THOSE ABLE TO
PETITION THE COURT FOR RETRO
ACT WILL LEAVE USING THE RACIAL
JUSTICE ACT. WE'VE ALSO BEEN
WORKING WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL SINCE THE ACT'S
IMPLEMENTATION. AND AB TWO
FIFTY SIX REFLECTS TECHNICAL
AND CLARIFYING CHANGES.
COLLEAGUES THE RACIAL JUSTICE
ACT FOR ALL ANSWER THE SIMPLE
QUESTION QUESTION. THE
PROHIBITING RACISM AND OUR
COURTS AND PROVIDING A PERSON A
MEANS TO REMEDY RACIAL BIAS AND
THEIR CASE IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO GOING FORWARD. SHOULD NOT
BE THE RIGHT THING TO DO FOR
EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF WHEN THE
JUDGMENT WAS WANT RENDERED. TO
ILLUSTRATE WHY WE NEED THE
RACIAL JUSTICE ACT FOR ALL
YOU'LL HEAR FROM WITNESSES WITH
FAMILY THERE ARE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCES. OF OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. FOR WHICH RACE
PLAYED A FACTOR IN. PERSON
WOULD BE JULIE RODRIGUEZ
BROTHERS WHO GO TRAVIS WAS
CURRENTLY IMPRISONED. AND
FIGHTING THE CASE OF A POWER
COURT. AND ECONOMIC TERMS ON A
MICHAEL MCCANN WAS ALSO
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED. FOR
PROSECUTORS ARE ABLE TO USE
RACIAL UNDERTONES IN THE CASE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YOUR
FIRST WITNESS MISS RODRIGUEZ.
PAUL MY NAME IS JOE IT'LL
BIGGEST BROTHER TWO ZERO TRAVIS
I'M JUST ME CONVICTED AND
SENTENCED TO MORE THAN A
HUNDRED YEARS OF LIFE FOR A
CRIME HE DID NOT COMMIT I WILL
BE READING A STATEMENT FROM YOU
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
BANDARI DIDN'T DIRECTLY CALL ME
BE YOUR LONG LIFE TRASH
IMMIGRANTS OR ANY OTHER RACIAL
SLURS. HE WAS ALLOWED TO DO WAS
MUCH WORSE YOUR TACK MY
UPBRINGING HISPANIC AMERICAN
CULTURE HE PAINTED A PICTURE
THAT PORTRAYED ME AND EVERYONE
ELSE LIVES IN OUR COMMUNITY
WHERE I GREW UP AS CRIMINALS AT
THE BEACH YOU GOT ALL OF THE
MORE IMMIGRANTS IS ON AMERICAN
WORKERS. MORE MOMENTS I
REMEMBER CLEARLY IS WHEN I WAS
ON THE STAND HE ASKED ME IF IT
HAD BOTH PRISON GAME CONNECTING
THE SPORTS ACTIVITY PLAYED BY
MANY HISPANICS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES TO CRIMINAL
BEHAVIORS MY COMMUNITY. WILL
CRIMINALIZE THE I'M A COMMUNITY
YOUTH CENTER WITH THE TICKET AS
A BREEDING GROUND FOR GANG
MEMBERS ONE PARTICULAR OFFICER.
USE AN EXPERT WITNESS FOR THE
STATE. YOU KNOW WHAT HISPANIC.
LOOKS LIKE CURRENTLY. LISTS ALL
INCOME DISCRETE WITHIN TO MAKE
A JUROR. FEAR FOR HER LIFE AS
YOU RECALL. FOR RECURRING. IN
THE AUDIENCE TO BE REMOVED.
FROM THE COURTROOM IT'S A
POSSIBLY BEING GANG MEMBERS
BASED ON. AYE SHE SAID GIVEN
THE NATURE OF THE DISH OF THE
TESTIMONY AND WE CURRENT PEOPLE
IN THE AUDIENCE THAT BASED ON
DESCRIPTIONS. OF WHAT GANG
MEMBERS LOOK LIKE. LOOK
POSSIBLY AS IF THEY'RE GANG
MEMBERS AND IT MAKES ME
UNCOMFORTABLE. THE RECURRING
PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE IS
GERMAN RECORDS TOO OR MY
BROTHER'S ONLY A HARD WORKING
FAMILY MAN. AND JOSE. IS
SUPPORTING COMMUNITY ADVOCATE.
SURE WHEN OFFICE SPACE HEY HAS
BEEN PULLED BACK ON A DIFFERENT
POPULATION AFTER CLAIMING TO
HAVE LISTENED TO EVERYTHING THE
ATTORNEYS AT THE STATE. THIS
HAPPENED WITHIN THE FIRST FEW
WEEKS OF AN EIGHT MONTH LONG
TRIAL. I DIDN'T STAND A CHANCE
AGAINST THE OBVIOUS RACIAL AND
SOCIAL PREJUDICE THE COURTS A
LOT OF MISTER PANDORA TWO
PRESENTS THE JURY. THERE ARE
MANY OTHER EXAMPLES OF RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION SOCIAL BIAS AND
I DON'T HAVE THE TIME TO
MENTION BUT I WILL CONCLUDE
WITH THE FOLLOWING. IT'S TIME
WE MAKE POLICY THAT PROPELS
MEANINGFUL CHANGE NOT FOR THE
LEGISLATION THAT SUPPRESSES THE
ISSUE OF THIS COUNTRY HAS
SUFFERED. FOR MANY YEARS ONLY
FOR IT TO RESURFACE CONTINUE.
TO PLAGUE OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
I IN MY CASE THE COURT ROOM
WHAT THE NATURE FOR RACIAL. AS
PUBLIC OFFICERS WERE LOCKED
STRATEGICALLY USE RACIAL
PREJUDICE TWO APPEARANCES
HIGHER. SOCIAL CLASS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF GETTING A CONVICTION
WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE LINKING.
TO THE FACTS OF THE CRIME
QUESTION THE FOURTEENTH
AMENDMENT OF OUR CONSTITUTION
PROHIBITS PROSECUTION BASED ON
PREJUDICE. THAT DIDN'T SEEM TO
APPLYING MY TRIAL DELAYS ARE
TRUSTED PUBLIC FIGURES THAT
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE THEY ARE
THEY ARE IN A POSITION OF HIGH
INFLUENCE OVER JERRY'S.
UNCHECKED RACIAL AND SOCIAL
PREJUDICE FROM THE DELAY IN
LONG COURSE YOU GAIN EXPERTS
DURING MY TRIAL LED. TO ME
BEING FOUND GUILTY WE MUST DO
OUR PART TO HAVE A SOCIETY THAT
IS FREE OF RACIAL SOCIAL
DISCRIMINATION. WE MUST FIND A
REMEDY TO NOT ONLY CREATE A
BETTER FUTURE FOR BOTH. ALSO
PROVOKED- BOTH. WHAT FOR A
BETTER FUTURE BUT ALSO CORRECT
PAST WRONGS MAKING THE RACIAL
JUSTICE ACT RETROACTIVE THE BIG
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU THE NEXT WITNESS.
MAKO. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS INIGO THE MERGING ON
AND IWILL BE READING A
STATEMENT ON BEHALF OF MY SON
WHO IS SERVING TO TWENTY FIVE
YEAR SENTENCES FOR A CRIME
COMMITTED WHEN THEY WERE JUST
BLOWING. MY NAME IS MICHAEL THE
MERGER AND I AM A HUMAN BEING
pIN THIS WORLD. I HAD MADE A
POOR CHOICE WHEN I WAS FIFTEEN
YEARS OLD IN THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND. WHICH I HAVE BEEN
PRAYING FOR THE LAST TWENTY ONE
YEARS. IN PRISON. I'M NOT A
MONSTER NOR EVIL. AT THE TIME
HAS A FIFTEEN YEAR OLD KID I
HAD LIED AND DENIED ANY
INVOLVEMENT IN MY CASE. BUT I
HAD FALLEN TO A WORLD OF
APPRECIATIVE BECAUSE THAT IS
WHERE ALL THEY WANTED WAS A
CONVICTION. I'M BY NO MEANS
RACES BUT THE TRUTH COMFORTABLE
MY CASE DID NOT GIVE ME A FAIR
TRIAL. STORAGE UNIT POOL OF MY
PEERS. EVEN THOUGH WE ARE ALL
GOD'S CHILDREN. A LOT OF PEOPLE
FORGET THAT. AND LOOK AT THE
SKIN COLOR BOTH VICTIMS IN MY
CASES WERE WHITE. IT BREAKS MY
HEART EVEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE THEY WERE MY FRIENDS.
WE DID NOT SEE COLOR BUT IN
COURT IT TURNED INTO A WHOLE
DIFFERENT QUORUM. I'M A MIXED
RACE AND HALF BLACK. MY OLD
CASE WAS BASED ON LIES AND
RACIALLY MOTIVATED TO GET THE
CONVICTION. AND TRIAL
PROSECUTOR CALLED MADE
TERRORIST I CAN PROVE
EVERYTHING BEING A FACT BECAUSE
IT IS ALL IN MY TRANSCRIPT
UNDOCUMENTED. EVEN HIRING
ATTORNEYS COULD NOT STAND
AGAINST MINES THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN MADE. RACISM REALLY EXIST
IN THE POWERFUL COURT SYSTEM
WHICH HAS BARRICADED HIMSELF
WITHIN ITSELF. TO ALLOW NO ONE
TO GO AGAINST THEM WOOD SLICK
WORDS AND LITTLE. THAT CAN BE
MANIPULATED TO FAVOR. HI
MICHAEL THE MERCHANT CAN
HONESTLY SAY I DID NOT GET A
FAIR TRIAL AND THE WILL TO DO
IT OR DID. AND WAS RACIALLY
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST. BOB GOES
OUT ALONG WITH MY PRAYERS TO
ALL PEOPLE ALONG WITH THE
FAMILIES. THAT HAVE PULLED INTO
BEING A VICTIM WILL CREATE
CRIME. BUT THERE'S ALSO PEOPLE
THAT MADE SOME WRONG CHOICES
WHEN THEY WERE YOUNGER AND THAT
FORMER VICTIM PROPOSED TO HIS
SYSTEM. OF RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION AND OVERLY HARSH
TREATMENT ALONG WITH SENTENCES.
THINGS ARE CHANGING BY THE
RATIONS BUT THE RACIST WAYS AND
THINKING NEED TO STOP. BOTH OF
THE PRISONERS REALLY HAVE
FALLEN VICTIM TO RESERVE THEM
FOR TREATMENT THAT SEND THEM TO
PRISON JUST BECAUSE OF THE
COLOR OF THEIR SKIN. I'M NOT
SAYING EVERYONE BUT I
PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED RACISM
DURING MY TRIAL AND FELL VICTIM
TO IT. PLEASE MAKE SB TWO FIVE
SIX ORIGINAL JUSTICE FOR ALL
RETROACTIVE SO THE TRUTH CAN.
BE SEEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU NOW LET'S GO TO WITNESS
HERE THE ROOM OR IN. OF AB.
TWENTY AND I'M SORRY AB A TWO
FIVE SIX. SEEN ON HERE WILL GO
TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM THERE'S NO
ONE THERE EITHER- MODERATE-
LET'S GO TO OUR PHONE LINES
INTO IF WE HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO FIVE SIX.
THANK YOU MEDICARE FOR COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO FIVE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE END
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. TEN LINE NINETY THREE OR
MY COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR TOUR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHUCK BRAMBLE I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND EDUCATORS THE MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. WE THINK OF
SOMEONE ON A COLOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR THE. BLIGHT A ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MY NAME IS
ASHLEY RAVISHING DEPUTY AREA
DIRECTOR SOCIAL POLICY FOR THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS TO
CALIFORNIA A CO SPONSOR TO
STILL READING OFF A LIST OF
SUPPORTERS TO HELP SAVE TIME
FOR THIS HEARING- IN IN
ADDITION TO THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS I WOULD LIKE TO INCLUDE
FELONY MURDER ELIMINATION
PROJECT. ON COMMON LAW. LA
COALITION FOR EXCELLENT PUBLIC
SCHOOL. TIME FOR CHANGE
FOUNDATION ONE JUSTICE WHITE
PEOPLE FROM BLACK LIVES.
INITIATE JUSTICE. SAN MATEO
COUNTY PARTICIPATORY DEFENSE.
ALL OF US OR NONE BAKERSFIELD.
UNITING FAMILIES CONTRA COSTA
THANK YOU SO MUCH OPERATIVE
COMMITTEE TAKING TIME TO HEAR
THIS BILL AND THEY GIVE SO MUCH
TO MISTER KALRA FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE EIGHTY NINE.
CALIFORNIANS IN ORDER BACK
EIGHTY TWO FIVE SIX THANK YOU.
AN OUTLINE. ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
GOING BACK INSPIRED ELLA BAKER
CENTER MORNING COME SPONSORS. I
WOULD LIKE. ME TO READ INTO THE
RECORD ORGANIZATION ASK US TO
NINETY NINE TODAY TRUMP POLICY
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER. CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR YOU CAN COMMUNITY
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION. MARK
GATISS CALIFORNIA. AND SOLITARY
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY BRUTON READ
OUT AMNESTY INTERNATIONAL USA
THE CALIFORNIA INNOCENCE
COALITION SAMBAR DINO FREE THEM
ALL AND FROM GANGSTER GLORY
OPPORTUNITY FOUNDATION THANK
YOU ALL IN SUPPORT. NEXT
WITNESS. ALAINA. ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MITCHELL SHARED MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO FIFTY SIX THANK YOU. A
LINE OF ONE HUNDRED SIXTY TWO.
CALIFORNIANS DR THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WHY NOT ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
MEMBERS JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT. BLIND. ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CURTIS PLAYING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT EIGHTEEN FIFTY SIX
THANK YOU. BLIND AND. NINETY
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
MEMBERS WILLIAM MARTIN BURKE ON
BEHALF OF PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. WHY NOT. ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS
KELLY AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF SILICON VALLEY DE BUG ALSO A
PROUD CO SPONSOR AB TWO FIFTY
SIX THANK YOU TO KALRA I WOULD
LIKE TO READ OFF A FEW OTHER
NAMES THAT ARE ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT. YOUR FAMILY IS UNITED
THROUGH AND TELL WHAT.
EMPOWERING PACIFIC ISLANDERS
COMMITTEE EPIC. YOUR JUSTICE
HONESTY INTERNATIONAL GROUP
THIRTY POUNDS OF FISCAL CHARGE
BAY AREA SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE. WHY WCA BERKELEY
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE FOR JUST AND
MORAL GOVERNANCE. NITECORE
pRESTORED ACUTE JUSTICE COURAGE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE FOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM AND ATTEMPTED TO
GO PUBLIC DEFENDER THANK YOU SO
MUCH. PINE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STAND TO
LOSE OUT ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
PINE. ONE TWENTY THREE. THEIR
NUMBER MY NAME IS ARGHA
ALBERTUS AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO. TWO FIVE SIX
THANK YOU. LINE. EIGHTY SEVEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME. HELLO
GO AHEAD PLEASE OKAY MY NAME IS
ANITA ALKA AND PONDWEED- THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WOMEN
PRISONERS TALK ABOUT CO
SPONSORS I'M ALSO READING OFF A
LIST OF ADDITIONAL POINTERS AND
I WILL BE THE PENINSULA MCCARTY
COALITION COMPRISED OF THREE
THE TRANSFORMATIVE IN PRISON
WORKGROUP COMMUNITY AGENCIES
REPORT THE ACCIDENT BENEFITS.
BEYOND YOUR ACTION COMMITTEE
COMMUNITY LEGAL SERVICES IN
PALO ALTO THE STORAGE ACTIVE
SERVICE CONTRACT COUNTY THIRD
SECOND THIRD PHONE SHOWING UP
FOR RACIAL JUSTICE EIGHT
MILLION PROJECT. BRIDGES STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE ONE SIX
TWO FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAINTENANCE
THE TEMA CON COULD DIRECTOR OF
THE CEILING JUST PROGRAM FOR
AMERICAN FRIENDS SERVICE
COMMITTEE I WILL BE REGISTERING
STRONG SUPPORTER ON BEHALF OF
THE FOLLOWING CO SPONSORS OF AB
TWO FIVE SIX ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION AMERICAN FRIENDS SERVICE
COMMITTEE. CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR PRISON FOR WOMEN PRISONERS.
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET COALITION
FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS OUR
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS.
INITIATE JUSTICE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA.
NEXT GEN AND SILICON VALLEY DE
BUG THANK YOU. NINE ONE SIX TWO
SIX. THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE MANAGER HR THERE ARE
WITH YOU CALIFORNIANS UNITED
FOR LOCAL BUDGETS ARE PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL AS A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS SO WE CAN
AFFORD TO ALONG WITH THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS HUMAN
IMPACT PARTNERS. STARTING OVER
THIRTY BRANDS SHOWING UP FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE EQUAL JUSTICE
USA MCCARTY PROGRAMS LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN THEIR CHANCE PROJECT
THIS ANTI DEPORTATION. GEN
COALITION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NINE ONE SIXTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON PENINSULA ME HAPPENED
TO ORGANIZATION FOR CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF CAN BE A PROBLEM
AGENCY BACK IN THE CALIFORNIA.
COALITION SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU NOW WILL
MOVE TO WITNESS AN AWKWARD
POSITION WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND
WILL PROVIDE THEM- THREE
MINUTES EACH WE HAVE LARRY
MARSH AND WE OF COURSE SHOWS
ALSO WHOSE ARE READY WE CAN
BEGIN WITH YOUR TESTIMONY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
LARRY MORSE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION. LAST YEAR CDA
VIGOROUSLY OPPOSED THE PASSAGE
OF A. B. TWO FIVE FOUR TWO AND
FOR MANY OF THE SAME REASONS-
WE MUST ALSO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB TWO FIVE SIX. DESPITE
MYRIAD AMBIGUITIES UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS POSED BY AB TWO FIVE
FOUR TWO AB TWO FIVE SIX
PROPOSES TO MAKE ITS PROVISIONS
RETROACTIVE. DESPITE THE FACT
THAT THE PROPONENTS
SPECIFICALLY EXCLUDED
RETROACTIVE APPLICATION LAST
YEAR- WE RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S
POLITICALLY UNPOPULAR. TO
OPPOSE A BILL THAT HAS BESTOWED
UPON ITSELF THE NAME THE RACIAL
JUSTICE ACT. BUT WE BELIEVE THE
JUSTICE IT PURPORTS TO CREATE
ILLUSORY AT BEST A MORE OPENLY
COMPLICATE EFFORTS TO CREATE A
FAIRER. AND MORE EQUITABLE
JUSTICE SYSTEM- AB TWO BY FOUR
IS EVERY CREATE A BOWL DESIGNED
TO ELIMINATE DISCRIMINATION IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM A
GOLD WHOLEHEARTEDLY EMBRACED BY
CDA. BUT IT DID SO IN A WAY
THAT CREATED A TREMENDOUS RISK
OF DENYING JUST AS THE TWO
VICTIMS OF EVERY RACE ETHNICITY
AND NATIONAL ORIGIN BY
INSTITUTING A SYSTEM THAT WOULD
REVERSE A CASE. EVEN IF THERE
WAS NO SHOWING THE DEFENDANT
WAS DEPRIVED OF A FAIR TRIAL.
FOR EXAMPLE IF THERE IS A MASS
SHOOTING AT A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER INVOLVED IN THE CASE.
WHOSE ONLY ROLE WAS TO TAKE AN
UNDISPUTED VIDEOTAPED STATEMENT
FROM THE DEFENDANT. WHAT
DISCOVERED TO HARBOR BIASES
AGAINST THE DEFENDANT. THE BILL
MANDATES THAT THE DEFENDANT'S
CONVICTION WOULD HAVE TO BE
REVERSED DESPITE THE FACT THAT
FIFTY PEOPLE OBSERVE THE
DEFENDANT SHOOTING OTHERS
VICTIMS. THE WHAT THIS IS BIAS
WAS REVEALED TO THE JURY. THE
WITNESS COULD NOT EVEN
TESTIFIED AND ALL THE PEOPLE
WHO WERE MURDERED ALONG THE
SAME RACIAL AND ETHNIC GROUPS.
AS THE DEFENSE. THAT RACIAL
JUSTICE. AB TWO FIVE FOUR TWO
WHICH AGAIN THIS BILL WOULD
MAKE RETROACTIVE IS SIMPLY
RENTAL WITH AMBIGUOUS LANGUAGE
INADEQUATE DEFINITIONS AND
UNANSWERED LEGAL QUESTIONS THE
BILL WOULD OVERTURN A
CONVICTION OF THE DEFENDANT WAS
CHARGED OR CONVICTED OF A MORE
SERIOUS OFFENSE NOT THE FINE
THE DEFENDANTS OF OTHER RACES
ETHNICITIES OR NATIONAL ORIGIN
WILL COMMIT SIMILAR OFFENSES
NOT DEFINE AND ARE SIMILARLY
SITUATED NOT THE FIVE. AND THE
EVIDENCE ESTABLISHES THAT THE
PROSECUTION MORE FREQUENTLY
SOUGHT VAGUELY DEFINED OR
OBTAIN CONVICTIONS FOR MORE
SERIOUS OFFENSES AGAINST PEOPLE
WHO SHARE THE DEFENDANT'S RACE
ETHNICITY OR NATIONAL. ORIGIN
COOLEY TROUBLING THE BILL DOES
NOT PROVIDE ANY GUIDANCE IN
ASSESSING THE RELEVANCE FOR
COMPARISON PERSON PURPOSES IT
FIVE YEARS TEN YEARS TWENTY
YEARS AGO WE DON'T KNOW. WHAT
QUALIFIES AS AN ETHNICITY OR
NATIONAL ORIGIN AGAINST THE LAW
IN THIS BILL PROVIDES ZERO
GUIDE. SHOULD OFFENDERS CHARGED
WITH THE SAME CRIMES TO BE OF
THE SAME ETHNICITY BUT A
DIFFERENT NATIONAL ORIGIN OR
RACE OR BE OF THE SAME RACE BUT
A DIFFERENT ETHNICITY OR
NATIONAL ORIGIN. WHICH IS THE
RELEVANT GROUP FOR COMPARISON
NONE OF THESE COMPLEX ISSUES
HAVE YET BEEN ADDRESSED BY AN
APPELLATE COURT IN THIS BILL
SEEKS TO MAKE IT RETROACTIVE.
EVERY TO BELONGS TO AT LEAST
TWO OR MORE RACIAL ETHNIC OR
NATIONAL ORIGIN GROUPS.
PRACTICALLY EVERY SINGLE
CONVICTION THAT HAS EVER
OCCURRED IN CALIFORNIA CAN NOW
BE RE OPEN THE POTENTIALLY
REVERSE. DESPITE INDEPENDENT
NOT HAVING BEEN DENIED A FAIR
TRIAL BY ANY REALISTIC STANDARD.
HOW ABOUT PROVIDING THE COURTS
AND TRYING TO OUR IRON OUT THE
MULTITUDE OF LEGAL ISSUES
RAISED BY THE BILL LET'S
DETERMINE THE ACTUAL COST OF
THE NEW LAWS ENACTED BY AB TWO
FIVE FOUR TWO IN A POST OPEN
COURT WORLD. BEFORE MAKING IT
RETROACTIVE. EITHERIMMEDIATELY
TO ALL PERSONS CURRENTLY
SERVING A SENTENCE STATE PRISON
OR THE COUNTY JAIL. LET'S GET A
HANDLE ON THE SIGNIFICANT COST
AND LEGAL ISSUES BEFORE
MANDATING GETS RETROACTIVELY
AND YOU OF ALL THESE FACTORS.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU TO MENTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR VERSE
CHORUS A LITTLE BEHALF OF CAL
STATE SURE ASSOCIATION- I THINK
MISTER MORRIS LAID OUT A LOT OF
THE POLICY BASED CONCERNS THAT
WE SHARE WITH AB TWO FIFTY SIX
WE CERTAINLY DON'T DEFEND
DISCRIMINATION. BASED ON THE
FACTORS NOTED IN THE BILL OR
ANY OTHER FACTORS THAT SAID
THIS BILL IN ITS PREDECESSOR GO
FAR BEYOND ATTEMPTING TO
PREVENT OR REMEDY DECISIONS AND
OUTCOMES THAT ARE ALLEGED TO BE
A FACTOR OF RACE ETHNICITY OR
NATIONAL ORIGIN I WOULD JUST
SIMPLY HIGHLIGHT- IN ADDITION
TO THE POINT THAT MISTER MORRIS
MADE AGAIN- THAT AB TWO FIFTY
SIX. DESPITE THE- PURPOSEFUL
ACTION. REGARDING THE BILL LAST
YEAR TO MAKE IT PERSPECTIVES
CAN REACH ONLY- IS NOW JUST
MONTHS LATER NOT BEING MADE TO
BE RETROACTIVE- AND WE EXPECT
THAT AB TWO FIFTY SIX WILL ONLY
FURTHER AGGRAVATE THOSE
EXPECTED SPIKES IN COURT
CASELOAD RESULTING FROM AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY TWO DELAYING
OR DENYING JUSTICE TO OTHERS
WHO SEEK IT SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB TWO FIFTY SIX. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE TO
THE ROOM THERE ARE THERE
WITNESSES HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. OF A AB TWO FIVE
SIX. TWO NINE WILL GO TO OUR
OVER FORMER TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NO ONE THERE AS WELL.
MODERATE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES AND SHIFTERS WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO FIVE SIX.
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWO FIVE SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CARE WE HAVE NO IN QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME. OKAY WE'LL BRING
YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE. NO. I'M SORRY. I
WOULD MAKE IS IF WE HAD ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS I
COMMITTEE- I WOULD JUST WANT TO
THANK A CINNAMON FOR BRINGING
THIS ROGER FORD I'M ALWAYS
BLOWN AWAY AT THE ARGUMENT THAT
RACE PLAYS NO PART AND MUCH OF
WHAT LAW ENFORCEMENT IN OUR
JUDICIAL SYSTEM DOES ON A DAILY
BASIS- BUT IT'S LAUGHABLE-
HISTORY IS PROVEN IN THAT RACE
PLAYS AS MUCH OF A PART SOME
TIMES ONCE GUILT OR INNOCENCE
SPECIALLY IN THIS COUNTRY. AND
SPECIALLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
NUMBER OF BLACK AND BROWN
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
INCARCERATED IN THIS COUNTRY
AND IF I COULD QUOTE A RICHARD
PRYOR- OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
JUST THAT JUST US JUST BLACK
AND BROWN FOLKS WHO ARE
CONVICTED THE MOST HARSHLY AND
SENT TO PRISON ALL THE TIME
CHAU DISK SAY AND THEN THE
EXAMPLE THAT MISS MORRIS MISSED
MORE SHOES AS A MASS SHOOTING
OF FIFTY PEOPLE OF THE SAME
RACE. THE MILITARY NO BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE HAVE COMMITTED ANY
SUCH ACT IN THIS COUNTRY SO-
THAT'S A POOR EXAMPLE AS FAR AS
I'M CONCERNED CHAU- UNTIL YOU
CAN SHOW ME A CASE WHERE BLACK
AND BROWN PEOPLE. HAVE KILLED
MASS SHOOTINGS AND- THAT WOULD
GOOD ENOUGH. ON THAT NOTE. I
WILL ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE MISTER
CAR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MATURE FOR. YOUR OWN WISDOM IN
YOUR SUPPORT- THESE YOU KNOW
IT'S EASY TO SAY. OF COURSE WE
BELIEVE ANYBODY NEED TO GET RID
OF THIS COMBINATION IS MORE
DIFFICULTTO DO IT. AND THIS
ACT OF BLUE THE RACIAL JUSTICE
ACT INCLUDING THIS BILL WHICH
ALLOWS FOR A PHASED IN
RETROACTIVITY TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE- THE WORKLOAD CONCERNS- IS
THE DIFFICULT WORK THAT ALL OF
US ARE TASKED TO DO. AND SO I
WOULD ENCOURAGE OF THE
OPPOSITION PARTICULARLY OUR-
FRIENDS OVER THE DISK ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION. TO ROLL UP THEIR
SLEEVES AND FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN IMPLEMENT THIS IN A WAY.
THAT ACTUALLY ACHIEVES JUSTICE.
S. THEIR CONCERN ARE ARE K.
THAT ARE ON THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
GOING TO HELP. TO FURTHER
DEFINE- OF THE LEGISLATION ANY
PEACE LANDMARK LEGISLATION OR
POOR COURT PRECEDENT REQUIRES
FURTHER ANALYSIS FROM THE
COURTS NUMBER AND WE'RE GOING
TO BE SEEN THAT. IN THE MONTHS
AND YEARS AHEAD BUT IN THE
MEANTIME RETROACTIVITY INSURERS
THAT- THAT WE ARE. APPLYING
THIS MORAL JUSTICE TO EVERYONE
THAT'S BEEN IMPACTED IN OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEMS ON
THANK YOU MISTER. AS WELL AS OF
THE WITNESSES I SPOKE ON THE
PHONE SHARING STORIES OF THOSE
IMPACTED. THE OVER ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
SIMILAR THEIR SUPPORT. AND TORE
AB TWO FIFTY SIX SPONSORS. VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THEIR SUPPORT
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BOUGHT.
WE HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION TO APPROACH
WE'RE LOOKING FOR MOTION. IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER COM
LOGGER. CANCEL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON AB TWO FIVE SIX. AB TWO
FIVE SIX BRADFORD HI READ FOR
DIETRO BOGE. TURBO NO COM
LONGER HI I'M LONGER AYE
SKINNER WINNERS. ASSEMBLY POWER
WILL LEAD ROLE OPEN FOR THOSE
APPS MEMBERS TO ADD ON. THANK
YOU THE RETURN THANK YOU NEXT
UP IS. THROUGH WE ARE NOT SURE.
MCCARTY OKAY YES- WE HAVE AB.
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO. WE ARE
FIFTEEN FORTY TO BUY US A
MOMENT I'M CARD WHEN YOU'RE
READY YOU MAY TESTIFY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR WORKING WITH US AND
TALKING TO US ABOUT THIS BILL.
IT SAY- THE BILL HAS QUITE A
BIT OF A MOTION I KNOW ON BOTH
SIDES BUT IN REALITY IT'S A-
IT'S A DISTRICT BILL IT'S A
PILOT PROJECT FOR MY COUNTY
WHICH SHOULD BE HELD IN YOLO
COUNTY WHICH I. SHARE WITH-
CENTERS PAN AND DODD IN THIS
SIDE OVER HERE- THIS IS HOW THE
SUNSET FOR FIVE YEARS TO TEST
OUT AN IDEA THAT WE KNOW IS A
BIG THING IN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM TOO MANY PEOPLE
GOING IN AND OUT THROUGH THE
SYSTEM. WITH UNDERLYING DRUG
ADDICTIONS AND NEVER EVER HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO- TO GET
TREATMENT I THINK THAT THERE
HAS BEEN A LOT OF
MISCOMMUNICATION ABOUT THIS
BILL AND IF THE BILL REALLY DID
WHAT THE OPPOSITION IS CLAIMING
I WOULD NOT TO THE BILL I WOULD
NOT BOTHER IT AND FRANKLY I'D
VOTE AGAINST IT BUT IT'S NOT-
THAT- THIS BILL CREATES A
VOLUNTARY WAY FOR INDIVIDUALS.
TO HAVE AN UNDERLYING DRUG
ADDICTION. AFTER THEY'VE BEEN
SENTENCED. TO EITHER A STATE
PRISON TERM OR LONG TERM- TERM
IN COUNTY JAIL. TO SEEK
TREATMENT INSTEAD IN LIEU OF.
THIS IS A 100% INVOLUNTARY. IT
WOULD BE BASED ON
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS- NOT
NECESSARILY JUST THE JUDGE. THE
JUDGE COULD APPROVE IT IF THE
DA AND HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS PROVIDE A
RECOMMENDATION THAT THIS COULD
BENEFIT AN INDIVIDUAL HAS BEEN
SENTENCED. AND AGAIN IT'S
VOLUNTARY. INDIVIDUAL GOES DOWN
THIS ROUTE. AND DOESN'T- I
THINK IT'S A GOOD FIT THEY CAN
BACK OUT BUT WHEN THEY BACK
OUT. JUST BE CLEAR BUT NOT
GOING TO GO HOME THE NICKEL
BRACELET THEY'RE GONNA GO
EITHER GO. TO THEY'RE SENTENCED
TO STATE PRISON OR IN COUNTY
JAIL. SO THAT YOU KNOW. SHOULD
OF PERFECT WORLD WE'D LIKE MORE
COMMUNITY TREATMENT. FOR
INDIVIDUALS. IT FOR DRUG
TREATMENT IN THEIR OWN
NEIGHBORHOODS BUT THESE
INDIVIDUALS. BUT I WOULD BE
GOING OTHERWISE TO RETURN-
INCARCERATED AND WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S NOT GOOD TREATMENT
FRANKLY YOU CAN GET DRUGS
EASILY AND- AND ART AND ART IN
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
ANYWAY. SO THIS IS A CHANCE FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO GO TO. A SECURED
FACILITY TO FOCUS ON TREATMENT
ONCE THE TREATMENT IS
COMPLETED. THEY WILL HAVE THEIR
FELONY RECORD EXPUNGED IN BE
ABLE TO. MOVE ON WITH OUR
LIVES. WE KNOW THAT WE NEED TO
TRY. NEW THINGS IN CALIFORNIA
THE CURRENT SYSTEM ABOUT
ADDICTION AND INCARCERATION IS
NOT WORKING. AND I WOULD ASK
THAT WE GIVE THIS- PILOT
PROJECT IN YOLO COUNTY. I TRIED
FOR FIVE YEARS I WITH ME TODAY.
OUR OUR DISTRICT ATTORNEY FROM
YELLOW COUNTY JEFF REISIG. AS
WELL AS HIS- DEPUTY IS IN THE
AUDIENCE WITH US AS WELL. AND
ANTHONY BROWN. I ASK THE
ARRIVAL MISTER CHAIR. PART HERE
FOR MR IT WILL GIVE THE
WITNESSES SUPPORT MINUTES. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS THIS
CONCERNING JEFF REISIG OF
YELLOW COUNTY. YOU MANY PEOPLE
WHO SUFFER FROM SERIOUS
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS ARE
GOING TO PRISONS AND JAILS FOR
CRIMES THAT ARE MOTIVATED BY
THEIR ADDICTION. BRITAIN'S IN
JAILS ARE SIMPLY NOT PLACES
WHERE SICK PEOPLE GO TO GET
BETTER. AND AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY MENTIONED. WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN CALIFORNIA ON THESE
ISSUES ISN'T. WORKING OUT AS
WELL AS WE WOULD HOPE AND WE
HAVE A REVOLVING DOOR. AB
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO PROPOSAL
LOCAL TREATMENT ALTERNATIVES TO
PRISON AND JAIL. FOR THOSE
PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN CONVICTED OF
FELONY LEVEL CRIMES MOTIVATED
BY THEIR SERIOUS ADDICTION TO
DRUGS. BUT WHO POSED TO MUCH OF
A RISK FOR A JUDGE TO SIMPLY
RELEASE THEM INTO A UNSECURED
RESIDENTIAL FACILITY IN THE
COMMUNITY. WHERE THEY CAN
SIMPLY WALK AWAY. OR CRAWL OUT
A WINDOW ON DAY ONE AND
POTENTIALLY CAUSE MORE HARM TO
THEMSELVES. OR OTHERS CHAU
INSTEAD AB FIFTEEN FORTY TWO
ENVISIONS CREATING A SECURE.
DIGITAL LIKE TREATMENT
ENVIRONMENT WITHOUT JAILS AND
BARS AND GUARDS AND GUNS THAT
CAN SERVE AS A SANCTUARY
BERSERK SERIOUSLY ADDICTED
FELONY OFFENDERS. WHO
VOLUNTARILY CHOOSE TO TRY LOCAL
COMMUNITY BASED TREATMENT. AND
WRAPAROUND SERVICES IN THE CITY
CONCERT YOU'RE SITTING RIGHT
HERE AT HOME IN YELLOW INSTEAD
OF BEING MERELY BE IN WAREHOUSE.
HIND BARS- WE CALL THIS
POTENTIAL PLACE HOPE YELLOW.
WHAT ALSO MAKES THIS TREATMENT
ALTERNATIVE UNIQUE IS THAT IT
WILL BE DESIGNED AND STAFFED BY
TREATMENT PROVIDERS AND THEY
WILL DECIDE WHO'S AN
APPROPRIATE CANDIDATE AND WHO
IS NOT AND WHAT THE TREATMENT
SHOULD LOOK LIKE. FOR THOSE WHO
DO SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETE THE
TREATMENT. OVER PRISON THEY
WILL HAVE THEIR CONVICTIONS
EXPUNGED AND THEY'LL GET A
CLEAN START RIGHT HERE AT HOME.
ULTIMATELY AB FIFTEEN FORTY
TWO. REMEASURED PILOT BILL
ANNUAL CHARITY THAT IS DESIGNED
TO OFFER. EARLY VOLUNTARY
TREATMENT ALTERNATIVES TO THAT
THOSE WHO ARE OTHERWISE ON
THEIR WAY TO PRISON OR JAIL. I
WOULD URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO
GIVE THIS PILOT PROGRAM A
CHANCE THANK YOU. I BELIEVE WE
HAVE ONE MORE WITNESS VENTURE
WE HAVE A MARKET YES SORRY
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THE FOR THE
NAME FOR THE SECOND WORD IS
JUST HAPPENING BROWN. I'M SORRY
ANTHONY BROWN ANTHONY BROWN ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. YES I AM
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU- I'M
HELLO CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HI MY NAME IS ACTUALLY
BROWN AND I'M CURRENTLY A
LICENSE I GET. THE TECHNICIAN A
REGISTERED NURSE A PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE AND CERTIFIED
ADDICTION TREATMENT COUNSELOR
THIRD LEVEL NURSE. CERTIFIED
ANGER MANAGEMENT FACILITATOR AS
WELL AS A CERTIFIED DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SPECIALIST- MY
EDUCATIONAL GOVERNMENT SUCH AS
AN ART DEGREE ASSOCIATE OF
SCIENCE DEGREE IN NURSING AND A
BACHELOR OF SCIENCE DEGREE IN
NURSING. I'M CURRENTLY EMPLOYED
AS THE DIRECTOR OF NURSING
SERVICES THAT IT NINETY NINE
BAD THANK AT THE FACILITY IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS A FULL
TIME TEACHER. IN THE HOUSE
SCIENCE DEPARTMENT AT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. ARE YOU SURE.
MY ACCOMPLISHMENTS- WITH THE
COMMITTEE B. PRIOR TWO THOUSAND
AND TWO MY CDC NUMBER WHICH H.
SEVEN TWO SIX NINE NINE. I
SPENT MOST OF THE NINETIES IN
VERY FACILITY THAT FACILITY
STATE PROGRAMS R. J. DONOVAN
CHUCKWALLA VALLEY STATE PRISON
AVENAL STATE PRISON. KERN
VALLEY PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA'S
TO FOR MEN ETCETERA ETCETERA
ETCETERA. I PRIOR TO THAT I WAS
HOMELESS FROM THE AGE OF
FOURTEEN TO THIRTY SEVEN. AND
ARE YOU STARTED- GETTING
INVOLVED IN ALCOHOL AND DRUGS
AND ALL OF THAT- FROM EARLY AGE
BECAUSE A CHILDHOOD TRAUMA. I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO FOR
INDIVIDUALS LIKE ME CAN BE ABLE
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
HAVE THEIR LIVES TRANSFORMED AS
I HAVE I KNOW I JUMP THROUGH A
LOT OF DIFFERENT HOPE BECAUSE
OF MY CRIMINAL BACKGROUND. AND
I DO BELIEVE THAT THIS
TRANSITIONAL CARE MODEL THAT
YOU'RE DEVELOPING AND YELLOW
COUNTY WOULD BENEFIT NOT ONLY
ME BUT OTHER INDIVIDUALS LIKE
ME. CURRENTLY I'M STUDYING TO
BECOME A FAMILY NURSE
PRACTITIONER AND I REALLY
BELIEVE SOMETHING LIKE THIS CAN
HELP CURB WHAT'S GOING. ON OUT
THERE TO TRY THE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER AROUND HERE.
AND CONGRATULATIONS BY THE WAY-
WILL NOW MOVES INTO WITNESSES
HERE IT IN SUPPORT AT FORTY TWO
OH THREE SEVENTY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SAYING NINE. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN TWENTY FOUR
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. FIFTEEN FORTY TWO. C.
NINE. THANK YOU ALL NUMBER ONE
TWO WITNESSES WANTING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ARVEST MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY
TWO. WE WILL BEGIN. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
SEVENTY SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE.
I'M SORRY I'M SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT WILL
PLEASE RE QUEUE WHEN THE
OPPOSITION COMES AROUND ONE
MOMENT THIS AND IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND TO MODERATE IF YOU COULD
GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. ONE SECOND PLEASE WE
HAVE FOUR LINES OF THIS POINT.
WE WILL NEXT TO LINE ONE ZERO
ONE KELAN. ONE ONE A ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I AM READY TO
TESTIFY OPPOSITION AS WELL.
THANK YOU WHEN THEY OPPOSITION-
WHEN THE OPPOSITION IS
ANNOUNCED PLEASE RE QUEUE UP BY
PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO. THE
BOTTOM LINE. ONE FORTY TWO.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
MODELING COOPER FROM THE OPEN
MARKET MORE ON BEHALF OF YELLOW
COUNTY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOUNG.
NINE ONE SIX THREE EIGHT GO
AHEAD PLEASE. YEAH THIS IS JUST
YOUR TEETH FORMER YOU'LL COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS SCHOOLS AND
REPRESENTING THE YOLO COUNTY
CONCEALED IN SUPPORT. OF. AB
FIFTY FORTY TWO THANK YOU. THEY
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR. AND
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS AND WILL NOT POLICY
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION- AND I BELIEVE WE DO
HAVE LEAD OPPOSITION- DO WE
HAVE LESLIE HOUSTON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS ON
THE LINE. YES MA'AM I'M HERE.
PLEASE PROCEED- THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON TRACY OLSON THE
YELLOW COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER
WAS GOING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION BUT HAVE RUN INTO
SOME OBSTACLES MY NAME IS
LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON I AM A
RETIRED CHIEF DEFENDER OF
SOLANO COUNTY AND
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION.
ON BEHALF OF OUR ASSOCIATION I
WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT DEEP
CONCERNS ABOUT AB FIFTEEN FORTY
TWO FIRST THIS BILL
INCENTIVIZES THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS TO SEEK AND JUDGES TO
APPROVE AND IMPOSE A PRISON
SENTENCE IN ORDER TO REQUIRE
OUR CLIENTS TO RECEIVE
TREATMENT. WE KNOW WHAT THE PIT
THAT THE CATCH IS THAT THESE
CLIENTS WOULD GO TO PRISON
ANYWAY. I WOULDN'T TREATMENT
FEATHER. AT THE VERY MAJORITY
OF CASES ARE SETTLED THROUGH
NEGOTIATIONS PROSECUTORS HAVE
BROAD DISCRETION AS TO HOW THE
SHUTTLE CHASE. YES JUDGES MAKE
THE ORDERS BUT IN REALITY THE
JUDGES ARE OFTEN JUST APPROVING
LAUGHTER FROM THE PROSECUTION
AND ACCEPTED BY THE DEFENDANT.
THE BILL BANKS ON THE IDEA THAT
WHEN FORCED TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
PRISON AND TREATMENT THE CLIENT
WOULD QUOTE UNQUOTE SHOES
TREATMENT. THERE WILL INCREASES
AND CREATES A SYSTEM BY WHICH
PROSECUTORS AND- CONSCIOUSLY OR
NOT WILL MAKE PRISON MONSTERS
THEY WOULD NOT NORMALLY MAKE
JUST TO GIVE OUR CLIENTS TO AS
I SAID QUOTE UNQUOTE SHOES
TREATMENT. THAT IS A BROKEN
SYSTEM CHECK IT. THE BILL HAS
NO PROTECTIONS TO ENSURE OUR
CLIENTS WON'T SERVE MORE JAIL
CUSTODY TIME AND TIME ON
PROBATION IF THEY PARTICIPATE
IN TREATMENT SECTION THREE TWO
ALLOWS THE CLIENT COULD BE IN A
LOCKED FACILITY AND UNDERSTOOD
PROVISIONAL LONGER. THAN THE
ACTUAL SENTENCE IMPOSE. WE ARE
NOT A DAHLE OPPOSED TO OFFERING
TREATMENT SERVICES TO OUR
CLIENTS BUT WE MUST DO IT IN A
WAY THAT DOES NOT INCENTIVIZE
PRISON SENTENCES AND DOES NOT
LINK THAN DEFENDANTS STAYS IN
JAIL OR PUREED THE PROBATION
SUPERVISION. YELLOW COUNTY JAIL
HAS UNDERGONE A MAJOR REMODEL
AND NOW HAVE DEDICATED SPACE TO
PROVIDE TREATMENT. SERVICES TO
BEGIN LATE. AND HAD ALL BEEN TO
EMBED SERVICES IN THE JAIL AND
THEN TRANSITION PEOPLE BACK
INTO THE COMMUNITY THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS NOT AVAILABLE
UNDER THE- PROPOSED LAW. WE
APPRECIATE THE INCREASED
DIGNITY RECOGNITION AND THE
NEED FOR TREATMENT AND TO TREAT
THIS DISORDER OF THE MEDICAL
TECHNICIAN. BUT FIFTEEN FORTY
TWO AS WRITTEN DESERVES YOUR NO
VOTE THANK YOU. RIGHT WITH THE
PRIMARY WITNESS OPPOSITION
MISUSED. SO NOW WE GOT OUR
REBEKAH PARTISAN. HELLO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME
TO SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS THAT
THE EYES AND ON THE FIELD
HEALTH RIGHT THREE SIXTY ONE OF
THE LARGEST SPEAKING AT
CHATTANOOGA BORDER PROVIDERS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
LOCAL ON THE BORDER CAD PETER
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION A
TREATING PROVIDER MORE FORMER
DRUG USER I DIDN'T GET
TREATMENT AND I HAVE OVER
THIRTY YEARS EXPERIENCE IN THE
FIELD. OUR ORGANIZATION WITH
FIFTY MORE THE STATE. ANNUAL
COUNTY OPPOSING THIS BILL. IN
AN ERA WHERE WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TOWARDS MORE EVIDENCE
BASED CARE FOR PEOPLE WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER. ONE OF
THE SAME TIME QUESTIONING THE
WAR ON DRUGS AND THE NEGATIVE
IMPACT THAT HAD ON COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. THIS BILL SIMPLY
MOVE. IN THE WRONG DIRECTION ON
BOTH COUNTS. THE BILL'S WORDING
ATTEMPT TODAY AT BETWEEN THE
RAINDROPS. WILL BRING TO THE
PROGRAM AS A VOLUNTARY WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME DESCRIBING A
PROGRAM THAT IS WHAT. AND EVEN
INDIVIDUAL IS CALORIC INDICATOR
UNDER JUDGE'S ORDER. YOUR
PERMITTED BEING TO BE SENT TO A
DIFFERENT LOCK INSTABILITY THAT
WOULD BE JAIL. IT SHOULD BE
NOTED THAT YOU'RE LOOKING JAIL
ALREADY HAVE AN INCOME SEPT YOU
FROM PROGRAM. ADDITIONALLY IT
HAS A DRUG COURT PROGRAM
BRITAIN BEGGING THE QUESTION
WHY DOES YELLOW COUNTY NEED
THIS NEW PROGRAM. AND ONE OF
THE NEEDS OF LEGISLATORS
LEGISLATURES APPROVAL IF IT
ALREADY HAS TWO DIFFERENT
TREATMENT PROGRAM. MONITORED BY
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THAT CAN MENTION A COMMUNITY
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT SYSTEM AND NETWORK OF
CARE. UNDER DRUG MEDI CAL FOR
DRUGS FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES. I DID MEDICAL
RESEARCH TO PAY CORPS. BUT IT
WILL BOTH PROGRAM BASED ON
EVERYTHING WE ABOUT RULES WE
BELIEVE THAT THEY COULD NOT
TRUE BECAUSE THE PROGRAM
PROJECT BUT DO NOT HAVE FREEDOM
OF MOVEMENT A CALL
REQUIREMENTS. FOR MANY
CALIPATRIA. MOREOVER WE KNOW
THAT THERE IS NO CURRENT
LICENSING STANDARDS DEPARTMENT
HELP HEALTHCARE SERVICES. FOR A
SECURED RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
PROGRAM WHICH WOULD ALSO
PROHIBITED FROM GOING DOWN THAT
CALIFICACIONES. DON'T TAKE IT
FOR A LOCKED PROGRAM I JAIL BY
ANY OTHER NAME IS NOT MEDICARE
WILL BILL CONTEMPLATES THE
FUTURE USE OF THE MULTI STATE
OPIOID SETTLEMENT FUNDS. ONCE
AGAIN THE DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL LEADERS
COULD NOT REFUSE IS NOT IN
KEEPING WITH THE PRINCIPLES OF
EVIDENCE AND EQUITY. DEVELOPED
BY A BROAD SET OF NATIONAL
EXPERTISE STAKEHOLDERS IT WOULD
BE A PAINFUL IRONY THAT WHILE
IT'S HARD TO THE NET MULTISTATE
OPIOID LAWSUIT WALKED FREE. THE
OUTCOME OF THAT CASE RESULT IN
LOCKING UP SOME OF THEIR
VICTIMS THE DRUG OVERDOSE
CRISIS IS URGENT WE UNDERSTAND
THE DESIRE TO EXPAND CARE TO
MEET THE MOMENT. BUT THIS BILL
DOES NOT DO THAT EQUITABLE OR
RESPONSIBLE WAY PLEASE VOTE NO.
AGAINST HIS BILL THANK YOU.
PART WE'RE MOVING TO. HEARING
FOR TWO OLD. ARE THERE
WITNESSES PRESENT HERE IN
OPPOSITION- THIS MEASURE AB
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO. NO THEN WILL
GO TO TWENTY FROM TWENTY FORTY.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THERE
ARE NONE MODERATOR WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION OF FIFTEEN FORTY
TWO. THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF IT AB FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME TO GET YOUR LINE
NUMBER. WILL GO FIRST TO LINE
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
OCCURRED ON ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN OPPOSITION. HELLO.
NINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN. OFFERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. THE CORRECTION FOR
JUDGES IF YOU'RE DOING FINE ONE
ZERO FOUR. WHAT ABOUT MY NAME
IS SHERRY TURN AND I AM PART OF
SURGEONS SAN FRANCISCO AND ON
BEHALF OF- I JUST WANNA SAY
THAT THIS BILL IS. IT'S LIKE
POSING AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
INCARCERATION BUT IT ACTUALLY
WILL BE A CHEMICAL TANKER THEY
PERSECUTE THE ARM HOW CAN. AND
I FEEL THAT RATHER THAN CREATE
NEW WAYS TO ENCOURAGE. PEOPLE
WE SHOULD BE ADDRESSING HOW.
YOU INVALID AND PRESERVING A
HORRIBLE PROVIDING SERVICES TO
THOSE IN NEED AND PREVENTING
INFECTION. IN CUSTOMER LET
SHOULD MILLER LEAVE STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. CAN THE
SCALE OF BALLING KERRY
COMMUNITY BASED DRUG TREATMENT
PROGRAMS FOR PEOPLE WHO NEED
HELP CAN GET IT- AND I DON'T
THINK IT'S AN ALTERNATIVE TO
INCARCERATION A. B. FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO IS. REGIONAL AND I
REALLY- YOU TO JACQUELINE AND
INVESTMENTS. NON CHRISTIAN
NATION MENTAL CALMNESS. BUT
WHEN HE RETURNS MONEY NEXT
WITNESS PUSH. LINE EIGHTY GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBER SHERRY DALY WITH
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS IN OPPOSITION.
LINE ONE TWENTY TWO GO AHEAD
PLEASE. SERIK ME ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE AND RESPECT
PROPOSITIONS. ONE ONE EIGHTY
THREE. YES I AM GOING BACK
ACTUALLY- BAKER CENTER FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. NINE ONE EIGHTY TWO
FIVE MILLION NINE ONE EIGHTY
TWO IF YOU AGREE Q. I CAN BRING
YOUR MIND BACK UP MEANWHILE
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS ROBERT HARRIS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE. CALIFORNIA
EXPERTS MAKE TREATMENT OF
SUBSTANCE ABUSE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL. NINE NINETY NINE. EXACTLY
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN OPPOSITION. NINE ONE
EIGHTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
GENETICALLY FOURTEEN ON BEHALF
OF DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN
OPPOSITION. WELL BACK TO LINE
ONE EIGHTY TWO. ACCORDING TO
MARK BONE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
WOMEN PRISONERS MANZANILLO TOM
LATHAM SOMEONE IN JAIL MY
FAMILY MEMBERS ON. PRESIDENT AT
DECADE OF WORK BY ON FOR.
ACCEPTED. THIRTY GOOD LUCK WAIT
WHEN ARTISTS PERFORMANCE I
UNDER THE GUISE A FORM THAT
SOUNDS LIKE IT MIGHT BE THAT.
THANK FOR CALLING AB FORTY HE
WAS A WALK SHOOT OKAY NOT A
PROBLEM CRIMINAL DR REFORM.
LINE ONE SEVENTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT THE CANNOT TAKE
OFF CALLING IN AND CAL VOICES
TO STATE OUR OPPOSITION TO AB
SIXTEEN FORTY TWO THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE SEVENTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN OPPOSITION. NINE ONE SEVENTY
NINE. NINE ONE SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. AT WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA KNOCKS THAT
COALITION IN THE COUNT
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL COMMUNITY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCY IN
OPPOSITION. ONE ONE TWENTY
EIGHT. YES THIS IS CECILIA
TRIAL WITH THE TELECOM BALLY
DEBUGGING SANTA CLARA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. LINE.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE. THANK YOU
HEAR ME. BUT HAD PLACE IN
MOSCOW THANK. HI THIS IS THE
BALLET RED DIGNITY AND POWER
NOW A LOCKING THOSE BIG
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS AND
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION WERE ALSO PART OF
THE CAREFIRST CALIFORNIA
COALITION AND WE BELIEVE THAT
IN BACK THEN IT'S BETTER SPENT
IN ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION THAT OUR
COMMUNITY BASED AND NOT ROOTED
AND INCARCERATION MASQUERADING
AS TREATMENT UP LEADS AND BACK.
AN ACTUAL ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE
RESIDING IN THE COMMUNITY- AND
NOT IN CONSTRUCTING MORE JAIL-
THAT MASQUERADE. AS TREATMENT
THANK YOU. ONE ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN. CANACCORD ON AGAIN THIS
TIMEREGISTERING OPPOSITION ON
BEHALF OF THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION. WE HAVE ONE OF THE
LINE QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT
WHILE THE PROVIDE DEADLINE
NUMBER. LINE ONE EIGHTY SIX GO
AHEAD PLEASE. WHEN I GET UP IN
THE CONSIDERABLE IS WHEN WITH A
STORM CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTEEN FORTY
CARE. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
OTHER QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS
RELATES TO. FIFTEEN FORTY TWO
BY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
TURNER WINNER SURE I. THANK
YOU- MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK
THE AUTHOR BERMAN IS A
KNOWLEDGE THIS IS- IT'S A THIS
IS A POKER SITUATION- A LOT OF
MY I DO A LOT OF TIME OF DRUG
POLICY WORK AND A LOT OF MY-
FRIENDS HER OPPOSING THIS BILL
IN TERMS OF INCLUDING A LOT OF
AMAZING ADVOCATES AND- IN MY
OWN COMMUNITY AND WHEN I FIRST.
CAME UPON THIS BILL I- HERE I
CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER THIS IS
TAKING US IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION IN TERMS OF HOW WE
TREAT SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
AND I WILL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT I
STILL HAVE. THOSE CONCERNS. AND
I JUST WANNA SERVICES CITY THAT
UNKNOWN THAT- SO ROSA
CALIFORNIA BACK MY HEAD SERRANO.
BUT WE SHOULD NEVER BE LOOKING
AT OURSELVES AND- AND THE
MONARCHS- BUT I ALSO KNOW. THAT
WE HAVE SO MANY. CHALLENGES IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AROUND THE
INTERACTIONS OF DRUG USE AND
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM-
AND WE ARE ALSO TRYING TO. WE
HAVE BEEN TRYING FOR A LONG
TIME CENTER BALLOTS SOME BILLS
IN THIS. ONE WHEN DRUGS ARE
INTERACTING WITH SOMEONE
COMMISSION OF A CRIME HOW DO WE
DEAL WITH THAT IN A WAY THAT'S
NOT. SIMPLY PUNITIVE IN A WAY
IT'S ACTUALLY GETTING PEOPLE
THE HELP THAT THEY- THEY NEED-
I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW- THIS
AUTHOR- IT IS SOMEONE WHO IS
ONE OF THE MOST PROGRESSIVE
VOICES IN THE LEGISLATURE ON.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE ISSUES I WAS
PROPOSING OUT LIMITED PILOT
PROGRAM FOR COUNTY AND IS
DISTRICT AND. ALSO YOU KNOW I
THINK. I'D LIKE TO SHOW. WHEN
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO THE PILOT
PROGRAMS FOR THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY THAT THEY KNOW BEST-
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
PROVIDE SOME LEVEL DIFFERENCE
THERE DODD TO BE HONEST- FIVE.
YOU KNOW I WILL ALSO JUST SAY
THAT I THINK THERE ARE SOME
CONTINUING QUESTIONS ABOUT.
THIS BILL- AND I WANNA MAKE
SURE FOR SO THAT I UNDERSTAND
SOME THINGS AND I THINK THIS
BILL. NEEDS MORE WORK- SO YOU
KNOW WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS ACTUALLY SOMETHING THAT
IS GOING TO BE BENEFICIAL TO
PEOPLE. AND NOT HARMFUL ONE
THING I ALSO NEGLECTED TO
MENTION WHEN I FIRST YOU KNOW
POSITIVE FORM SOME OF THE
CONCERNS OR QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
BILL I WENT BACK AND LOOKED AT
THE ASSEMBLY FLORIDA AND FOUND
THAT- BUT PRETTY MUCH ALMOST
EVERY SINGLE. DEMOCRAT IN THE
ASSEMBLY INCLUDING SOME VERY
VERY PROGRESSIVE LEADERS ON
THESE ISSUES VOTED FOR THE BILL
AND THAT YOU KNOW MAYBE SEVERAL
TAKE A HARDER LOOK- AT THE
BILL. SO I GUESS IT'S JUST A
FEW QUICK QUESTIONS- FOR THE-
FOR THE AUTHOR. THERE WAS A
COMMENT- EARLIER ABOUT HEALTH I
THINK FROM THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S ASSOCIATION. THAT
THIS COULD LEAD TO SOMEONE
HAVING A LONGER. PERIOD OF TIME
IN A LOCKED FACILITY. THAN THEY
WOULD HAVE JUST BY THE PRISON
SENTENCE. I MIGHT I MIGHT BE
MISREADING THE BILL PUT UP MY
UNDERSTANDING WAS DIED THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY SAYS AND PLEASE
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG IF IT
DOESN'T I THINK THIS NEEDS TO
BE CHANGED. THAT THE
COMBINATION OF THE- OF THE LOCK
TREATMENT PLUS TO STEP DOWN.
CAN NOT EXCEED. V. WHAT THE
PRISON SENTENCE WOULD HAVE
BEEN- AND I IN ADDITION. IF A
PERSON DECIDES TO LEAVE
TREATMENT AND GO BACK GO AND GO
INTO A PRISON SETTING. THE
TOTAL AMOUNT CAN'T EXCEED. THAT
SENT OKAY YOU CLARIFY THAT TIME
FOR ME BECAUSE I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE AREN'T. IF YOU
CHOOSE THIS OPTION IF THEY
DON'T END UP SPENDING MORE
TIME. THAN THEY WOULD HAVE HAD
THEY SIMPLY- ACCEPTED THE-JAILER PRISON SONS. THANK YOU-
AND I APPRECIATE THAT THE BACK
AND FORTH HERE AND I'D LIKE TO
GO INTO GREAT DETAIL ON THIS
YOU KNOW AS THAT THE CHAIR
ALLOWS US TO- BUT YEAH THAT WAS
THE INTENT OF THE BILL WHEN WE
HIT WE INTRODUCED IT AND WE
TOOK AN AMENDMENT. IN THE
ASSEMBLY THAT CLARIFIES THAT
SO. I'M KIND OF AT A LOSS AND
SO IF WE CAN FURTHER CLARIFY
THAT POINT. I'M WILLING TO DO
SO BUT I THINK WE'RE CLEAR.
THAT THE INDIVIDUALS- THAT TIME
IN IN THIS IN THE TREATMENT
WOULD WOULD NOT. EXCEED WHAT
THEY WOULD GET THROUGH THEIR
UNDERLYING SENTENCE. INDOOR
PROBATION OKAY WOULD YOU BE
WILLING TO MAKE A COMMITMENT TO
DIE. IF THERE NEEDS TO BE
CHANGED TO THE BILL. TO PUT
GUARDRAILS- IN PLACE. THAT THAT
YOU'LL DO THAT ABSOLUTELY AND I
ALSO IN TERMS OF- I. ZERO
SOMETIMES P. GET RELEASED
BECAUSE OF- CREDITS FOR. GOOD
BEHAVIOR OTHER KINDS OF CREDITS
THAT THEY RECEIVED TO THEIR
THEIR SENTENCES LET'S SAY TEN
YEARS BUT BECAUSE OF DIFFERENT
KINDS OF CREDITS ARE ABLE TO BE
RELEASED IN SEVEN YEARS- AND I.
WOULD ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
AND AGAIN IT'S A LITTLE
THEORETICAL BECAUSE IF YOU'RE
NOT INCARCERATED- BY YOU KNOW
YOU OBVIOUSLY WOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO THOSE TO THOSE CREDITS I AM
I WOULD ASK THAT YOU EXPLORE
HELD MAYBE. DOT CONCEPTS- COULD
BE INCORPORATED BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW I THINK IT'S DRAFTED AS
WHAT THE MAXIMUM SENTENCE CAN
BE AND WE KNOW THAT MOST PEOPLE
DON'T SERVE THE MAXIMUM
SENTENCE- THEY SERVE SOMETHING
LESS THAN THAT- OF BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT GOOD ENOUGH BECAUSE
CREDITS OR WHATEVER ELSE- AND I
WOULD LIKE LIKE TO SEE THE BILL
INCORPORATE. THAT POSSIBILITY
SO THEY'RE NOT SO THE DOG
TOPPED THE YOU'RE GONNA PUT IF
NEEDED GUARD ROSEN FOR HIS
AUTOMATICALLY INTO THE HIGH
RANGE OF THE SENTENCE I KNOW
IT'S COMPLICATED- ADAM I KNOW
WE'D BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
ON THAT- BUT I'D I'D LIKE TO
SEE THAT. BOMBING CORPORATE ED-
INTO YOU OPEN THE LOCK COVERS.
YEAH JUST ON THAT IT AND I DO
THE I'M NOT SURE FOR D. A.
STILL ON THE LINE WE HAVE OUR
DEPUTY YOLO COUNTY CHIEF DEPUTY
JONATHAN RAVEN HERE COULD
CLARIFY MY UNDERSTANDING IS
IT'S A KIND OF A SWEET SPOT OF
WHO WOULD. WHO WOULD
PARTICIPATE IN THIS IS A NOT
MISDEMEANORS. THESE ARE NOT
SERIOUS CRIMES AND FELONIES SO
THESE AREN'T YOUR LONGER
SENTENCES. SO THE SHORTER
SENTENCES ANYWAY JUST BY THE
FACT OF THE TIME THEY ARE. THE
DURATION OF THE OF THE
TREATMENT. IT WOULDN'T BE THE
E. WOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
GET CREDITS AND HAVE A LOWER
SPENT TIME IS THAT CORRECT.
MYSTERY THAT IS CORRECT AND- I
THINK YEAH BOTH THE OR RIGHT
ON- BY OPERATIONAL LOG THE THIS
POPULATION WOULD BE CONSIDERED
IN CUSTODY EVEN THOUGH THEY
MIGHT BE IN. A RESIDENCE- BUT
THEY CAN'T LEAVE OF COURSE- AND
SO BY OPERATION F LAW THEY
WOULD STILL GET ALL THEIR
CREDITS AND I BELIEVE FOR THE
AUTHOR THAT IS CERTAINLY THE
INTENT. THAT THEY DO KNOW MORE
TIME THAN THEY WOULD DO IF THEY
WERE IN CUSTODY- AND CREDITS
WOULD COUNT IN THAT REGARD AND
HOW HELLO THE CREDITS BE
DETERMINED IF YOU'RE A NEW
TREATMENT SETTING AS OPPOSED TO
A CARCERAL SETTING. EXACTLY THE
SAME BUT IF YOU THAT IF YOU'RE
COMPLYING WITH THE TREE MAN
AND- AND NOT HAVING VIOLATIONS
THAN YOU GET CREDITS THAT
REDUCE. THE AMOUNT OF TIME YOU
WOULD SPEND IN THE TREATMENT
SETTING I THINK IF YOU'RE IN
THE SECURE TREATMENT SETTING NO
MATTER WHAT. YOU WOULD GET THE
CREDITS I MEAN BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE IN JAIL- IT YOU DON'T
GET CREDITS FOR GOOD BEHAVIOR
YOU GET AUTOMATIC CREDITS SO
SIMILAR THAT IF YOU WERE IN THE
SECURE. TREATMENT FACILITY YOU
WOULD AUTOMATICALLY GET
CREDITS. IRWIN I DEFECT
CLARIFIED- THE OTHER COUNTIES
IN TERMS OF THE SENTENCE
BECAUSE SOMETIMES. YOU MAY
MAYBE YOUR IT'S A FELONY FOR
AUTO BURGLARY BUSES PICK ONE OF
THE FELONY AUTO BURGLARY. FACT
THAT COULD QUALIFY- SOMEONE
MIGHT HAVE PRIORS TO THE END UP
HAVING. ENHANCEMENTS OR OTHER
THINGS SO- IN TERMS OF FAN AND
I I'VE I SHOULD'VE GONE BACK
AND LOOKED. AT THIS BEFORE- BUT
IN TERMS. WHEN WE SAY OKAY HAVE
TO SPEND AMOUNT OF TIME ENTRY.
BOB IS AT THE BASE SENTENCE OR
IS IT- BASINS PLUS ANY
ENHANCEMENTS. TO INCLUDE
ENHANCEMENTS HI- I WOULD MY
TAKE ON A IS THAT THEY SHOULD
BE LIMITED TO THE BAY SENTENCE
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
ENHANCEMENTS ARE. AND WE SHOULD
BE GETTING RID OF A LOT OF OUR
ANNOUNCEMENTS I THINK AND YOU
MAY DISAGREE WITH ME ON THIS I
THINK ENHANCEMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ATROCIOUS AND
DATE AND UP TURNING. WHAT WOULD
BE A REASONABLE SENTENCE FOR-
YOU KNOW FOR NONVIOLENT FELONY
INTO SOMETHING MUCH MUCH
GREATER- AND SO I WOULD REQUEST
THAT THIS BE LIMITED TO. THE
BASE CENTER AND SEN AND WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT MAYBE LIKE WHAT
WOULD BE LIKE SAY A TWO YEAR
SENTENCE IT TURNS INTO A SEVEN
OR EIGHT YEAR SENTENCE- YOU
KNOW THE IDEA OF SAYING YOU
HAVE TO SOMEONE HAVE TO AGREE
TO A YEAR'S WORTH OF. DRUG
TREATMENT- IS ARRIVING COULD
GET ON REASONABLE AND SO I'D
LIKE TO SEE A GUARD RAIL AND-
THAT. IT'S OF A SHORTER YOU
KNOW THE BAY SENTENCE OR
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT JUST.
LEAVING SOMEONE IN FOR A LONG
TIME AND I SAY ALL THIS SO I'M
GOING TO I'M GOING TO. I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT MOVING THE
SENATE COMMITTEE TODAY. I'M
BECAUSE I KNOW THE AUTHOR IS
OPERATING IN GOOD FAITH THAT I
KNOW WERE. WORKERS VALUES LIE
IN TERMS OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM- BUT I I'M GONNA WANT TO
LOOK AT THIS WHEN IT COMES BACK
ON THE FLOOR- AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT- YOU KNOW I JUST
WANT TO PUT OUT THERE THAT I
THINK WOULD BE IMPORTANT. FOR
ME TO SEE GUARDRAILS AROUND
MAKING SURE THIS DOESN'T GO ON.
FOREVER NEVER BECAUSE I THINK
YOU CAN PROBABLY IN THE SUMMER
COMING FROM. YOUR OWN STATE
AUTO BURGLARY FELONY THAT WAS
DRUG RELATED MAYBE THE PERSON
DOES HAVE A HISTORY- BUT IT
TURNS OUT TO YOUR SENSE INTO
SOME MUCH LONGER SENTENCE. THAT
MIGHT BE AN EXCESSIVE AMOUNT OF
TIME. FOR DRUG TREATMENT SO IS
THAT SOMETHING THEY ARE. OPEN
TO. WORKING ON OKAY- THE- HI
PLEASE SEND MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
COME IN THIS IS YOU KNOW IT'S
IMPORTANT- DISCUSSION- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
JUDGE. AND THE JUDGE AB ONE OF
THE CONCERNS THE OPPOSITION HAS
EXPRESSED WHICH I UNDER I AGREE
WITH THEM AND I THINK THE BILL.
ADDRESSES OUT BUT MAYBE IT CAN
BE CLEAR. IS THAT JUDGES SHOULD
BE HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WHO
ARE. SERVE FORMULATING WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE TREATMENT AS NOT A
JUDGE WHO MAY OR MAY NOT BE AN
EXPERT IN THE AREA. I THINK THE
BILL HAS LANGUAGE THAT THE
JUDGE'S DETERMINATION IS
BOUNDED BY THE RECOMMENDATIONS.
OF HEALTH PROFESSIONALS CAN YOU
JUST COMMENT ON- EITHER THE
AUTHOR OR THE WITNESS ABOUT
WHAT HEALTH. STRESS HOW HOW
RIGID THAT BOUNDING IS BECAUSE
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT FOR
JUDGE. NOT TO BE ABLE TO GO
BEYOND WHAT THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ARE RECOMMENDING.
BUT KEEP IN MIND THAT THE THAT
THE JUDGE WILL BE A PLEA. FOR
GOES TO COURT THERE WILL BE A
JUDGMENT. AND SO AFTER THAT
THEN THE DA. WORKING WITH THAT
THAT HEALTH PROFESSIONALS COULD
COME BACK AND SAY BEFORE THIS
INDIVIDUAL GOES IN SEARCH OR
SENTENCE HERE'S ANOTHER OPTION
FOR YOU SO IT'S AFTER THE FACT
AND- YOU WANNA CLARIFY MYSTERY
MARK YET SO. SENATOR TRUST ME
WHEN I TELL YOU THAT- WE ALSO
DON'T WANT JUDGES MAKING THAT
CALL- WE WANT TO HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO MAKE THAT CALL
AND- MAKE THE ASSESSMENT. AND
MAKE TE RECOMMENDATION TO THE-JUDGE WE DON'T WANT JUDICIAL
ACTIVISM- WE DON'T WANT JUDGES
MAKING THE DECISION- THAT MAY
MAKE SOME JUDGES UNCOMFORTABLE
BUT IN THIS CASE WE WANT TO BE
IRON CLAD WE WANT THE LEVEL-
AND HEAD OF TREATMENT- TO BE
BASED ON. THE RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE EXPERTS THE HEALTH
CARE. ACTIVATORS I'D LIKE TO
BECOME MORE WHICH IS MAKING
SURE THAT THAT IS REALLY CHRIS
CRYSTAL CLEAR IN THE BILL AND
JUST TO MUCH TWO MORE QUICK
THINGS IF- LET'S SAY THE
PERSON'S JAIL SENTENCE- IS FIVE
YEARS AND SAID THAT THEY AND
THEY OPT FOR THE RESIDENTIAL OR
THIS BLOCK TREATMENT AND LET'S
SAY AFTER TWO AND A HALF FOR
THREE YEARS. IT THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TURN THIS PERSON
HAS. LIKE TO HEAD OUT OF THE
BALLPARK AND IS LIKE JUST DOING
SO GREAT- WE CAN THIS PERSON
HAS SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED- OF
DRUG. TREATMENT OR
REHABILITATION. IS A PERSON
HAVE TO THEN SERVE THE REST OF
THE TIME IN PRISON OR COULD THE
PERSON BE RELEASED BEFORE THE
END OF THE PRISON TERM YES
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION CENTER
AND FIRST OFF ON A FIVE YEAR
SENTENCE THAT INDIVIDUAL LONG
BEACH SERVING HALF THAT TIME
RIGHT BUT- WE DON'T ENVISION
SOMEONE SPENDING A YEAR TWO
YEARS THREE YEARS FOUR YEARS IN
A TREATMENT FACILITY- IF IT YOU
KNOW IT WOULD PROBABLY BE- MUCH
LESS TIME. THAT THEY WOULD- GET
BETTER AND THEN BASED ON
ASSESSMENT BY THE HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS- ONCE THEY DECIDE
THAT THEY NO LONGER NEED TO BE
THERE THEN THEN THEY SHOULDN'T
BE THERE BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE
ALSO SHOULDN'T BE IN A
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT FACILITY
THEY DON'T NEED INPATIENT AND
THAT THAT WOULDN'T BE FOR THEM
EITHER YOU DON'T WANT A HIGHER
LEVEL OF CLEAR YOU WANT THE
LOWEST LEVEL OF CARE. AND IN
THIS CASE OF SOMEONE- HIT OUT
OF THE PARK AS YOU SAY AND GOT
WELL THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
FINISH THEIR SENTENCE AND BE
DONE AND HAVE THEIR CASE- THEIR
CONVICTION EXPUNGED WHEN YOU
SAY FINANCES SOUNDS WHAT DO YOU
MEAN. AB OUT OF CUSTODY OUT OF
ANY TYPE OF CUSTOMER. SO IF
THEY'RE SENTENCED TO FIVE YEARS
FOR THE SENTENCES FIVE YEARS
THEY OPT FOR THIS ALTERNATIVE.
AND THEN AFTER NINE MONTHS. OF
TWO OF TWO OF THETREATMENT.
THEIR DECLARED LIKE YOU YOU'VE
SUCCEEDED. RELATED TO HIM MAYBE
THREE MORE MONTHS IN A STEP
DOWN FACILITY. SO THAT WOULD BE
A YEAR. THAN THEY WOULD BE OUT-OF CUSTODY IN ONE YEAR AND SET
UP A FIVE YEAR SENTENCE
CORRECT. OKAY. OKAY AND I THINK
MAYBE WE CAN LOOK AT THE
LANGUAGE JUST AGAIN MAKE SURE
THAT THAT IS A CLEAR. AND IT'S
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE
DETERMINING WHETHER THE PERSON
IS SUCCESSFULLY- HAS SIX HAS
SUCCEEDED ABSOLUTELY BAPPA
FINALS WHO WHICH HEALTH. WHO IN
PARTICULAR MAKES A FINAL
DECISION. IT WOULD PROBABLY BE-
TREATMENT PROVIDERS AND ARE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY IN YOUR COUNTY OKAY. I'M
GONNA THAT'S ANOTHER ONE. WANT
TO GO BACK AND MAKE SURE THAT.
IT'S CLEAR ENOUGH FINALLY I
WANT TO SAY ONE THING I REALLY
LIKE ABOUT THIS. IS THAT WHEN
THE PERSON SUCCESSFULLY.
COMPLETES THE PROGRAM. THEIR
CONVICTION NOT JUST A
CONVICTION BUT I THINK THEIR
ENTIRE RECORD. OF FOR THIS
PARTICULAR CRIME IS COMPLETELY
X. IS EXPUNGED. AUTOMATICALLY I
THINK IT'S. OF THE JUDGE. SHALL
DO THE- AND- AND THEN THE JUDGE
HAS THIS. TO GO BACK. AND
EXPLAINS PREVIOUS DRUG
CONVICTIONS ON RELATED TO THE
CURRENT ONE- SO THAT'S A
POSITIVE IN TERMS OF GETTING
PEOPLE. BACK ON TRACK WHERE IS
IF YOU JUST COMPLETE YOUR
CONVICTION AND YUNIS'S YOUR
JAIL SENTENCE YOU KNOW
EXPANSION IS NOT AN AUTOMATIC
THING BY ANY STRETCH OF THE
IMAGINATION SO- ANYWAY I THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THE AUTHOR AND THE
WINDOWS- I THINK SOME OF THESE
ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED IN THE
BILL SOME OF THEM MIGHT BE NEED
TO BE. PUBLIC CLARIFIED AND
MAYBE WE COULD EVEN WORK WITH
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
WITH THE CHAIR- ON SOME OF
THESE CLARIFYING AND
MAINTAINING AMENDMENTS- AND
WITH THAT I'LL BE SUPPORTING
MOVING THIS BILL. FORWARD-
TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR WARNER
CENTER COME ON. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
FOR ASKING- A LOT OF QUESTIONS
THAT I TO- WAS THINKING ABOUT I
HAVE TO SAY WHEN I. WAS READING
THIS BILL AND I JOKE WITH THE
AUTHOR- YOU KNOW IT MADE ME
THINK ABOUT ONE FLEW OVER THE
CUCKOO'S NEST WHICH- IS NOT. A
GREAT MOVIE BECAUSE IT ACTUALLY
TALKS ABOUT HOW YOU WIND UP IN
A FACILITY- AND YOU'RE NOT ABLE
TO GET OUT- IN ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT HAPPEN. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME LISTENING TO THE
OPPOSITION. I HAVE TO BE REALLY
HONEST. AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR EVERYONE TO HEAR
THIS YOU KNOW THE REALITY IS
THAT A THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE OUT IN THE WORLD WHO ARE
ADDICTS. N. B. THERE ARE A LOT
OF PEOPLE OUT IN THE WORLD WHO
DO COMMIT CRIMES AND NOT EVERY
CRIME THAT IS COMMITTED. COMES
FROM A PLACE OF TRAUMA- AND I'M
JUST SAYING AS ABLACK WOMAN I
THINK WE HAVE TO COULD NOT USE
THAT- AND LEAN ON THAT EVERY
SINGLE TIME SOME PEOPLE DO MAKE
REALLY BAD DECISIONS. AND NEED.
HELP AND SOMETIMES THEY NEED
HELP THAT THEY DON'T WANT- TO
HELP THEM GET BETTER OR TO GET
IN THE PLACE WHERE THEY ARE
ABLE TO MAKE A DIFFERENT SET OF
DECISIONS AND PUT THEMSELVES-
IN DIFFERENT KINDS OF
CIRCUMSTANCES TO ALLOW THEM TO
MAKE BETTER DECISIONS- I ALSO
HAVE TO SAY I THINK ONE OF THE
MAJOR REASONS THAT THIS BILL
HAS A LOT OF OPPOSITION IS
BECAUSE THERE'S PROBABLY LACK
OF TRUST WITH THE SOURCE WITH
THE SPONSOR- AND FOLKS ARE NOT
REALLY INTERESTED IN YOU KNOW
WORKING WITH D. A.'S OFFICES
BECAUSE MORE OFTEN THAN NOT-
YOU KNOW TO BE QUITE FRANK.
THOSE OFFICES ARE THE ONES THAT
ARE OPPOSING A LOT OF THE BILLS
THAT ARE FOCUSED ON CRIMINAL
LEGAL REFORM- END. IF WE ARE
GOING TO OPPOSE SOMETHING WHAT
IS THE ALTERNATIVE YOU KNOW
AND- HOW VIABLE IS IT TOO
REALLY ADDRESSING THE ISSUE- SO
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT BECAUSE
THIS IS IT'S- IT'S NOT
COMPLICATED BUT IT'S HARD
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY HARD FOR
FOLKS TO SAY PEOPLE MAKE BAD
DECISIONS PEOPLE DO BAD THINGS
THAT PEOPLE NEED HELP AND
SOMETIMES PEOPLE DON'T WANT THE
HELP. THAT THEY HAVE TO GUESTS
FOR THAT THEY NEED- AND I'M
SPEAKING AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
ADDICTION IN MY FAMILY ANYWAYS
HAVE FOLKS WERE INCARCERATED
BECAUSE OF ADDICTION- SO DON'T
NOBODY TELL ME THAT I DON'T
KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT. SO
I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS AND I
SPOKE WITH THE AUTHOR AND HE
SAID THAT YOU WERE GOING TO BE
HERE AND SO MISTER CHAIR IF YOU
DON'T MIND I WILL BE ADDRESSING
SOME OF MY QUESTIONS ALSO TO-
THE USER. SO A I WANTED TO KNOW
HOW THIS IS GOING TO BE FUNDED
BECAUSE MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THERE IS CURRENTLY SO IT'S
NOT ABOUT CONSTRUCTING A NEW
FACILITY BUT THERE IS CURRENTLY
A JUVENILE FACILITY THAT IS NOT
BEING USED AND SO THE GOAL IS
TO FIGURE OUT MAYBE NOT THE
GOAL BUT HOW ELSE COULD YOU USE
THIS PARTICULAR FACILITY SO
EIGHT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT NEW
CONSTRUCTION BECAUSE THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS REFERENCED
BY. THE OPPOSITION. IT'S NOT
NEW CONSTRUCTION CENTER AND-
THAT JUVENILE FACILITY HAS BEEN
TAKEN OFF THE TABLE BECAUSE IT
WAS CONTROVERSIAL WE THOUGHT IT
WOULD BE A GOOD WAY TO HAVE A
SOFTER SETTING. WITH THE
OPPOSITION UNCOMFORTABLE WITH
THAT- WE TOOK THAT OFF THE
TABLE SO WHAT WE ENVISION IS.
AS I SAID. HOUSE SO LIKE WE
HAVE A PLACE CALLED WALTER'S
HOUSE WALTER'S HOUSE HAS ABOUT
THIRTY BEDS IN IT- AS A MATTER
OF FACT THAT DIRECTOR OF ALTERS
HOW SPOKE IN SUPPORT. IN THE
ASSEMBLY OF THIS BILL AND
WALTER'S HOUSE MAYBE MOVING
ACROSS TOWN CLOSER ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY. THAT
BUILDING MAY BE OPEN- AND
THAT'S THE TYPE OF THE-
BUILDING. OR FACILITY THAT I A
OR THAT WE ENVISION WE WOULD BE
USING- IT WOULD BE SECURE IT
WOULD BE LOCKED. BUT IT WOULD
BE A SOFT FACILITY LIKE A LARGE
HOUSE. OR APARTMENT BUILDING OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT- DO AS AS-
MISTER ISAAC SAID. NO BARS NO
GUNS NO GUARDS IT'S NOTHING
LIKE THAT IT'S A MUST MUCH
SOFTER FACILITY. AND WE'RE
REALLY NOT TALKING ABOUT
BUILDING. MORE CELLS BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT'S NOT THE WAY TO GO.
SO OKAY THAT WAS MY SECOND
QUESTION. MMHM THIS IS A LEVINE
DOESN'T HAVE CELLS. CORRECT
RIGHT OKAY- BECAUSE I HAVE.
VISITED SOME PLACES IN OTHER
COUNTRIES WHERE IT'S A MUCH
SOFTER FACILITIES SIMILAR TO
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
ALMOST LIKE AN APARTMENT
BUILDING BUT PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO
COME AND GO AT NIGHT MAYBE THEY
HAVE TO COME IN AND STAY- SO I
GUESS I DON'T KNOW IF THERE IS
AN OPTION OR IF THAT. IF
THERE'S SOME SORT OF STRUCTURE
THAT'S FLEXIBLE DEPENDING ON
YOUR PROGRESS- IF YOU STILL
HAVE TO REMAIN LOCKED UP
BECAUSE I ALSO THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WITH FOLKS WHO ARE
RECUPERATING OR RECOVERING FROM
ADDICTION IS HOW THEY'RE ABLE
TO DEAL IN THE REAL WORLD. IN
THE REAL WORLD ISN'T
NECESSARILY A LOCKED FACILITY
FROM TEAM MINDS THEY DO HAVE TO
SORT OF INTERACT WITH SOME OF
THE YOU KNOW. FIGURING OUT HOW
TO MANAGE THEIR TRIGGERS
OUTSIDE- SO I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS- ALSO
OR COULD BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION BECAUSE I KNOW
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT THE
OPPOSITION- HAVE IS THAT. IT'S
NOT IT'S A JAIL NOT POSING AS A
JAIL BECAUSE YOU'RE STILL NOT
ABLE TO GO AND SOME OF YOUR
CIVIL LIBERTIES ARE- TAKEN. SO
AS IS THAT UNDER CONSIDERATION
I GUESS BASED ON PROGRESS THAT
YOU'RE ABLE TO MAKE UNDERTAKEN
WITHIN THIS TREATMENT FACILITY.
SO THE ONLY WAY CENTER YOU
COULD EQUATE THIS TO JAIL IS
THE FACT THAT THE PERSON CAN'T
COME AND GO AS THEY PLEASE
WHICH IS WHAT YOU JUST SAID AND
CENTER AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW. IN
MOST RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES YOU
HAVE A BLACKOUT PERIOD AND
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO LEAVE.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO AVOID LIKE
THOSE RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
WITH BLACKOUTS IS. THE
INDIVIDUAL HAVING A CHANGE OF
HEART- THAT SAME EVENING OR
THAT SAME DAY THE NEXT DAY AND
LEAVING- SO. IT WOULD BE LOCKED
COULD WE HAVE STEPPED DOWN
WHERE MAYBE PEOPLE COULD COME
AND GO AS THEY PLEASE JUST LIKE
THEY DO AT RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES AS YOU. AS YOU.
SUCCEED YES WE COULD POSSIBLY
CONSIDER THAT- BUT INITIALLY-
WE ENVISION THAT IT WOULD BE A
PLACE WHERE. THE PEOPLE INSIDE
COULD NOT COME AND GO. AS A
PLEASE. SO WHAT ELSE WOULD BE
HAPPENING IN THIS FACILITY.
IT'S JUST LIKE ANY OTHER
RESIDENTIAL FACILITY THEY WOULD
HAVE- BUT INDIVIDUAL THERAPY
SESSIONSTHEY WOULD HAVE GROUP
THERAPY THEY WOULD LEARN LIFE
SKILLS THEY WOULD LEARN HOW-
HOW TO HOW TO SUCCEED ON THE
OUTSIDE- YOU KNOW WITHOUT GOING
BACK TO. TO USING- THEY WOULD
LEARN ABOUT THEIR TRIGGERS THEY
WOULD LEARN ABOUT- SAFETY PLANS
YOU KNOW ALL THESE DIFFERENT
THINGS IT WOULD BE VERY
INTENSIVE ALMOST LIKE AN
INTENSIVE OUTPATIENT PROGRAM-
BUT IT WOULD BE IMPATIENT AND
YOU KNOW YOU YOU THE THING IS
YOU DON'T IT'S VERY TIRING- TO
HAVE ALL THIS THERAPY AND ALL
THESE GROUPS THAT WE DON'T WANT
TO. OVERDO IT WITH THEM BUT-
THEY'RE PROBABLY UP THE ALSO-
DIFFERENT ACTIVITIES THAT HAVE
THAT REALLY HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH- THE TREATMENT SO THEY
WOULD BE KEPT BUSY- THEY WOULD
HAVE CERTAINLY FREE TIME BUT
THEY WOULD BE DOING A LOT OF
WORK ON TO GET BETTER- I WANT
TO ECHO SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO MENTION ABOUT THE
JUDGE BEING ABLE TO DETERMINE
THE LENGTH OF TREATMENT AS I'D
READ- THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
IT SAYS JUST AFTER IT SAYS THAT
THE JUDGE IS ABLE TO DETERMINE
THE LENGTH OF TREATMENT- AFTER
BEING INFORMED BY. ASSESSMENTS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS OF
TREATMENT PROVIDERS WHICH
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN THAT
THEY HAVE TO- ADHERE TO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND SO I WOULD
HOPE THAT THERE COULD BE SOME
TIGHTENING WITH REGARDS TO
THAT- BECAUSE TO YOUR POINT YOU
DON'T WANT ACTIVISTS JUDGES BUT
I THINK- IT'S ABOUT
INDIVIDUALIZED AND CUSTOMIZED.
TREATMENT PROGRAMS AND THE
REALITY IS THAT MOST OFTEN WHEN
JUDGES ARE SENTENCING. IT'S
THEIR FORMULAS YOU KNOW IT'S
LIKE THREE YEARS FIVE YEARS
NINE YEARS PLUS. AND SO THIS
ISN'T THAT I DON'T THINK WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE IT THAT SO. I
WOULD JUST LIKE THERE TO BE A
LITTLE MORE CLARITY WITH
REGARDS TO- HOW THE
DETERMINATIONS ARE MADE BECAUSE
THIS DOES GIVE A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY TO JUDGES AND WE
KNOW THAT OFTENTIMES AIR ON
SOMETHING THAT'S MUCH MORE
CONSERVATIVE- SO I WOULD LIKE
FOR THAT TO BE RE LOOKED AT
AGAIN AND THEN. HOW SUCCESS IS
DEFINED TREATMENT SUCCESSES
ALSO REALLY VAGUE- WHATDOES
SUCCESS LOOK LIKE THAT YOU
NEVER RELAPSE THAT YOU DON'T
RELAPSE WHILE YOU'RE THERE WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU COME OUT IF
YOU COME OUT AND THEN YOU
RELAPSE ARE YOU PICKED UP WHAT
WHAT'S THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THIS TREATMENT CENTER AND CDC
ARE IN PROBATION. I WOULD SAY
THAT I DON'T THINK THAT
PROBATION IS NECESSARILY
TRAINED NOR CDC ARE- TRAIN TO
KIND OF DO THAT. MONITORING AND
SUPPORT AS IT WHEN SOMEONE GETS
OUT- IF YOU'RE TRYING TO MOCK
YOU KNOW HELP THEM CONTINUE.
THERE SUCCESSFUL POSTTREATMENT
JOURNEY SO CAN YOU KIND OF
THREE TO THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THIS TREATMENT A AND C.
D. C. R. AND B. PROBATION. SO I
THINK M. NONE OF US WANT CDC
ARE INVOLVED IN THIS OTHER THAN
THE REPORTING THAT'S THE ONLY
REASON WHY THEY'RE MENTIONED-
IN THE BILL SO- I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE NONE OF US WANT THAT WE
DON'T NEED CITY SARGSYAN. CDC
ARE INVOLVED. THE MONITORING
AND THIS IS KIND OF AND- I'M
TRYING TO USE THE RIGHT
LANGUAGE THE MONITORING WOULD
BE DONE BY THE HEALTH CARE
PRACTITIONERS. BUT OUR- HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
DIRECTOR SHE HAD A LOT OF
REALLY GOOD FEEDBACK FOR US IN
TERMS OF MAKING TO BUILD MORE
MORE PALATABLE. AND HELPING US
WITH THE LANGUAGE AND WHAT SHE
TOLD US WHICH MAKES TOTAL SENSE
IS THAT- PROBATION SHOULD IS
THAT THE HEALTH CARE
PRACTITIONER SHOULD NOT BE
SUPERVISING. THEIR CLIENTS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO HAVE THIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEIR CLIENTS
AND IF THEY START GOING TO THE
JUDGE AND SAYING. YOU KNOW. JOE
IS NOT FOLLOWING THE TREATMENT
PLAN THEN THEY'RE GOING TO.
LOSE THAT RELATIONSHIP SO THE-
MONITORING WOULD BE DONE BY.
THAT HEALTH PRACTITIONERS BUT
THE SUPERVISION WOULD BE DONE
BY PROBATION AND THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE
AMENDED OR CHANGED AT SOME
POINT. UPON THE RECOMMENDATION
OF OUR HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. DIRECTOR YOU HAD A
FEW MORE QUESTIONS AS WELL SO
YOU ANSWERED THE QUESTION ABOUT
CCR. I'M LISTENING TO YOUR
RESPONSE ABOUT PROBATION. BUT
YOU KNOW THE OTHER REALITY IS
THAT I OFTENTIMES PROBATION YOU
KNOW THEIR TECHNICAL VIOLATIONS
THAT COME FROM PROBATIONERS
RIGHT. NOT PROVISIONS BUT FROM
THE PROBATION DEPARTMENT. AND
IT'S REALLY HARD TO SORT OF ON
LEARNED BEHAVIOR RIGHT BASED ON
HOW YOU RUN YOUR DEPARTMENT IT
JUST IS. AND SO DO YOU WOULD
NEED TO TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION BECAUSE THE GOAL
IS NOT TO. CREATE A NEW- SYSTEM
BUT THEN AN ADVERT ONLY KIND OF
CREATE THESE FINALS AT LEAD
BACK TO THE OLD SYSTEM THE IDEA
IS TO CREATE A NEW SYSTEM AND
THEN PILOT THIS OUT. IN A WAY
THAT'S LIKE USING DIFFERENT
PARTNERS. DO YOU KNOW REGARD
TRAINING. THEM TO DO DIFFERENT
THINGS OR MAYBE JUST NOT EVEN
USING THEM AT ALL. SO THAT YOU
CAN CREATE DIFFERENT OUTCOMES
B. YOU KNOW BECAUSE THE OTHER
REALITY IS IF YOU'VE BEEN
CONVICTED OF THIS AND YOU OPT
TO DO THE TREATMENT. CHANCES
ARE YOU'RE NOT A FIRST TIMER
CHANCES ARE YOU'VE ALREADY HAD
SOME PRE EXISTING RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE PROBATION DEPARTMENT.
SO CHANCES ARE. YOU DON'T HAVE
A GREAT SORT OF RELATIONSHIP OR
THERE ISN'T A HIGH LEVEL OF
CREDIBILITY WITH THAT
DEPARTMENT- OR WITH SOME OF THE
FOLKS THAT ARE WORKING IN
THERE. THAT'S NOT GOING TO HELP.
RIGHT SO- WE EXPECT RELAPSES
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED WE EXPECT
TECHNICAL VIOLATIONS IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE AN ELEVATOR GOING
TO THE TOP GOING TO BE AN
ESCALATOR AND SO WE HAVE A
MENTAL HEALTH COURT WE HAVE AN
ADDICTION INTERVENTION COURT-
THESE ARE FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE
BEING TREATED SAFELY OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY BUT IN THAT COURT WE
HAVE A TEAM WE ALL WORK
TOGETHER SO- HE ALSO HIT THE
NAIL ON THE HEAD WHEN YOU SAID-
ACTUALLY WAS YOU CENTER THIS
DISTRUST AND THAT'S A REAL
SHAME THAT WE HAVE THAT- JUST
BECAUSE THE DA. HAS WRITTEN A
LANGUAGE FOR A BILL IT'S A
SHAME THAT PEOPLE CAN GET
BEHIND IT I KNOW IN OUR COUNTY
AND OUR PROGRAMS WE HAVE A LOT
OF TRUST. AND THAT'S WHAT MAKES
THEM WORK SO THE BOTTOM LINE
IS- SOMEONE AS A TECHNICAL
VIOLATION SOMEONE HAS A RELAPSE
THAT'S NO REASON TO KICK HIM
OUT OF THE PROGRAM IF THEY
COMPLETELY DISENGAGE. AND DON'T
FOLLOW ANY OF THE TREATMENT
PLANS AFTER AFTER OPPORTUNITIES
TO DO THAT. THEN MAYBE THEY
SHOULDN'T BE THERE AND MAYBE
THEY RE IN A SENSE BY THEIR
ACTIONS THEY'RE OPTING NOT TO
BE THERE RIGHT. SO AS I SAID.
WE YOU ANYONE IN A TREATMENT
FACILITY WHICH THIS IS EXPECTS
RELAPSES THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENS. HOUSES FUNDED- SO THE
FUNDING IS NOT QITE CLEAR YET
BUT- I KNOW WHAT WE WERE
LOOKING TO THE- OPIOID CELLUM
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT OF COURSE
THERE HAVE TO BE AN
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THAT- THAT'S
ONE OF THE OPTIONS. OKAY I
APPRECIATE YOU ANSWERING THESE
QUESTIONS- I AM. YOU KNOW I'M
PROBABLY GOING TO WAIT UNTIL IT
GETS TO THE FLOOR BECAUSE MY
HOPE IS THAT I CAN SEE SOME OF
THE RESPONSES TO SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT I ASKED AND ALSO
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT THE
SENATOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO ASK
BUT I DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT GETS OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE-
BECAUSE I THOUGHT I- HAVE FAITH
IN THE AUTHOR- AND SOMETIMES
YOU JUST HAVE TO. MAKE RADICAL.
CREATE RADICAL OUT
ALTERNATIVES- TO GET DIFFERENT
OUTCOMES- SO I APPRECIATE IT.
BUT I TO IN LIKE. JUMPING INTO.
A DIFFERENT- A POOL WATER AND
SO WANT TO MAKE SURE NOBODY
GETS BURNT OUT. WE ALL ARE
THANK YOU. YEAH OF COURSE. I
JUST APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR RING
IN THIS MEASURE FORWARD AND-
KEEPING AT A LOCAL PILOT
PROGRAM I APPRECIATE THE PILOT
PROGRAM SPECIALLY- IN THIS
CASE- I THINK ONE OF MY BIGGEST
CONCERNS IN THE PAST WITH BUT
CERTAIN PRIVATE PURPOSE I HAVE
BEEN PRESENTED WITH THE
COMMITTEE- IS THE- THE
PERCEIVED- CULTURE THAT COULD
BE PERMEATED BY. PROMOTING
CERTAIN BEHAVIORAL SO THAT'S MY
BIGGEST CONCERN THAT I HAVE BUT
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THIS
IS A LOCAL PRIVATE AT LOCAL
PILOT PROGRAM. AND APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT YOU FOLKS ARE-
TRYING TO BE CREATIVE AND THINK
OUTSIDE THE BOX. AND AN ISSUE
THAT IS UP FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND JERRY HAVE.
PREVALENT IN IN THE IN THE
COUNTY SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND I DON'T WANT TO BE
REDUNDANT BUT I THINK WE'VE
HEARD THE CONCERNS THAT HAS
BEEN RAISED- BY ALL MY
COLLEAGUES HERE AS IT RELATES
TO. THIS MEASURE AND- FOR THE
FACT THAT IT IS A PILOT PROGRAM
IS DISTRICTS SPECIFIC- LEADS ME
WILL A LITTLE BIT MORE COMFORT
AND MOVING AS MEASURE FOR BUT I
HAVE QUESTIONS. IS THERE A DRUG
COURT SYSTEM ANNUAL O'CONNOR.
THERE IS A DRUG COURT SYSTEM WE
DON'T CALL IT DRUG COURT WE
ACTUALLY CALL IT DICTION
INTERVENTION COURT AND WE HAVE
ALL SORTS OF SORTS OF
DIVERSIONARY PROGRAMS BUT FOR
SOMEONE TO GET INTO OUR
ADDICTION INTERVENTION COURT WE
HAVE A TEAM WE HAVE A TREATMENT
TEAM THAT ASSESSES THEM AND
RECOMMENDS WHETHER THEY'RE
SUITABLE FOR THE PROGRAM IN
ORDER FOR THEM TO BE SUITABLE
FOR THE PROGRAM. THEY HAVE TO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO GET THE
TREATMENT AND SUPERVISION IN
THE COMMUNITY N. FOR THIS
POPULATION WHO WOULD BUT FOR
HELP YELLOW BE SERVING TIME IN
JAIL OR PRISON- THEY'RE NOT THE
POPULATION THAT WOULD BE
SUITABLE FOR BEING TREATED IN
THE COMMUNITY. ALL RIGHT AND-
UNDERSTANDING THAT BOTH. BEING
RAISED IN A HOUSEHOLD BY A
NURSE SHOES STILL WITH A
DICTION AND DEALT WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS- ONE CARD FEELS THIS
MORE OF A COWORKERS AND THEN A
VOLUNTEER SITUATION SO CAN YOU
HELP EXPLAIN- THOSE CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED BY THOSE
ADVOCATE TO DO THIS WORK ON A
DAILY BASIS AND YOU WOULD
THINK. THEY WOULD BE STRONG
SUPPORTERS OF SUCH A PROGRAM
BUT THEY SEEM TO HAVE GREAT
CONCERN. AT ALL I'LL TAKE A
CRACK AT THAT- AGAIN THIS IS A
VOLUNTARY EFFORT. THAT WE DID
PUT IN THE BILL THAT SOMEONE
HAS ENOUGH SECOND THOUGHT HAD
BACKS OUT. THE DAY BEFORE ONCE
THEY ENTER THEY CAN THEY CAN
REVERT TO. BUT AGAIN THEY'RE
NOT REVERTING GOING BACK ON THE
CLOSER THEIR UNDERLYING
SENTENCE BUT ARGUE THAT MANY
TIMES LIKE AS SENATOR CONGRESS
SAID. MANY FAMILIES WE'VE WE'VE
HAD PEOPLE YOU HAD TO HAVE
INTERVENTIONS. THOSE ARE KIND
OF ARTICLE WORSENS OR THE
CONTROLLING SOMEONE TO MAKE A
DECISION PROBABLY. THIS ISN'T
YOU KNOW SAYING CHOOSE THIS OR
ELSE BUT IT'S PROVIDING I
THINK. AN OPTION WE'D LIKE
PEOPLE TO TAKE THIS OPTION
BECAUSE ONE THEY CAN GET
BETTER. FOR THEMSELVES FOR
THEIR FAMILY AND FOR A
COMMUNITY AND AS I TALKED WITH
SENATOR WIENER ABOUT EARLIER
RIGHT NOW ALL RIGHT WHEN IT
SAYS. THEY DOING THIS THEY
WOULD MOST LIKELY HAVE A LOT OF
A SHORTER TERM. IN IN THE
SYSTEM AS WELL SO. IT IT'S NOT-
COERCE WE INCENTIVIZED
HOPEFULLY PEOPLE TO MAKE THIS
DECISION AND I WOULD THINK IT'S
A SOUND DECISION AS WELL. AND
IF AND THE FLIP SIDE WHAT'S THE
ALTERNATE BEING INCARCERATED.
WITH NO TREATMENT WOULD
PROBABLY ACCESS TO DRUGS AND
FORTUNATELY IN OUR STATE PRISON
SYSTEM. IN COUNTY JAILS
UNFORTUNATE HAPPENS ANYWAY.
MMHM WILL THE WAS QUITE THE- I
DIDN'T THAT IT WOULD SHORTEN
YOUR TERM- IT WAS KIND OF LIKE
A LITTLE WHILE. THERE ON
WHETHER YOU WOULD HAVE A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME SIR BASED ON THE
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS IT SOONER
PALM HARBOR- SO I WOULD HOPE
THAT WE CAN DEFINE THAT THAT IF
A PERSON CLEARLY- COMPLETES THE
PROGRAM THAT HE OR SHE- WOULD
HAVE A REDUCE TIME TO BE SURE.
AND IT YOU KNOW- I SEE A NEED
FOR SOMETHING LIKE THIS BECAUSE
AS YOU STATED. THE MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE WHO GO TO PRISON WHO. GO
THERE WITH AN ADDICTION USUALLY
GET OUT WITH THAT SAME
ADDICTION BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
REAL REHABILITATION AND OUR
PRISON SYSTEMS IN OUR JAIL
SYSTEM SO THIS AFFORDS
OPPORTUNITY FOR REHABILITATION
I WOULD HOPE- AND REDUCED- YOU
KNOW- THEY RETURN RECIDIVISM SO
TO SPEAK- BUT YEAH THAT'S A LOT
OF CONCERNS AND I GUESS THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE SCENARIOS WHERE WE
HEAR OFTEN. IT'S BETTER TO HAVE
A BAD BILL WITH A GOOD AUTHOR
VERSUS A GOOD BILL IN ABOUT
AUTHOR HERE WE HAVE A GOOD
AUTHOR I WON'T CALL IT A BAD
BILL BUT IT TO BILL THAT WE ALL
AGREE STILL NEED TO MARK SO
IT'S BECAUSE OF THAT AUTHORS
REPUTATION AND HIS COMMITMENT
TO. DO THE RIGHT THING THAT HAS
LED ME TO GIVE THE CELL I
RECOMMENDATION WITH THE HOPES
THAT. OFFICE WE WILL ADDRESS
MANY OF THOSE CONCERNS THAT ARE
BEING RAISED IN THAT YOU WILL
WORK IN CONCERT WITH OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF ENSURING UP THE
LANGUAGE AND BUTTON IT UP A
LITTLE BIT- BEFORE IT GETS TO
HEALTH COMMITTEE SO WE MAKE
SURE WE ADDRESS ALL THOSE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
HERE TODAY THANK YOU. IF THAT'S
THE CASE OUR OUR FOR YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY CLOSE THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
APPRECIATE DEBATE AND AGAIN
THIS IS IT THIS IS A PILOT ONE
COUNTY WITH A FIVE YEAR SUNSET
AND CENTER THIS IS A PROBLEM
AND ALL ARE COUNTY SEDUCTION
AND REVOLVING DOOR. SO WORST
CASE SCENARIO THIS DOESN'T WORK
AND WE WILL BUT THAT'S CASE
SCENARIO IT'S A MODEL THAT WE
CAN BRING THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO BECAUSE WE REALIZED THE
ECSTATIC WORLD IS NOT WORKING
ANYWHERE YOU WALK OUTSIDE THE
STATE CAPITOL IN MY- OTHER
COUNTY RIGHT HERE. IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY YOU CAN SEE
LOUD AND CLEAR. YOU CAN SEE IT
FROM THE CAN HEAR IT TOO- AND-
I THINK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AND WE I WILL TAKE THE-
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH-
SENATORS WHO WIENER AND CALM
LAGER AND POTENTIAL YOURSELF
CENTER BRADFORD TO TEST TO BUT
NOT SOME OF THESE ISSUES AND
MAKE THIS BILL BETTER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ON THAT NOTE-
WE WILL LOOK FOR MOTIONS. FOR
MOVED CENTER IT'S BEEN MOVED
AND- WE WILL. MOVE IT ON TO A
DO PASS TO SENATE HOLE WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT AMENDMENTS
WILL BE TAKEN AND SENATE
HEALTH- MY CORRECT COUNCIL. I
DON'T THINK ANY AMOUNTS HAVE
BEEN AGREED UPON BUT THE
AUTHORS COMMITTED TO CONNECT
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
AND LOOK AT AMENDMENTS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD SO IF THAT'S THE
CASE. SANITIZES I'D TO THAT I
THINK WE HAD A REALLY GOOD
COLLOQUY AND I THINK WE HAVE AN
AGREEMENT THAT WILL BUT WE WILL
WORK TO TIGHTEN UP. A NUMBER OF
THESE ISSUES AND TO WORK ON MY
OFFICE WILL DEFINITELY ENGAGE
WITH PUBLIC SAFETY STAFFING
WITH THE AUTHOR- TO- TO YOU
KNOW TO COME UP WITH. HI MA'AM
AND SIR CAN BE TAKEN AND THE
WHOLE COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S- WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH US THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THE SECURITY COUNCIL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON A. B.
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO AB FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO BRADFORD ARE RADFORD
I'D SHOW BOTH I PROVOKE ICON
LAGER SKINNER WIENER. WIENER
AYE THE MEASURES OUT WILL LAVE
AN ON CALL FOR THOSE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER CARTER
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION FIRST
PATIENT NEXT UP WE HAVE MR
HOLDEN I APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE MR HOLDEN. COULD YOU
SHOP THROUGH ALL OF THAT AND-
WE PROMISE THAT. WE'LL MAKE
YOU'RE ABOUT TO STEM SHORT OF
THE PRISON. ALWAYS A PLEASURE
TO BE IN YOUR COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN AND A TO JOIN WITH THE
OTHER SENATORS AND- HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT OUR BILL
THIS AFTERNOON- TURN MEMBERS
TODAY I'M PRESENTING ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SIX. THE BILL THAT
SEEKS TO PROVIDE UNIVERSAL
MEASURES THAT ESTABLISH TWO
THINGS. WHAT IT MEANS FOR
POLICE OFFICER TO INTERVENE
WHEN WITNESSING AN EXCESSIVE
USE OF FORCE BY ANOTHER PEACE
OFFICER. AND TO CERTAIN
OUTCOMES FOR FAILURE TO
INTERVENE. MEMBERS WE WERE ALL
JUST MADE BY THE TRAGIC EVENTS
THAT LED TO THE UNTIMELY DEATH
OF GEORGE FLOYD. AND TO THEIR
CREDIT LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE
CONDEMNED THE ACTIONS OF THE
SUPERVISING OFFICER INVOLVED IN
THAT INCIDENT. THAT IS NOT WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT. THEIR
CHILDREN. THE SUPERVISING
OFFICER WAS CHARGED WITH
KILLING OF GEORGE FLOYD. BUT
JUSTICE FOR GEORGE FORD DOESN'T
REST IN HIS CONVICTION ALONE.
NOW THE COUNTRY HAS TURNED ITS
ATTENTION TO THE UPCOMING TRIAL
OF THE THREE OTHER OFFICERS.
MEMBERS I WOULD ARGUE THAT IN
THE DAYS WEEKS AND MONTHS
FOLLOWING THE TRAGIC EVENTS.
THAT THE PROTESTS AND
DEMONSTRATIONS THAT WE
WITNESSED THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. WE'RE NOT SAYING
REALLY FOCUS ON JUST THE
ACTIONS OF THE SUPERVISING
OFFICER. THE DEMONSTRATIONS
WERE ALSO PROTESTING THE FACT
THAT THE THREE ADDITIONAL
OFFICERS SIMPLY STOOD BY AND
WATCHED HIM DIE. THAT IS WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT. MEMBERS
CURRENT LAW AS WRITTEN SIMPLY
REQUIRES AN OFFICER HAS A DUTY
TO INTERVENE. HOWEVER THE
PROBLEM IS NOT HOWEVER THE
PROBLEM IS THAT NOTHING IN
CURRENT LAW ESTABLISHES FOR
EXPLAINS WHEN IN FACT A PEACE
OFFICER HAS INTERVENE. ABSENT
THIS UNDERSTANDING AT LEAST THE
PUBLIC UNINFORMED AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE ABILITY TO
DEFINE INTERVENTION HAS NGUYEN
WHATEVER EACH INDIVIDUAL PIECE
OFFICER DEEMS APPROPRIATE. FOR
THESE REASONS I PUT FORTH AB
TWENTY SIX. B. TWENTY SIX
CLARIFIES AND ESTABLISHES
INTERVENTION OR INTERCEDE TO
INCLUDE BUT NOT LIMITED TO THE
USE OF A DE ESCALATION
TECHNIQUES CONFRONTING THE
OFFICER APPLYING EXCESSIVE USE
OF FORCE. PHYSICALLY STOPPING
THE EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE WHEN
IN A POSITION TO DO SO.
ACCORDING IN DOCUMENTING THE
INCIDENT AND REAL TIME WITH
BODY CAMERAS AND REPORTING THE
INCIDENT TO DISPATCH OR TO THE
WATCH COMMANDER IN REAL TIME
STATING THE OFFENDING OFFICER'S
NAME. UNIT LOCATION TIME AND
SITUATION. ORDER TO ESTABLISH
THAT AN ATTEMPT TO INTERVENE
HAS BEEN MADE. ADDITIONALLY
REQUIRES A PEACE OFFICER
SUPPORT TO SUPPORT I'M SORRY TO
REPORT THE INCIDENT IMMEDIATELY
TO HIS OR HER SUPERVISOR. AB
TWENTY SIX PROHIBITS
RETALIATION ON PEACE OFFICERS
FOR REPORTING THE INCIDENT. THE
PROHIBITS AN OFFICER FROM
TRAINING OTHER OFFICERS FOR A
PERIOD OF AT LEAST THREE YEARS
FROM THE DATE THAT AN EXCESSIVE
USE OF FORCE COMPLAINT. WAS
SUBSTANTIATED. ALL DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS IN KHOBAR ARE PRESERVED
IN THIS BILL. IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE TECHNIQUES AND
PROCEDURES THAT ARE PUT FORWARD
IN THIS BILL FOR ESTABLISHING
THAT AN OFFICER HAS INTERVENE
CAN ACTUALLY BE APPLIED IN REAL
WORLD SCENARIOS. MY OFFICE
REACHED OUT TO THE POST. BOB
WHO IS CHARGED TO DEVELOP DUTY
TO INTERVENE TRAININGS. IN OUR
CONSULTATION WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE LIAISON FOR POST WE
HAVE CONFIRMED THAT THE DUTY TO
INTERVENE TRAINING IN ALL OF
THE FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS
ASSOCIATED WITH FAILURE TO
INTERVENE ISN'T ALL OF THE USE
OF FORCE TRAININGS. IT IS IN
THE ACADEMY AS WELL AS IN
SERVICE TRAINING AND RECENTLY
THE COMMISSION MANDATED USE OF
FORCE TRAINING AS A PERISHABLE
SKILL. WHICH MAKES THE REQUIRED
TRAINING FOR EVERY IN SERVICE
OFFICER EVERY TWO YEARS. IN
FACT POSTERS PURCHASE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
NEW TECHNOLOGY FOR A HUNDRED
VIRTUAL REALITY SIMULATORS THAT
WILL BE DISTRIBUTED THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THEY OFFER SIMULATOR
USE OF FORCE DE ESCALATION
COURSE THAT LITERALLY PRACTICES
INTERVENTION TECHNIQUES AND
SCENARIOS. MEMBERS THIS IS A
BILL THAT ABOUT TRANSPARENCY
AND REESTABLISHES PUBLIC TRUST
BY EDUCATING THE COMMUNITY ON
THE LAWFUL PROCEDURES AND
PRACTICES OF PEACE OFFICERS WHO
HAVE DEMONSTRATED THAT THEY
HAVE IN FACT ATTEMPTED TO
INTERVENE TO STOP EXCESSIVE.
USE OF FORCE. AB TWENTY SIX
SIMPLY CODIFIES WHAT IS
LITERALLY BEING TAUGHT AS WE
SPEAK. THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS
MY OFFICE HAS MET WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS. A LOT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT INCLUDING PORAC IN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HIGHWAY PATROLMEN HAVE GONE
NEUTRAL. HOWEVER SOME CONCERNS
REMAIN. AFTER DIGITAL
DISCUSSION WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
I HAVE TAKEN THE NECESSARY
STEPS TO SEND THEIR PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS TO LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL FOR DRAFTING WITH THE
COMMITMENT TO SUBMIT THOSE
AMENDMENTS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS SHOULD THIS BILL
GET OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY.
REMEMBER SPECIFICALLY STATE AND
SECTION ONE- SECTION AND
SECTION ONE SECTION SEVEN TWO
EIGHT SIX OF THE GOVERNMENT
CODEIS AMENDED LINE TO READ
THE REQUIREMENT THAT AN OFFICER
THAT HAS RECEIVED ALL REQUIRED
TRAINING ON THE REQUIREMENT TO
INTERCEDE AND FAILS TO ACT
PURSUANT TO PARAGRAPH NINE BE
DISCIPLINED UP TO AND INCLUDING
THE SAME MANNER AS THE OFFICER
THAT COMMITTED. THE EXCESSIVE
FORCE. IN THAT SPIRIT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU I SEE
YOU HAVE A PRIMARY WITNESS YOU
HAVE A BRIAN **** IS THAT WOULD
NOT READY AT THIS POINT MR
OPERATOR. WE HAVE FRANK **** ON
THE LINE WE WILL FOR HIM THREE
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY HE MADE
CAN. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN FOR PROVIDING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
I AM DEPUTY PUBLIC DEFENDER
BRIAN **** WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE. AND I'M SPEAKING TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX
ACROSS CALIFORNIA IN THE
COUNTRY POLICE HAVE USED
EXCESSIVE FORCE WITH LITTLE
FEAR OF CONSEQUENCES FOR FAR
TOO LONG. A RECENT STUDY FOUND
THAT ABOUT ONE IN EVERY ONE
THOUSAND BLACK MEN WILL BE
KILLED BY POLICE. POLICE
VIOLENCE IS THE LEADING CAUSE
OF DEATH AMONG MEN OF COLOR.
SAN FRANCISCO BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITY HAS LARGELY BORNE THE
BRUNT OF THE VIOLENCE SO MUCH
SO THAT SEPARATE US COACH
ENTERED INTO A REFORM AGREEMENT
THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE. IT'S
BEEN ONE YEAR SINCE GEORGE WARD
WAS MURDERED BY POLICE. WE KNOW
THE POLICE VIOLENCE THE NOT BE
DEADLY TO BE A LEADER. OR
MORALLY REPULSIVE. IN ROCHESTER
NEW YORK LEAST PEPPER SPRAYED A
NINE YEAR OLD GIRL. SHE SAT IN
A POLICE CAR HANCOCK COVERED IN
SNOW. BUT WE CAN REPORT IT
REVEALED IT HAS BECOME A TOO
OFTEN REFRAIN. WHEN A PERSON TO
FRICKLEY A PERSON OF COLOR DOES
NOT COMPLY QUICKLY NOUGH
OCCIDENTALIS OR TO A NECESSARY
FORCE. THE INCIDENTS IN
ROCHESTER AND MINNEAPOLIS ALSO
REAL TO THE STARTLING TRUTH AB
TWENTY SIX ADDRESSES. OFFICERS
SIMPLY STOOD BY AND DID NOTHING.
CLEVELAND VOLUNTARILY LIMIT
THEIR USE OF EXCESSIVE FORCE OR
CALL IT OUT WHEN IT HAPPENS.
LLAMAS PROVIDE CLEAR GUIDELINES
ON HOW OFFICERS INTERCEDE WHAT
THE CONSEQUENCES ARE I DO NOT.
AB TWENTY SIX PROVIDES A CLEAR
FRAMEWORK TO TAKE CONCRETE
PORTABLE STEPS TO INTERCEDE AND
PROTECT OFFICERS MATTEL USUALLY
WHEN THEY DO INTERCEDE. TO MORE
TO ENSURE THAT OFFICERS WHO USE
EXCESSIVE FORCE OR FAILED
INITIATOR HELD ACCOUNTABLE. I
CAN'T BE CONTROVERSIAL. THE
LINE'S BEEN IRREPARABLY HARMED
OR INJURED BECAUSE OF
PREVENTABLE UNNECESSARY POLICE
VIOLENCE WHICH ARE SWORN TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. THEY ALSO
MUST PROTECT THE PUBLIC FROM
UNNECESSARY POLICE VIOLENCE AB
TWENTY SIX BRING CALIFORNIA
CLOSER TO MAKING THAT A REALITY
FOR THIS REASON I SUPPORT AB
TWENTY SIX AN URGE TO DO SO AS
WELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER **** NO WILL MOVE TO
THIS ROOM THAT WE ARE WITH THIS
IS IN SUPPORT OF. AB. TWENTY
SIX. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF
GOVERN FOR CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN'S BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
HERE FORTY TWO OR THREE SEEN
NINE WILL NOW MOVES TO THE
OVERFLOW ROOM THERE'S NONE AS
WELL AND TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR
NOW WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
INTO THIRDS WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO. BACK
COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO. AND
ALIGNED ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
SEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
FIND. ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN.
WHY NO ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE.
I RESPECT YOU CAN FOLLOW
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. LINE AT. NINETY THREE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF BRAMBLE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. BLIND ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PROTESTING
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX THANK YOU. BLIND ONE
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON LEFT A CALDWELL
HOUSTON CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. BLINDED. NINETY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
WILLIAMSBURG ON BEHALF OF THE
BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. BLIND ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TEMPLES OTHER ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
BLIND. ONE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE NUMBERS TO
SORRY STEINBERG WITH HELP
ACCESS IN SUPPORT. LINE. EIGHTY
SIX. HELLO MY NAME IS GERRY RAY
GRAY AND I REPRESENT THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF JEWISH
WOMEN SACRAMENTO SECTION WE
HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING AB TWENTY
SIX FOR SEVERAL MONTHS AND
CONTINUE TO STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE BILL. THANK YOU. THE LINE
OF ONE HUNDRED NINETY THREE.
THE NEW MADRID SHARE GEN
NUMBERS I AM CALL PART NUMBER
HAPPY CALIFORNIA STATE MAX MAX
NETWORK. MATCH AFTER AND PULLS
FOR THE BILL. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION AND THERE'S TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WILL FOR THEM THREE MINUTES
EACH- WE FOR CHILD. BRIAN
SHERMAN IF HE'S PREPARED HE CAN
MAKE HIS PRESENTATION AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FRENCH GERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
AND THE POLICE OFFICER
ASSOCIATIONS OF CLERMONT HELD
FOR HE'S UPLAND INGLEWOOD
CORONA NEWPORT BEACH SANTA ANA
ARCADIA POMONA. BURBANK
RIVERSIDE IN CULVER CITY- WE
CURRENTLY HAVE IN OPPOSE
POSITION ON AB TWENTY SIX
HOWEVER WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR- AND IT KNOWLEDGE IS-
MA'AM WE APPRECIATE HIM- AND
THIS WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH
US IN ENSURING THE BILL
APPROPRIATELY DISCIPLINES
OFFICERS. WHO'VE. SINCE IT
REFUSE TO CONFORM THEIR ACTIONS
TO THEIR WITH THEIR TRAINING AS
MENTIONED BY THE SOMEONE IS A
BEAST TWENTY SIX ADVANCES FROM
THIS COMMUNITY CENTER
PREPARATIONS WE EXPECT TO BE
ABLE TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY SIX UPON ADOPTION
OF THE AMENDMENT. AGAIN WE
THINK THE OTHER FOR HIS WORK ON
THIS IMPORTANT BILL LOOK FOR
CHANGING OUR POSITION TO
NEUTRAL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
AS SHOWN ON BOTH. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR DURING COMMITTEE
SHAUN RUNDLE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OR CPO A IN
OPPOSITION BUT THE MAN DID TO
AB TWENTY SIX. WE AS WELL
DEEMED THE CURRENT MEASURE
IMPROVEMENT WE THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR SUCH DILIGENCE BUT- SOME OF
OUR OUR LINGERING CERN'S BUT
LINGERING CONCERNS TO REMAIN
OVER THE CURRENT DRAFTING. BUT
AS A NON UNION LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT ASSOCIATION OF MORE
THAN TWENTY TWO THOUSAND COPS
TO KILL A- IS A GROUP OF COPS
WHO WANT TO BE IN THE BEST COPS
AND ARE MEMBERS OF ALL RANKS
NEEDS TO THE CROSS CALIFORNIA
FEEL THAT THE- MEASURES
PROVISIONS ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE. OR SOME OF THEM WITH THE
PASSAGE OF THE BEST B. TWO
THIRTY TWO YEARS AGO. BECAUSE
OF THE WORK ON THAT BILL AND
OTHER USE OF FORCE REFORMS
FROM. PREVIOUS YEARS DUTY TO
INTERCEDE IT'S NOT A NEW IDEA
AND ONE THAT WE HAVE LONG
SUPPORTED WHAT. SB SIX TWENTY
SIX DOES HOWEVER. IS MANDATE
AGENCY POLICIES TO INCLUDE
REQUIREMENTS THAT AN OFFICER
INTERVIEWED WHEN PRESENT IN
OBSERVING IN OTHER OFFICERS.
FORCE THAT IS CLEARLY BEYOND
WHICH IS NECESSARY. SO WE WOULD
DISAGREE WITH THE ASSESSMENT
THAT THE BILL IS CURRENTLY A
CLEAR FRAMEWORK WITHOUT A
DEFINITION OF WHAT CONSTITUTES
CLEARLY BEYOND. THAT WE'VE SUCH
ACTIONS OPEN TO WIDE OF
INTERPRETATION AND SUBSEQUENTLY
LITIGATION. AT THE END BIGGEST
DEFINITION OF CLEARLY BEYOND
NOW ALSO MAKES THE DISCIPLINARY
PROVISIONS. BETTER STILL IN
PLACE MORE PROBLEMATIC AS WELL
SO THAT RELATES TO A DUTY TO
INTERCEDE OR REPORT. SECTION B.
THREE INCLUSION OF IMMEDIATELY
REPORT POTENTIAL EXCESS SUPPORT
TO A SUPERIOR OFFICER.IS ALSO
PROBLEMATIC NOT ONLY FOR ITS
VAGUENESS BUT ALSO THAT THEY'RE
SUPER THAT THEIR SUPERIOR
OFFICER MAY BE DIFFERENT THAN
THE BOND. BROWN TO. PERHAPS
FOR. ADDITIONALLY ARE MEMBERS
OF FELT THAT SUCH LANGUAGE
NOTING DUTY TO ACT OR FAILURE
TO DUTY. COULD BE INCLUDED TO
HELP CLARIFY EXACTLY HOW THEIR
ACTIONS ARE OUR BEST HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. SUCH A CLEARCASE
WERE ALSO ALIGNED WITH SECTION
NINETEEN OF THE BILL IS THE
AUTHOR MEMBER- MENTION WHEREBY
DUTY TO ACT OR FAILURE TO DUTY
LANGUAGE WOULD COME INTO PLAY
WHEN YOU'RE HOLDING OFFICERS
ACCOUNTABLE. WHO DIDN'T
INTERCEDE WHEN MAY QUOTE FAILED
TO ACT THAT THE SECTION STATE.
THE BILL READ NOW THOSE
OFFICERS WHO DIDN'T INTERVENE
WOULD BE HELD TO THE SAME
DISCIPLINE SANTEE DISCOVERY WHO
COMMITTED EXCEPT SUPPORTS WHICH
WE DON'T GOES PRUDENT POLICY
WENT. WHEN ACTS CLEARLY BEYOND
EXCEPT THEY WERE NOT DEFINED.
FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU HAD A
PROBATIONARY OFFICER WHO WHO
DIDN'T INTERVENE VERSUS THE
TWENTY. FIVE YEAR BET WITH A
CLEAR RECORD WHO ALSO DIDN'T
INTERCEDE THEN YOU DEAL WITH
THOSE IN A VERY DIFFERENT WAY
AND BE ASKED TO. YOU KNOW WANT
TO BE ABSOLUTE SENSE WE TREAT
THEM TO SAY. THE SAME WAY IS
NOT A SOLUTION WE CAN FULLY GET
BEHIND- AND AT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT ORGANIZATION
OFFICER ACCOUNTABILITY AND
MORE. IMPORTANTLY REMOVAL AND
CIRCUMSTANCES WHEN EXCESSIVE
FORCE IT IS CLEAR. THE SHARED
GOAL AMONG US ALL AND GO AGAIN
THE BILL HAS IMPROVED AND WE
HOPE TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
AS WELL WHEN. CERTAIN
DEFINITIONS CAN BE ADDED TO
ADDRESS TO THE DISCIPLINE
MANDATES ARE WORKABLE. BUT
GIVEN THE CURRENT DRAFTING
HOWEVER WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO AB
TWENTY SIX AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU MR THANK YOU. MODERATOR I
WILL GO BACK TO THE ROOM AND
WITNESSES IN OUR- OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY NINE WILL
GO TO OUR OVERFLOW TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NO ONE THERE AS WELL.
NO MODERATE WILL GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES INTO THIRDS
WITNESSES AND DESIRES TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY SIX.
FOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO NET COMMAND AGAIN ONE NINE
ZERO. AND FIRST WE'LL GO TO
LINE. ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX.
IF YOU CAME IN THE IN A SINGLE
YEAR CALIFORNIA ACTION WAS
ACTUALLY IN THE QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT SO WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE- A LINE
OF ONE HUNDRED NINETY NINE. HI
ALSO- THE SAME THING MISSED OUT
ON- SUPPORT BUDGET DEBATE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX.
AND MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
RIGHT NOW WILL BRING YOU BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE WHO- WE'RE ON
AB TWENTY SIX FURTHER ANY.
QUESTIONS ARE CONCERNED JONES
RELATES TO THIS MEASURE HELLO.
SKINNER SKINNER MINUTE. TO
FILE. ON FILE ITEM. NINE I
DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS AND
ACTUALLY I'D MOVE THE BILL. DID
SHE MOVE THE BILL YES OKAY. WE
HAVE A MOTION- SET FROM A
SOMEONE HOLDING I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU FOR. AGAIN WHAT I
THINK IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
I THINK WE ALL WITNESS THE
HORRIFIC- SITUATION MARCH HERE
IN MINNEAPOLIS WITH MISTER
FLOYD AND WE ALL KNOW THAT OF
THOSE THREE OTHER OFFICERS JUST
WOULD HAVE. INTERCEDED AT ANY
MOMENT THERE MR FOR IT WOULD
STILL BE ALIVE TODAY BUT TO
THEIR- UNWILLINGNESS TO. SEE
THE HUMANITY AND MISTER FLOYD
OUR- INTERCEDE IN WAR. YOU KNOW
ACROSS THE BLUE LINE OR
WHATEVER PREVENTED THEM FROM
DOING WHICH SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DONE- WE'VE HAD ENOUGH PEOPLE
WHO. HAVE BEEN OUTRAGED AT THE
POLICE OFFICER WE SAW EARLIER
THIS YEAR WHO WAS. BEATING A
DOG IN TRAINING. AND NAY
INTERCEDED AND THAT AND- BUT-
YOU SAW MISTER FLOYD THERE THEY
CHOSE NOT TO INITIATE THERE SO
I WOULD- STRONGLY- RECOMMEND-
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR MEASURE WE HAVE
A MOTION- A TO A BOOK A SYNERGY
OF ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
BEFORE WE- CALL THE ROLL. OKAY
THAT COUNTS SO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON A. B. TWENTY SIX IT'S
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS AND I
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE AMENDMENTS
TO BE TAKEN. OKAY. AB TWENTY
SIX BRADFORD REDFORD I'D SHOW
BOTH NO. NO CALM LAGER SKINNER
HI IN OUR AYE WIENER. LOU THE
ROLE OPEN FOR THOSE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MR HOLDEN NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO WHO WE AYE
MR GABER HE'S UP NEXT WITH. AB.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR. APRIL
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY YOU MAY
BEGIN ON AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TODAY TO PRESENT AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR A COMMONSENSE
EFFORT TO BRING MORE
TRANSPARENCY TO OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND TO ENSURE
THAT TAXPAYER RESOURCES ARE
SPENT IN A MANNER THAT TRULY
ADVANCES JUSTICE AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. AS MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE ARE WELL AWARE IN
RECENT YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS
IMPLEMENTED A NUMBER OF NOTABLE
REFORMS TOWARD JUSTICE SYSTEM
THESE REFORMS HAVE AIMED TO
REDUCE AMASSING MASS
INCARCERATION FOR MORE PROMOTE
PATHWAYS TO REHABILITATION AND
MORE EFFECTIVELY ADVANCE PUBLIC
SAFETY. RIGHT THE SUCCESS OF
THESE REFORM CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO LEAD THE NATION IN
SPENDING ON CORRECTIONS. INDEED
OVER THE PAST DECADE CDC ARE
SPENDING HAS INCREASED BY OVER
THREE BILLION DOLLARS OR
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY PERCENT.
AS A RESULT CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY SPENDS MORE ON
CORRECTIONS AND THEN TEXAS THE
NEW YORK COMBINED. EXTENSIVE
SPENDING ON CORRECTIONS HAS
RESULTED IN DIMINISH REVENUES
FOR OTHER PUBLIC POLICY
PRIORITIES INCLUDING EDUCATION
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION AND
PUBLIC HEALTH. AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR BUILT ON
BIPARTISAN MOMENTUM TO PROMOTE
FISCAL ACCOUNTABILITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY AND CALIFORNIA'S
FAILED EXPERIMENT WITH MASS
INCARCERATION. MODELED AFTER
SUCCESSFUL PROTOCOLS THAT HAVE
BEEN ADOPTED IN PHILADELPHIA
NORTHERN VIRGINIA AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR WILL BRING
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY TO THE
SENTENCING PROCESS AND
INCENTIVIZE PROSECUTORS AND
JUDGES TO CONSIDER THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE MEANS. TO
ADVANCE JUSTICE AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. TO BE CLEAR THIS BILL
DOES NOT IMPOSE ANY REAL BURDEN
ON PROSECUTORS RATHER IT SIMPLY
REQUIRES THEM TO TAKE THE
AVERAGE ANNUAL COST OF
INCARCERATION OR SUPERVISION.
WHICH WILL BE CALCULATED
REPORTED BY THE ALEJO OR THE
DSCC AND MULTIPLY THAT BY THE
LENGTH OF SIDE OF THE SENTENCE
THEY'RE RECOMMENDING. JUDGES
WILL THEN HAVE THE OPTION THEIR
COMPLETE DISCRETION TO CONSIDER
THIS INFORMATION IF AT ALL IN
THE MANNER THAT THEY BELIEVE IS
MOST APPROPRIATE. THIS BILL
THIS BILL DOES NOT DIMINISH
OTHER APPROPRIATE
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING THE
IMPACT OF THE CRIMES BUT MERELY
ADDS ONE OTHER ADDITIONAL DATA
POINT FOR THE JUDGE TO
CONSIDER. IF THEY SO DESIRE. IT
SO DOES IT DOING AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR WILL PROMOTE
TRANSPARENCY IN THE SENTENCING
PROCESS AND INCENTIVIZE
PROSECUTORS TO ENSURE THAT
TAXPAYER RESOURCES ARE SPENT
WISELY AND IN A MANNER THAT
TRULY ADVANCES JUSTICE AND
PUBLIC SAFETY. HERE WITH ME
TODAY TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE BILL IS
LARISSA SEPARATISTS ON BEHALF
OF RESTORE JUSTICE THANK YOU
AND AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
MISSED SAYS WITH THIS WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR NUMBERS. HERE ON BEHALF
OF RESTORE IT AND IT HAD A LONG
HEARING THIS AFTERNOON SO I
WILL SIMPLY SAY IF THERE ARE
ANY QUESTIONS. HAPPY CAN HELP
ANSWER OR CLARIFY- AND OUT WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT. OF
THIS COMMON SENSE MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
GO BACK TO THE ROOM THAT THEIR
MOM WENT WITH THIS IS HERE AND
FORTY TWO OLD THREE DESERVES TO
SPEAK AND SUPPORT YES MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS MCKINLEY ON
BEHALF OF GOVERNMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA HERE IN SUPPORT OF
MR GABRIEL'S BILL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU. NOW
WILL GO TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM IF
ANYONE DESIRING TO SPEAK AND
SUPPORT IN TWENTY FORTY WE SEE
NONE. NOW MODERATOR WILL GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES IF THEREARE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN FORTY SIX FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR. NOW TO TIME NASA
MCCUE. FOUR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE THEN
ZERO. BLIND ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
TWO YEAR MY COULD OPEN. THIS IS
TEARING ME ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JESSE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. BLIND. TWO HUNDRED
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JIM
WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. BLIND ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
STAND TO LOSE OUT ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
AN ONLINE. ONE HUNDRED NINETY
FOUR. BLIND ONE HUNDRED NINETY
FOUR. MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU NOW WILL GO TO OUR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE SEE
WE HAVE ONE LEAD- WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION LEARN MORE CITIES
PREPARED YOU CAN BEGIN HIS
TESTIMONY NO. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS LAURIE
MORE SOMEBODY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR THE SPECIAL
REQUIRES PROSECUTORS THE STATE
ON THE RECORD AT SENTENCING THE
ESTIMATED COST OF INCARCERATION
OR SUPERVISION. OR ANY PROPOSED
SENSE OF A PRE SENTENCE REPORT
AS ORDERED THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT MUST PREPARE AN
ESTIMATE OF THE COST ASSOCIATED
WITH INCARCERATION- SUPERVISED
RELEASE. FOR A PROPOSED
SENTENCE WE ARE UNCERTAIN WHAT
THE INTENT OF THE BILL IS THE
COST OF INCARCERATION AND CDCR
IS RELEASED ANNUALLY SO THAT
FIGURE WILL BE REPEATED EACH
TIME A PERSON IS SENTENCED TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
IF THE IDEA IS TO MAKE JUDGES
AWARE OF THE COST OF STATE
PRISON WE EXPECT THEY'LL GET IT
THE FIRST TIME IT STATED ON THE
RECORD AND WON'T NEED IT
REPEATED EACH AND EVERY TIME A
PERSON IS SENTENCED. AS THAT
NUMBER WILL NOT CHANGE. HOWEVER
GIVEN THE PLETHORA OF EARLY
RELEASE PROGRAMS APPROVED BY
THE LEGISLATURE IN RECENT YEARS
IT WILL BE NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE
FOR A PROSECUTOR TO STATE WITH
ANY REAL ACCURACY JUST HOW LONG
ANY INMATE LASER. ARE
PROSECUTORS EXPECTED OFFER A
FIGURE BASED ON THE FULL
SENTENCE OR JUSTICE FOR KNOWN
CREDIT LET ALONE UNKNOWN CREDIT
IN POINT OF FACT THERE WILL BE
NO REAL WAY FOR ANYONE TO
DETERMINE HOW MANY CREDITS AN
INMATE MAY OR. MAY NOT TURN
OVER YOUR LOCAL. THE CARD
SELECTION. OUT CAN UP. STATE
WITH ANY ERA. OR CERTAIN WHAT
THE COST OF NEC. SENTENCE WILL
BE. IN THE ABSENCE OF THAT
ACCURACY AND CERTAINTY WHAT IS
THE POINT OF THE BILL. EVEN THE
MOST RECENT FIGURES ON CDC ARE
COSTS MUST BE VIEWED WITH
CAUTION. WELL THE NUMBER OF
INMATES INCARCERATED IN
CALIFORNIA HAS DROPPED BY MORE
THAN TWENTY THOUSAND IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. THE COST
OF INCARCERATION IS ACTUALLY
REALLY. SUBSTANTIAL IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
FISCAL YEAR IT COSTS AND
ESTIMATED AB ONE THOUSAND TO
HOUSING INMATES IN CDC ARE.
ACCORDING TO THE GOVERNOR'S
MOST RECENT BUDGET THAT FIGURES
EXPECTED DECLINE BY MORE THAN
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS TO ONE
HUNDRED TWELVE THOUSAND BY THE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR. IT COUNTER
INTUITIVE BUT TRUE THAT DESPITE
A REDUCED INMATE POPULATION THE
COST OF RUNNING CDC OURS
ACTUALLY INCREASED
CONSIDERABLY. SO IT'S HARD
ARGUES THIS BILL DOES THAT
SHORTER SENTENCES ALTERNATIVE
SENTENCES RESULT IN COST
SAVINGS TO CALIFORNIA. THE
ESTIMATES FOR LOCAL TIME OR
EVEN MORE UNCERTAIN THE COST OF
INCARCERATION VARIES FROM
COUNTY TO COUNTY AND THE ACTUAL
TIME IN CUSTODY ANYONE SERVICE.
CAN VERY DRAMATICALLY BASED ON
A HOST OF CIRCUMSTANCES SUCH AS
JAIL CROWDING DIVERSION
PROGRAMS ALTERNATIVE BECAUSE
THE CREDIT THE BETTER. A PERSON
SENTENCED TO A YEAR IN COUNTY
JAIL MAY DO LESS THAN HALF
THAT. WHAT COST YOU THE
PROSECUTOR PUT ON THE RECORD.
IT WOULD BE DECEPTIVE TO PUT
THE COST ABOUT FOUR YEARS
INCARCERATION ON THE RECORD
WHEN AT CERTAIN HERE SHE WON'T
DO THAT MUCH THOUGHT. THE BILL
ALSO FAILED TO ATTEMPT TO
QUANTIFY THE COST OF
CRIMINALITY OR RECIDIVISM. THE
DEPENDED IS WHAT LEAST BECAUSE
OF HE COST OF INCARCERATION
GOES ON TO COMMIT MORE CRIMES
BECAUSE HERE SHE IS NOT
REHABILITATED OR SIMPLY
INCAPABLE OF ABIDING IN
SOCIETY. HOW DO WE ESTIMATE
THOSE COSTS. OR THE COST OF THE
SYSTEM PROSECUTION DEFENSE
JUDICIARY PROBATION ALL ACTION.
WHEN INDIVIDUALS RE. OFFENSE WE
KNOW ALL TOO WELL ALL THAT IS
THAT IT IS EXPENSIVE OWN CARS.
AND IS PRISON ACCOUNT JAIL BUT
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE DEMOCRATS
THE BY CRIME ON. AND ALL NEVER
BE AT. OR ACT CALLED QUAN. YOUR
GOING BILL. EFFECTS OF CRIME
UNDER COMMUNITIES BE GIVEN
AROUND NUMBER. WE BELIEVE THIS
BILL THOUGH WELL INTENTIONED
INACCURATELY ELEVATES DOLLARS
AND CENTS ABOVE OTHER EQUALLY
COMPELLING CONSIDERATION. THAT
MUST GO INTO ASSESSING
SENTENCING DECISIONS. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU NOW WILL GO TO THE
ROOM- HERE IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE IS ANYONE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM- DISCHARGE OF
PLAN- SPEAKING- AND OPPOSITION
OF. THIS MEASURE FOURTEEN FOR
SEVENTY FOUR SHE NINE WILL GO
TO TWENTY FORTY. C. NINE.
MODERATOR ARE THERE WITNESSES
DESIRING TO SPEAK AND
OPPOSITION OF FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR ON THE LINE IF SO NOW'S
THE TIME TO QUEUE. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO A. B.
FOURTEEN SEVEN OR PLEASE PRESS
ONE BUTTON ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE TEN ZERO. AND ALIGNED
TO HUNDREDS OF I APOLOGIZE WE
LOST LINE TWO HUNDRED SIX IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AGAIN. AND OUTLINED TWO
HUNDRED SIX OR MY COULD OPEN.
SHARON RILEY ON BEHALF OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL- BUT WE DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL HOWEVER WE HAD A VERY
PRODUCTIVE MEETING WITH DOCTOR
AND HIS STAFF LAST WEEK AND WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF WORKING
OUT AND THEN MEANT THAT WE HOPE
WILL ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO NOT TO
THIS. AND IT WE HAVE ONE MORE
COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH THEIR LINE NUMBER.
ONE MORE MOMENT PLEASE SEND NOW
WILL GO TO THE LINE OF TWO
HUNDRED FIVE YOUR MIKE IT'S
OPEN. IT'S BEEN DELIVERED TO
THE LENDER OF RECORD AT THE
BACKSEAT IN PORT- OF OUR
ORGANIZATION RESTORED TO THE
SUPPORT BILL AS WELL AS A YOUNG
WOMEN CHOOSING ACTION ON COMMON
LAW AND. FELONY MURDER
ELIMINATION PROJECT. AND MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. OUR LADY
NOW WILL COME BACK TO THE
HEARING ROOM- WITNESSES AND-
OPPOSITION NO ANSWER WHERE DID
ONCE IN OPPOSITION TO WERE.
RIGHT AND SMART WE'RE GOOD I'M
A BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS I
COMMITTEE ON THIS MEASURE.
CENTER CALLER I THINK I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I'M ACTUALLY
VERY INTERESTED IN THE BILL I
MAINTAIN THAT- THE CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM ISN'T ECONOMIC
ENTERPRISE- AND- YOU MAKE MONEY
WHEN FOLKS COME INTO COURT. AND
WHEN FOLKS GET SENTENCE AND-
WHEN THEY VIOLATE AND WHEN THEY
COME BACK IN SO IT WOULD BE
REALLY GREAT FOR FOLKS TO KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT THOSE COSTS ARE.
SO THAT WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW
TO HOW TO HAVE A MORE EFFICIENT
SYSTEM- THAT IS REALLY NOT
RATING THE WALLETS OF OUR
TAXPAYERS. AND DELIVERING
SOMETHING THAT IS NOT OF HIGH
VALUE. YOU KNOW I ALSO WANT TO
SHARE MISTER CHAIR THAT HAN
APPROPRIATIONS ON WHICH YOU AND
I SAID THERE WAS- AN URGENCY
BILL THAT CAME TO US NOT LONG
AGO THAT. WAS TALKING ABOUT
PAYING BACK FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED AND
INCARCERATED AND THE COST WAS A
HUNDRED AND FORTY DOLLARS A DAY
AND I SUBMIT THAT IT COSTS MORE
THAN A HUNDRED AND FORTY
DOLLARS A DAY. TO INCARCERATE
THEM SO THEY GOT THE SHORT END
OF THE STICK. SOMETHING LIKE
THIS COULD HELP REALLY- UP LIFT
THOSE. ERRORS IN CALCULATIONS-
AND MAYBE HAVE FOLKS ALLOW
FOLKS TO HAVE A GREATER
APPRECIATION FOR WHAT THIS
WHOLE SYSTEM IS- BY. ALLOWING
THERE TO BE SOME GREATER
TRANSPARENCY ABOUT HOW MUCH IT
COSTS TO RUN- SO THAT PEOPLE
SEE EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE PAYING
FOR- I WILL BE HAPPY TO MAKE A
MOTION TO MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
Q. ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS BYE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ON FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR. I
THINK THIS IS A PROPER TIME TO
MOVE THE BILL. IT HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR CALM WATER.
THE SERMON GABRIEL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
FOR THOSE COMMENTS CENTER MAKE
US BUT JUST JUST TO ADD A FEW
THINGS HERE- YOU KNOW THAT WERE
WERE RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION-
WE'RE NOT ASKING JUDGES OR
PROSECUTORS TO PUT TOGETHER
COMPLICATED ECONOMETRIC MODEL
AND TRY TO CALCULATE WITH EXACT
CERTAINTY THE COST OF. OF
INCARCERATION WE'RE ASKING THEM
TO DO A VERY SIMPLE- VERY
SIMPLE MULTIPLICATION RIGHT
WHICH IS TO SAY I'M PROPOSING A
SENTENCE OF EIGHT YEARS EIGHT
TIMES EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IS THIS AMOUNT I'M
PROPOSING A SENTENCE OF TEN
YEARS EIGHT TIMES TEN TIMES
EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS. IN HERE THIS THIS IS
MEANT TO HELP THEM THINK A
LITTLE BIT RIGHT IF I'M GOING
TO TRY TO DECIDE IF I WANT TO
RECOMMEND EIGHT YEARS OR. TEN
YEARS WHAT IT WHAT IS WHAT IS
THE BENEFIT TO JUSTICE IS THE
BESTTO PUBLIC SAFETY FOR THE
ADDITION- HUNDREDS TO TWO
DOLLARS THAT WILL THAT TOLD
THIS PURSE FOR TWO YEARS AND
JUST TO STIMULATE SOME THINKING
ON THE PART OF THE- OBVIOUSLY
WOULD HAVE DESCRIBED TO
RECOMMEND WHATEVER SEND THEY
WANT. AND THEN THE SAME THING
FROM THE AND I AM I STE I
SUGGEST THEIR POWER A LOT OF
SITUATION IN WHICH A JUDGE
WOULD SAY IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE
TO TAKE COST INTO CONSIDERATION
AT THIS POINT BUT THERE MAY BE
SITUATIONS WHERE A JUDGE IN
THEIR DISCUSSION WOULD SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT IT IS IMPORTANT TO
THINK ABOUT THIS DO WE REALLY
WANT TO. LOCK THIS PERSON UP
FOR A LENGTHY SENTENCE FOR
POSSESSION OF A CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE IS NOT REALLY GOING
TO BENEFIT TAXPAYERS IS A
REALLY GOING TO BENEFIT PUBLIC
SAFETY IS THAT REALLY GOING TO
BAT BUT BENEFIT JUSTICE. OR IS
THERE TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND OR
300-100-0500 THOUSAND DOLLARS
THAT COULD BE BETTER SPENT ON
OTHER THINGS FOR THE BENEFIT OF
SOCIETY FOR THE BENEFIT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY SORT IS A VERY
LIGHT TOUCH APPROACH- IT'S AN
APPROACH THAT HAS A LOT OF THE
PROMINENT CONSERVATIVE LEGAL
SCHOLARS LIKE JUDGE RICHARD
POSNER FROM THE SEVENTH CIRCUIT
HAVE RAISED AS AN ISSUE THAT WE
SHOULD TAKE AND IT'S GOING TO
GET CONSIDERATION. YOUR FORMER
REPUBLICAN ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
INCLUDING THE FORMER REPUBLICAN
LEADER WHO HAVE SAID THAT THE
COST OF MASS INCARCERATION A
COMPLETE WASTE OF TAXPAYER
RESOURCES SO YOU KNOW WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS THIS IS A
WAY TO BRING THAT INTO THE
CONVERSATION IN A VERY. DEL K.
Y. NOT ALL TO DIMINISH OTHER
CONSIDERATIONS ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT. THE OPPOSITION
RATES ARE APPROPRIATE
CONSIDERATIONS AND THEY'RE
ALREADY TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION IN THE SENTENCING
PROCESS. BUT THIS IS JUST ADDS
ONE ADDITIONAL DATA POINT. THAT
JUDGES CAN CONSIDER. AT THEIR
DISCRETION WE LEAVE IT UP TO
THEM AND SO I ALWAYS THINK THAT
MORE INFORMATION. IS BETTER IT
WILL HLP US TO ROUTE. TO REACH
OUTCOMES THAT ARE BETTER
ADVANCINGJUSTICE BETTER ADVANCE
PUBLIC SAFETY. AND WITHOUT
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR COM
LONGER COUNCIL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR REMEMBER MICHAEL YES SOME
SORT ORDER THOSE STEP OUT BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR ON THIS. BILL- BE
DELIGHTED TO HAVE YOU THANK YOU
CENTER. THANK YOU. AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR BRADFORD ON
REDFORD I'D SHOW. NO TROUBLED
NO COM LOGGER. KAMLAGER AYE
SKINNER SKINNER AYE WINNER
WINNER I FOR ONE. MAJOR HAS
FOUR YES VOTES ONE NO IT'S OUT
CONGRATULATIONS NOW MOVING ON
TO SOME WOMEN STONE. HE HAS AB.
FIVE OH THREE. WE'RE PROPERLY
CLEANED UP THERE YOU MAY BEGIN
YOUR PREFERRED PRISON TATIAN
RISTORANTE. THANK YOU. B. FIVE
OH THREE IS INTENDED TO.
PROVIDE SOME CONSISTENCY COUNTY
BY COUNTY WITH. OUR YOUTH WHO
ARE ON NONCUSTODIAL WAR CHIPS
IN ON PROBATION AND THAT THE
FACTS ARE THAT DEPENDING ON THE
COUNTY IN SOME COUNTIES IN THE
FOR THE SAME ISSUES. THE
PROBATION TIME CAN BE AVERAGING
TWO AND A HALF YEARS AND IN
OTHER COUNTIES FOR THE SAME
ISSUES AVERAGING SIX MONTHS SO
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A GREAT
DISPARITY BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT.
THE ALMOST 90% OF THE KIDS ON
THESE WERE TO. CHRISTO DEAL
PROGRAMS ARE NOT CUSTODIAL
WARSHIPS ALMOST 90% FOR KIDS
OF COLOR AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE CONDITIONS THAT THESE KIDS
ARE HAVING TO MEET AND THESE
ARE JUST KIDS WHILE THEY'RE ON
THESE **** TO WORSHIP PROGRAM
SOMETIMES THEY'RE FIVE
CONDITION SOMETIMES FIFTY
CONDITIONS AND IF THEY'RE TOO
MANY CONDITIONS. FOR A TEENAGER
TO REMEMBER TO BE ABLE TO
MANAGE THE CONSEQUENCES ARE
EXTENDING TIME A PROBATION OR
EVEN POTENTIALLY INCARCERATION.
SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH
SB FIVE OH THREE IS TO SET SOME
CLEAR STANDARDS THE EXPECTATION
WOULD BE. NO LONGER THAN SIX
MONTHS ON PROBATION. AND BUT
THAT IS NOT A THAT IS NOT THE
LENGTH OF TIME THEY'RE GOING TO
NECESSARILY SPEND ON PROBATION.
BUT AT THE END OF SIX MONTHS IT
WOULD NEED TO BE REVIEW. AND
BASED ON THE PREPONDERANCE OF
EVIDENCE. THAT CAN BE EXTENDED
IF IT IS NECESSARY TO SERVE THE
INTERESTS OF THE CHILD AND TO
SERVE THE INTERESTS OF JUSTICE.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO PUT SOME.
SOME CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
SERVICE THAT THAT CHILD THE
NONCUSTODIAL WARSHIP THAT THAT
THAT THAT CHILD IS CONTAINED
FOR AND THE ABILITY OF THEM TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT THEY
NEED TO ADDRESS A TO GET BACK
INTO SOCIETY TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM AND TO BE TREATED IN
A CONSISTENT MANNER STATE BY
STATE THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS
BILL IS ALL ABOUT IT'S
REQUIRING THAT THE TERMS THEN
IF THERE ARE CONDITIONS OF
PROBATION THOSE TERMS ARE
REASONABLY RELATED TO WHAT THE
CHILD NEEDS IN ORDER TO BE.
REHABILITATED TO ADDRESS THE
SITUATION THAT THEY FIND
THEMSELVES IN THAT'S WHAT AB
FIVE FIVE OH THREE IS ABOUT
WE'RE WORKING WITH.
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICER TO PROPOSE
SOMETHING FAIRLY SIMILAR A YEAR
OR SO AGO ALTHOUGH IT WAS A
YEAR RATHER THAN SIX MONTHS AND
WE'RE TRYING TO SIX MONTHS
BECAUSE THE WHOLE LOT OF THE
WORK THAT WE HAD DONE AROUND IN
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
DEPENDENCY DELINQUENCY THE
SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS THOSE ARE
SIX MONTHS AND THEY'RE DESIGNED
TO SIX MONTHS FOR A REASON.
THAT IF WE LET KIDS LANGUISHED
IN THE SITUATIONS THAT IT'S TO
THEIR DETRIMENT. GETTING THEM
THE SERVICES TO HELP THE NEED
GETTING THEM TO TONE WHAT
PROBLEM THAT THEY GOT THEM SO
INTO BUT IN A REASONABLE OF
TIME AND THEN I'LL FROM
UNDERNEATH PROBE IS A THIS BILL
IS ALL ABOUT SO WITH THE I
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
THEIR YOUR STAFF ANALYSIS ON
THIS AS WE TRY TO MOVE THIS
THROUGH IN A RESPECTFUL ASK
YOUR I. VOTE. BUT YOU HAVE TO
BE. WHEN THIS. ONE OF THE
BIGGER MELGOZA. AND PRISCILLA
MANA. IS THAT CORRECT. CHETHAM
ARE OR EITHER ONE READY TO
TESTIFY AT THIS POINT WILL
PROVIDE YOU KNOW LAW YOU THREE
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY EACH.
MISTER CHAIR I DO WE GET OUT
SHOW THAT EITHER HAS CONNECTED.
HER RIDE. WHAT WE'RE WAITING
WE'LL COME TO THE ROOM IS THERE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
OH THREE YEAR IN A ROW. KERN
JINAN WILL GO TO TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NO ONE THERE- JUST
TRYING TO SIDE- EITHER ONE OF
THE PRIMARY WITNESSES. CHECKED
IN YET. WE DO NOT SHOW THEM
CONNECTED ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO
THE PHONE LINES AND SEE IF
THERE'S WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE OH THREE MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE Q. THOSE CALLERS UP
WHO ARE DESIROUS OF SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT. OUR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE OH THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO BACK
COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO. WE WILL
FIRST GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD-
GOOD AFTERNOON I'LL GO CHECK
BAIRD MORE COMPLETE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF ALL LINK AND THE
ALLIANCE OF BOYS MEN OF COLOR.
WHERE COSPONSORED BIN IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE OH THREE AND
IF OU DON'T MIND I'M ALSO
GOING TO READ A LIST OF
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIVE OH
THREE- STARTING OFF WITH
ABORTION ACTIVE PRACTICE BOND.
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION ALONG
THE FOR YOU JUSTICE ALL OF US
OR NONE BAKER. ALL SAINTS
CHURCH FOSTER CARE PROJECT
CALIFORNIA STOP COALITION
CENTER ON JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM- CHILDREN NOW
CHILDREN BUT BENT ON CALIFORNIA
COURAGE EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW
CENTER. ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS SWEETUMS FOR YOU
PRESS WILL BARRED HEROES YOU
NEED A- HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOU KERN
COUNTY PARTICIPAR. LANDMARK
AND- MIGHT BE LYON MARTIN
HEALTH THEY'RE BUILT NATIONAL
ACTION NETWORK A LOS ANGELES
NATIONALCENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
OAKLAND NIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
OAKLAND UNITE REUNITING
FAMILIES CAUGHT- CAUGHT SURE.
CONTRA COSTA CON- COUNTY
CIRCLED VALLEY DEEP- PARTING
OVER INCORPORATION YOUNG WOMAN
FREEDOM. YOU COLLIDE YOU LAW
CENTER I MEANT THREE ADDITIONAL
INDIVIDUALS FIND ON SUMMER LOW
INCOME SACRAMENTO STATE THE GO
DELL FROM GREEN GRILLED AND
KELPIE BREED. FROM EUREKA
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
KNOW WITNESS. THE LINE. TWO
HUNDRED EIGHT- NO LIABILITY CAL
CANNOT IN ANY POINT EIGHTY FIVE
YEAH. BLIND AT ONE TWENTY TWO.
THIS IS SERRA REGNI I'M OF AN
JEFF AND COURT. BLIND ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON WE'RE BACK GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THE LINE. TWO HUNDRED
FOR. HELLO LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. BLIND. ONE HUNDRED
FORTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER FROM
THE OPEN MARKET BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. BLIND. ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY. BLIND ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY. BLIND. TWO HUNDRED
TWELVE. SHARE MEMBERS PREFERRED
DOCTOR ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER
FOR EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
AND SUPPORT. BLINDED TWO
HUNDRED NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS DANIEL GUTIERREZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT. BLIND. TWO HUNDRED
ONE. BLIND. TWO HUNDRED ONE. M.
S. SIX A WE HAVE ONE MORE
COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH THEIR LINE NUMBER.
ONE MORE MOMENT PLEASE. IT
LOOKS LIKE- THE LAST COMMENT
COMING FROM- TRADE MELGOZA
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME ONLY I'M ACTUALLY I'M
FROM ELEMENTARY AND CENTER AND
I'M ACTUALLY WITH- I MAY BE
THINKING FOR DREAM I'LL GO BACK
AND OUTSIDE BRISTOL AND THEN
NOT AFFECTING WOMEN- COMMITTEE
ON BEHALF OF GERRY GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JAME AGO
THAT I'M A YOUTH ORGANIZER WITH
YOUNG WOMAN FREEDOM CENTER-
COSPONSORED EIGHTY FIVE OH
THREE. I AM A FORMERLY
INCARCERATED YOUNG PREGNANT BY
MY ENTIRE TEENAGE YEARS ON
HUMAN OPERATION AT THE AGE OF
FOURTEEN I WAS COMPENSATION FOR
NONVIOLENT CHARGE A MISDEMEANOR
WHICH WE HAD ORIGINALLY PUT ME
ON PROBATION SUPERVISION FOR
SIX MONTHS BUT TECHNICAL
VIOLATIONS. BUT NEED TO BE
OPERATION PERFECT HERE.
NEGATIVELY AND EVERY. MY COOL-FAMILY FRIENDSHIP RELATIONS AND
MORE. BUT WITH THE PROBATION
CONDITIONS I GIVE THEM A AND
LESS THAN WAS BASED ON
ASSUMPTIONS. ABOUT NEED TO THE
WHAT I WORE HI. GENERAL WHY
WOULD RAISE AND MODERATED. FROM
CURFEWS AGREE. SCHOOL TENANTS
CLARA I WORK WITH THEY WERE
WITH THEM. TO WRAP HIM SEARCHES
IN MY ROOM AND I THINK THAT.
HOW THE ONLY MY- TO KEEP HOLE.
DEMANDING A PROBE UMBILICAL HOW
TO DEAL. BECAUSE THE PROGRAM
THAT WOULD I. BY MANY BUT-
POLITICAL. PETER HAVING THINK
THAT SEVEN DAYS A WEEK FOR.
PROGRAMS I TRAVELED I HAD NO
TIME TO MYSELF AND TO THIS DAY
I'M CONFUSED ABOUT HOW IT WILL
TO LEARN ABOUT TERMINATION
INDEPENDENCE WITHOUT RELYING ON
A SYSTEM. THAT WOULD COMPANY
TRYING TO GET ME TO CONFORM TO
WHAT THEIR IDEA OF WHAT MIGHT
AFFECT THE B. I WAS GOING
UNIFIED HEALTHY COPING
MECHANISM VEHICLE TO CUT OFF
FAMILY AND FRIENDS BECAUSE THEY
LIKE THE COURT WITH THEM. ALL I
HAD LEFT IN MY IMMEDIATE FAMILY
WHICH WAS COMPLICATED MY
PROBATION BECAUSE THE WEDGE
BETWEEN. BECAUSE THE NUMBER OF
TIME GOES BY SB THREE TECHNICAL
VIOLATIONS OUR RELATIONSHIP WAS
ALREADY. STRAINED THE ONLY
ALTERNATE. TO MAINTAIN ANY
RELATIONSHIP WITH HEALTHCARE.
WHICH PRADYUMAN MORE DOWN ON MY
FACE. AND BECAUSE MORE STRESS
THE NEED. HOW MY MOM. TO PAY
ABOUT SHE WAS OFF AFFECTED DROP
OFF HAD TO. MEETING AND MANAGE
PROGRAM THAT TACKLE FROM OUR-
HOW MUCH I THOUGHT I WOULD A
LONG TRIP MY- MULTI. BY OFF TO
COME MY PARA A HAPPY BRING WITH
MORE THAT. DON'T. THEY'LL TAKE
ADVANTAGE BACKING ABOUT MY FOR.
RIGHT MONEY. MY PRIVATE LIFE MY
FOR. BURKE IN THE- ARE WE- JUST.
TO GET RID OF THE TWO THINK
EVERY WE HAVE THAT. THEIR TIME
OTHER. IN THOMAS. PRODUCT ONLY
BE. AGINST THAT THAT THERE NO
IDEA WHAT THE PARTY GET ALL. OR
THE RETURN AUTHORIZATION. THAT
OCCURRED FOR THE TO PROVE THAT
I NEED TO. FOR THE HOTEL TO. I
COULDN'T. EVEN CALL MY- MEETING.
WHO WERE AND WHAT THEY WERE
THERE FOR. I CREEK. TIME- I WAS
IN CLASS. BY I WORK EARLY WE BE
A LOT. TIME TO- INSTEAD I CHOSE
TO WRITE A LOT. TO INCARCERATED
LOVED. MONEY TO WALK AND POWER.
DOING LOUDLY IN THE FINAL IN
PART BY. OF WHAT IS THAT YOU
CAN BE READY IN. THE LONG. BOX
MY CHECK OUR JUMPER. ONE
EXAMPLE WITHOUT. ABOUT ADMIN
CUTICLE. AND THE COMMISSION A
LOT OF. BEAT EVERY ASPECT OF MY
LIFE. DURING MY CONFIRMATION I
WOULD ALWAYS. WHAT THE COURT
MAY COMING BACK ON TRACK.
HOWEVER I. NOT I EVEN GIVE WITH
THE TEN THINGS TO DO AND IF I.
EIGHT HOW MICHAEL LOOK AT YOU
LIKE YOU'RE- TO CLIMB. AN
UPDATE THE CORRECT PRESSURE
HAVE BEEN ABLE. I URGE YOU TO
PASS. FIVE A RETURNS THAT YOU
CAN ABLE TO GROW. FOR POTENTIAL.
BECOME INTRODUCED. AND TO OUT
OTHER MAKE IT THERE. FOR THEM
WITHOUT WITH. TO THEM. AND
CONSIDERING ACTUALLY. YOUNG
PEOPLE THE- HAVE THEIR SPEECH
LIKE FROM. BUT WITH COULD BE A-
IN GIVEN A PART. THE CORE
WITHOUT. YOUR THE CURRENT COST
YOU HAVE A LOT. OF THREE HIGH
BY TIME AND- COST THEM. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND THEN I.
HAVE STOLEN AND I. THE LINE. AS
THE- SECOND PRIME. THE PROGRAM
BACKGROUND- THAT'S OF NO
QUESTIONS. ASKED BECAUSE OF A-
OF A SUM SHOULD BE MADE. UP OF
WHILE. THAT WAS CREATED BY THE
KEEP THEM EACH TIME I WOULD
GIVE A TECHNICAL VIOLATION THIS
PROGRAM CALLED OUT AND I'M
INTRODUCED. INTO ANOTHER
PROGRAM WHICH MEANT THAT I
WOULD HAVE TO BUILD ANOTHER
RELATIONSHIP AND OPEN UP TO
ANOTHER STRANGER. I'VE BEEN
FORCED AN EXPECTED TO BE OPEN
TO ALL OF THESE PROGRAMS EVEN
IF I FELT THEY WERE NO HELP AT
THAT POINT IN MY LIFE. AND
THREE YEARS I HAVE A- SEVEN
PROBATION OFFICERS I HAVE BEEN.
THE BEST OF THE BEST ADVOCATE
FOR MYSELF YET BASICALLY. TURN
AND I AM TOLD THEY KNOW WHAT'S
BEST FOR ME BECAUSE THEY ARE
ADULTS. I OFTEN WONDER WHAT
LIFE WOULD BE LIKE IF I HAD
BEEN GIVEN THE RESOURCES THAT
THE POOR I NEEDED WHEN I WAS
FOURTEEN. I CAN ONLY HOPE THAT
MOVING FORWARD YOU. ARE GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THAT
SUPPORT AND ARE NOT KEPT ON
PROBATION FOR LONGER THAN
NEEDED. I URGE YOU TO PASS. AB
FIVE ONE THREE THANK YOU. Q.
NOW WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITE. AT
WE TO IN LEAD OPPOSITION MIKE
BELOW AND DANIEL SANCHEZ WILL
GIVE THEM THREE MINUTES APIECE
FOR. THEIR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I AM MIKE BELOW-
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
JUVENILE COURT JUDGES OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS A SECTION
OF THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION WE APPRECIATE THE
THOROUGH QUALITY ANALYSIS
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK TO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
AND HIS SPONSORS ABOUT THE BILL
THERE IS MUCH THAT WE AGREE ON
IN THIS. ISSUE WE DO AGREE THAT
ANALYSTS PROBATION IS A BAD
THING AND THAT PROBATION OUT TO
BE IMPOSED NO LONGER THAN
NECESSARY WE ALSO AGREE THAT-
PROBATION WHICH VARIES WIDELY
AMONG COUNTIES. SO THAT YOU
COULD CAUSE A SITUATION CALLED.
JUSTICE BY GEOGRAPHY IS A BAD
THING SO THERE'S MUCH THAT WE
AGREE ON WE DO NOT AGREE THAT A
PRESUMPTIVE SIX MONTH LIMIT ON
PROBATION. IS THE APPROPRIATE
TIME HOWEVER AND WE'VE HAD
EXTENSIVE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THIS- JUVENILE COURT JUDGES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE VERY VERY
DEDICATED TO THE REHABILITATION
OF YOUTH. A WE WERE A SPONSOR
OF A BILL TO INCREASE DIVERSION
FOR USE FOR EXAMPLE SB THREE
EIGHTY THREE. BUT WE THINK THE
SIX MONTH PERIOD IS TOO SHORT.
AND IT WILL HAVE UNINTENDED
EFFECTS IT COULD INCREASE
CUSTODIAL TIME FOR YOU WHICH IS
UNFORTUNATE UNINTENDED EFFECT
IT COULD CAUSE MORE MOTIONS TO
TRANSFER USED TO ADULT COURT
WHICH WOULD BE AN UNFORTUNATE
RESULT. WE SUGGEST THAT THE ONE
YEAR. THAT WAS A PROPOSAL LAST
YEAR IS A MORE APPROPRIATE
TIME. AND I WOULD SAY THAT THE
AT THE OTHER PROBLEM IS THAT
THE BILL SAYS THAT AND WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT TAKING
THE- PREPONDERANCE OF THE
EVIDENCE STANDARD FOR
OVERCOMING THE SIX MONTH
PRESUMPTION. BUT THE
PREPONDERANCE MUST SHOW THAT IT
IS IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
USE. AND THAT'S CONTRADICTORY
TO. EXISTING LAWS IN WELFARE
AND INSTITUTIONS CODE SECTION
TWO OH TWO WHICH APPLIES TO ALL
JUVENILE PROCEEDINGS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE LAW SPECIFIES
THREE. OBJECTIVES IT IS THE
JUDGE SHALL CONSIDER THE SAFETY
AND PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC.
PORTENTS OF REDRESSING INJURIES
TO VICTIMS AND THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THE MINOR IN ALL
DELIBERATIONS PURSUANT TO THE
CHAPTER. AND THE BILL SAYS THAT
THE- I MEAN CAN BE OVERCOME BY
A PREPONDERANCE ONLY RELATING
TO THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
YOUTH WE THINK THAT THE JUDGE
SHOULD TAKE INTO ACCOUNT. ALL
OF THOSE FACTORS IN SECTION TWO
OH TWO. WE STILL BELIEVE THAT A
YEAR IS THE APPROPRIATE LENGTH
AND THAT THE PROTECTION OF THE
PUBLIC. HAS TO BE PART OF THE
CONSIDERATION FOR THE JUDGE IN
ADDITION TO THE INTERESTS OF
THE U. SO WE ARE WE HOPE THAT
THE BILL COULD BE APPROPRIATELY
AMENDED AT THIS POINT WE ARE
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON
KEREN MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHEAP PROBATION
OFFICERS I OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED EIGHTY FIVE OH THREE- I
DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT IN FRAMING
OUR COMMENTS TODAY TO NOTE
THAT- THE PROVISIONS HE SAID
SHARE THE GOAL OF CREATING
PROPHECIES TO MOVIES
SUCCESSFULLY OUT OF THE SYSTEM
IN THE BUILDING SYSTEM WITH
LIMITS AND INCENTIVES TO HELP
MOVE YOU SUCCESSFULLY THROUGH
THEIR PROGRAMS AND OFFER
PROBATION- AND WAS STATED
EARLIER- WE HAVE PROPOSED IN
PREVIOUS LEGISLATIVE YEARS.
SETTING UP FRAMEWORKS- RELIGION
DID YOU BUT I'LL PROBATION
TERMS SO WE REALLY LEANED INTO
THIS DISCUSSION AND YOU WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT OUR OPPOSITION
IS NOT REFLECTIVE OF THE OVER
ARCHING GOALS IN WHICH I THINK
THERE'S AGREEMENT REALLY ON
AGAIN WHAT WHAT IS I'M BEING
SOUGHT TO BE ACHIEVED HERE
WE'VE ENGAGED IN CONVERSATION
SINCE THE BILL WANTED TO PRINT-
WITH THE OFFERING WITH THE
SPONSORS NOTING OUR CONCERNS ON
THE CURRENTLY PROPOSED
PRESUMPTION FOR DISCHARGE AT
SIX MONTHS- AND IN LIGHT OF.
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS WHICH DO
NOT MAKE CHANGES TO THAT
SPECIFIC PROVISIONS WE'RE IN A
POSITION NOW TO OPPOSE AND WE
ARE CONCERNED THAT BY SENDING A
PRESUMPTION AT SIX MONTHS EVEN
WITH THE POTENTIAL TO EXTEND
THAT SIX MONTHS WERE CHIP WILL
NOT BE DEEMED SUITABLE FOR SOME
CASES AND WILL NOT ACCOMMODATE
THE LENGTH AND CERTAIN
TREATMENT ARE PROGRAMS AND
THEREFORE DISPOSITION SUCH AS
ADULT COURT OR SECURE SETTINGS
COULD BE CONSIDERED MORE IN
SOME INSTANCES WHICH IS
CERTAINLY. NOT SOMETHING THAT
WE WANT TO SEE MORE US WE
BELIEVE THAT LOOKING AT THE
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS AND THAT YOU
PROGRESS TOWARDS OUR KEYS PLAN
AND COMPLETION OF PROGRAMS IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO GUIDE AND THE
DISCHARGE FURTHER THERE'S A
GRADUATING CONTINUE LET YOU AND
ALL RESPONSES TO REFLECT THE
NEEDS OF USED AND THE TIMELINE
SET FORTH IN THIS BILL FOR
WORSHIP I WOULD NOTE ARE
SHORTER IN DURATION THAN SOME
OF THE OTHER GRADUATING
DISPOSITIONS. SUCH AS AT THE
FOR ENTRY OF JUDGMENT WHICH HAD
THE MINIMUM OF A YEAR YOU TOO
HAVE BEEN MADE WARDS OF THE
COURT AS WITH THE STILL HAVE
BEEN DETERMINED BY THE CORTINI
FOCUS SERVICES PROGRAMMING AND
TREATMENT. THAT MAY EXTEND
BEYOND SIX MONTHS AND WITH MORE
TO BE REALLY. WITH THE CAN ON
FOR SECOND- OFF INVOLVING MORE.
OFFENSE AND ENOUGH. AND
APPROPRIATE. FOR THE SAFETY AND
THE U. N. THE CAN- BUT I DO
WANT TO HIRE. WE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO HAVE A
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT TO
EXPECT OF THEM IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT THEM IN SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETING THEIR TERM OF
PROBATION. AND WE AGREE WITH
BUILDING A FRAMEWORK WITH
PARAMETERS AND SENTENCED TO.
MOVE YOU THROUGH THEIR PROGRAMS
AND AGAIN OFF OF PROBATION. BUT
WE BELIEVE THE CURRENT
MECHANISMS CREATE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND THEREFORE
WE'VE AFTER THEIR TO BE
CONSIDERATION OF AMENDMENTS TO
THE SIX MONTHS PRESUMPTION.
THANK YOU FOR THE DISCUSSION
TODAY WE LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS. THANK
YOU NOW WILL MOVE TO OUR PHONE
LINES ARE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITE
ONE NO LET'S GO TO THE
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM- SHE NO
ONE HERE AND OUR OVERFLOW ROOM
THERE'S NO ONE IN TWENTY FORTY
EITHER NOW. MODERATE WILL GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES FOR. WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO YOU. AB FIVE
ALL THREE. FOR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE OH THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO. AND
FIRST WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I MY NAME IS ELLIE AND
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA POLLUTION
I'M ACTUALLY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE OH THREE. HANK YOU
IN THAT LINE TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY. BY. TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN. HI MY NAME IS ERICA
AND I'M FROM DIFFICULT MISSION
APPROACH COSPONSORED AND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIVE ONE
THREE THANK YOU. BLIND. TWO
HUNDRED TEN. GREG STUBER ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE COALITION
OF PROBATION ORGANIZATIONS IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY PROBATION
ASSOCIATION AN OPPOSITIONAL AS
AMENDED THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE. WHERE WITH
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES GOING OPPOSITION
UNLESS AMENDED. AND WE HAVE.
OUTLINED IT. TWO HUNDRED
SIXTEEN. FINE TWO HUNDRED
SIXTEEN OR MY COULD OPEN. AND
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
YOU WE'LL BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OTHER QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS AS IT RELATES TO AB
FIVE ALL THREE THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS AT THIS POINT.
CERNER CHOKE I'M JUST KINDA
CURIOUS TO KNOW WHERE YOU ARE
WITH WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION IN ADDRESSING SOME
OF THEIR CONCERNS THEY MENTION
TODAY WELL REALIZES BILLS MEN
AND MEN IT SEVERAL TIMES TO TRY
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS WE CHANGE THE STANDARD
OF REVIEW AND RIGHT NOW WE ARE
LOOKING AT. APPROPRIATE
AMENDMENTS TO SET THAT STANDARD
AT WHICH TO- TO BE ABLE TO USE
THAT INSTEAD OF THE WHAT'S
CURRENTLY IN THE BILL THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE CHILD BECAUSE
WE DO UNDERSTAND. THE
FLEXIBILITY BEING ASKED THERE.
THE SIX MONTHS I THINK IS IT IS
A LITTLE BIT MORE DIFFICULT.
BECAUSE A YEAR IS A LONG TIME.
IT RELIES IN SOME COUNTIES
AVERAGE PROBATION IS SIX MONTHS
IN SOME COUNTIES AVERAGE
PROBATION TWO AND A HALF YEARS.
SAME KINDS OF CRIMES SO WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND THE RIGHT POINT
AT WHICH TO SET THAT
PRESUMPTION AND IF THERE IS A
SENTENCE FOR CIRCUMSTANCE THAT
IS LONGER THAN THAT SIX MONTHS.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY POSSIBLE IT
COULD GO ANOTHER SIX MONTHS AGO
ANOTHER SIX MONTHS AGO ANOTHER
SIX MONTHS DEPENDING ON THE
LENGTH OF TREATMENT THAT'S
NEEDED. DEPENDING ON WHAT THE
OUTOMES REALLY FAR BUT WHAT
THIS IS SETTING UP IS THAT
REVIEW. AT SIX MONTHS. UNDER
THIS THE CIRCUMSTANCES AND
AGAIN WE'RE WORKING ON
AMENDMENTS AROUND WEEK TO- TO.
TO LOOK AT THE PROGRESS OF THAT
CHILD IS MAKING LOOK AT THE
OTHER FACTORS SO IF THE
TREATMENT GOES LONGER THAN SIX
MONTHS THAT'S ABSOLUTELY BUILT
IT. AND WHAT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
HERE IS THAT WE'RE CREATING
DIFFERENT STANDARDS FOR SETTING
THOSE PROBATION CONDITIONS SO
THAT THEY WILL BE MORE
CONSISTENT ACROSS THE STATE
WHICH I THINK YOU HEARD FROM
THE JUDGES AND PROBATION
OFFICERS. OR CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR AS
WELL. WE'VE BEEN WORKING I
THINK FAIRLY CLOSELY WITH THEM
WE HAVE SOME DISAGREEMENTS. BUT
WE'VE BEEN TAKING AMENDMENTS
ALONG THE WAY TO TRY AND LISTEN
TO THEIR CONCERNS UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE PRACTICAL IMPLICATIONS
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
FACING. AND AN ADDRESS THOSE IN
THE BILL BECAUSE THIS BILL IS
REALLY ABOUT GIVING AS MUCH
FLEXIBILITY AS POSSIBLE. BUT
PROVIDING CONSISTENCY ACROSS
THE STATE COUNTY BY COUNTY SO
THAT THERE IS A AN APPROPRIATE
EXPECTATION. OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT THAT CHILD
IS GOING TO FIND THEMSELVES IN
IF THEY'RE IN A NONCUSTODIAL
WARSHIP. WITH THE STATE SO WE
ARE WHO WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM. TO SEE WHAT WE
CAN DO TO ULTIMATELY ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS. AND FOR EXAMPLE
THEY THE JUDGES DON'T MIND THE
SIX MONTH REVIEW. BUT THEY WANT
TO CREATE THE PRESUMPTION AT
ONE YEAR. BUT THEN WHAT DOES
THAT DO FOR THOSE KIDS THAT ARE
THAT ARE. WOULD ONLY BE
OTHERWISE BE SUBJECT TO THE SIX
MONTHS BECAUSE IN THOSE
COUNTIES THAT HAVE AN AVERAGE
OF SIX MONTHS FOR THE CRIME THE
THEY WOULD THEN BE EXTENDED TWO
YEAR THAT DOESN'T SEEM FAIR SO.
WE'RE TRYING TO SORT THROUGH
THAT BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
TERMS OF THE BILL THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT THEY WANT. AND
THE ABILITY TO TAILOR
CONDITIONS TO THE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF THAT CHILD IS REALLY WHAT
THIS BILL IS ALL ABOUT. SORRY I
ALSO SEE HERE THAT THERE'S
QUITE A BIT OF- ELIMINATION OF
CERTAIN AREAS IN THE BILL THAT
STATED SO THE PROBATIONARY
PERIOD OF SIX MONTHS JUST ONE
PORTION OF THE BUILDING YOU
HAVE OTHER ITEMS HERE THAT YOU
IS THAT WITH THE INTENT TO
CREATE UNIFORMITY THROUGHOUT.
HEY AND- AND THE OTHER QUESTION
I NOTICED HERE WAS THAT- IN
CONSIDERATION OF THE SIX
MONTHS- THERE REALLY WASN'T
MUCH AB HELPED. IT DOESN'T TAKE
IN CONSIDERATION- THE TYPES OF
CRIME- SO I'M READING HERE.
BECAUSE THE BILL CONTAINS NO
DISQUALIFYING CRIMES A MINOR
PROBATION FOR MURDER SEXUAL
ASSAULT VEHICLE VEHICULAR
MANSLAUGHTER ARMED ROBBERY OR
GANG SHOOTING BE TREATED THE
SAME AS A MINOR ON PROBATION
FOR PETTY THEFT OR VANDALISM.
BUT THAT'S NOT TRUE. BECAUSE
THE PRESUMPTION IS SIX MONTHS
BUT THERE'S NOTHING THAT
PRECLUDES THAT FROM BEING
EXTENDED BASED ON THE SEVERITY
OF THE CRIME THE NEEDS OF THE
CHILD. THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
ARE THERE AND FOR A LOT OF
THOSE CRIMES THOSE ARE GONNA BE
CUSTODIAL CRIMES WE'RE TALKING-ABOUT NONCUSTODIAL WARSHIPS
HERE SO THAT THEY ARE DIVERTED
THERE THERE IN THE COMMUNITY
BUT THEY'RE STILL SUBJECT TO
PROBATION. AND IF THE NEEDS
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE LOOKING AT
WEEK TWO OH TWO STANDARD
BECAUSE THAT DOES TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT PUBLIC SAFETY AND SOME
OTHER THINGS RATHER THAN JUST
WHAT'S WHAT THAT CHILD NEEDS AT
THE TIME. SO THAT REVIEW COULD
BE BUILT IN IN THE EXPECTATION
IS THAT. THAT THAT SIX MONTHS
IN THE PRODUCTION HERE REALLY
FORCES A REVIEW OF THE CASE.
PROGRESS THAT THE CHILD IS
MAKING. THAT THE CIRCUMSTANCES
AROUND WHY THEY'RE THERE ALL
THAT COULD BE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT. AS YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THE EXTENSION AND ESPECIALLY IS
WE WORK THROUGH INCORPORATING
WITH TWO OH TWO SO THE- THE
NOTION THAT THAT EVERY KID IS
ONLY GOING TO GET SIX MONTHS
WHICH IS WHAT A LOT OF THE
OPPOSITION TO SAY. IS JUST NOT
TRUE. WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE'RE
ESTABLISHING IS. A BASS LINE.
AND THEN A REVIEW SO THAT WE'RE
NOT HAVING. NOT ONLY THE
DISPARATE. TIME ON NORTON NOT
THESE NONCUSTODIAL MORE TIPS
OF. YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS
IN SOME CASES SIX MONTHS TO A
YEAR IN OTHER CASES BUT A
LITTLE BIT MORE CONSISTENCY BUT
WHAT'S IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS IS
THAT THAT REVIEW IS FORCING THE
COURTS TO LOOK AT THE PROGRESS
OF THAT CHILD. AND LOOK AT WHAT
THE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE. THEY CAN
EXTEND. SO IT IT IT'S NOT A CAP
IT'S NOT A LIMIT. BUT IT IS A
REVIEW AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE CREATE THAT PRESUMPTION. SO
THAT IT'S NOT A REVIEW IN NAME
ONLY AND JUST CHECKING A BOX.
BUT THERE'S A STANDARD THAT
NEEDS TO BE MET. FOR CARRYING
THE WATER SO THE MORE SERIOUS
THE CRIME. THE LONGER THEY'RE
GOING TO BE. POTENTIALLY ON
PROBATION. I BELIEVE THAT
CHILDREN- YOU KNOW DO DESERVE A
SPECIAL CONSIDERATION SPECIALLY
WHEN YOU UNDERSTAND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE BRAIN AND
HOW- YOU KNOW HUGE RESPONSE TO-
THEIR HORMONAL STATE- AND
DURING THAT PERIOD OF TIME- BUT
I AM CONCERNED WITH SOME OF
THE- THE OPPOSITION'S AND I AM.
I ACTUALLY APPRECIATE WHERE
YOU'RE COMING FROM AS FAR AS
THE- THE REVALUATION- PERIOD
AND TO REALLY CONSIDER- THEY
SHOULD I THINK. HERE AT LEAST
THE COURT SYSTEM ALREADY DOES
THAT AB WHEN THEY'RE LOOKING
AT- AT THE SENTENCING OF A
SITUATION WE HEAR THE ARGUMENTS
WITH SOME OF THE JUDGES MAYBE
NOT EVERYONE BUT I THINK. THE
ONES THAT- YOU KNOW. THAT I'VE
UNDERSTAND. DO- BUT I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING- THE FUTURE
COLLABORATION YOU HAVE WITH THE
OPPOSITION I'M NOT GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL RIGHT NOW BUT
I DO TRULY APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT THAT YOU'RE DOING IN
CREATING THIS- THE SYSTEM FOR
REVIEW FOR YOU BECAUSE I DO
BELIEVE THAT- OUR KIDS NEED
HELP. AND THEY NEED TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HAVE- KIND OF AIM AT
SOMETHING FOR- TO TRY TO STRIVE
TO DO BETTER IN TO CHANGE THEIR
LIVES AND TO HAVE SOMETHING TO
MOTIVATE THEM SO IN THAT
INSTANCE I TRULY DO APPRECIATE
THE INTENT OF YOUR OF YOUR BILL
AT THIS TIME- BUT I DO WANT TO
SEE SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT
ARE BEING ADDRESSED- HE
FURTHER- ADDRESSED- BUT I DO
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING IT- COME
BACK ON THE SENATE FLOOR TO SEE.
HOW THEY HAVE EVOLVED. WELL
HOPING IT'S NOT COULD COME BACK
TO THE TO THE COMMITTEE SO
YOU'LL SEE IT THERE AND THEN I
FULLY EXPECTED. THAT HE WOULD
BE SUPPORTING THIS AND THAT'S
FINE. BUT TO UNDERSTAND THAT.
THE DISPARITIES COUNTY BY
COUNTY IS WHAT'S REALLY DRIVING
THIS AND AS WE TALK TO JUDGES
WHO SAY OH I WOULD NEVER DO
THAT OKAY BUT YOUR NAME THE
JUDGES IN YOUR NEIGHBORING
COUNTY. TO AVERAGE IN SOME
COUNTIES THE TIME A PROBATION
SIX MONTHS. OTHER COUNTIES TWO
AND A HALF YEARS. HOW DO WE
JUSTIFY THAT WITHOUT DOING
SOMETHING. ABOUT IT SO IT'S
JUST NOT TRUE. AB JUDGES ARE
TRYING TO DO WHAT THEY THINK IS
BEST BUT SOMETIMES THEY BECOME
VERY PATERNALISTIC AND THAT'S
WHY YOU'LL SEE FIFTY CONDITIONS
CAN YOU MATCH FIFTY CONDITIONS
HAD AS A TEENAGER EVEN BEGIN TO
TRACK THAT. AND AS SOON AS
THERE IS A VIOLATION OF THE
TERMS OF PROBATION. INFORMATION
GETS EXTENDED ADDITIONAL
CONDITIONS GET PUT ON THEY
COULD EVEN END UP INCARCERATED.
BECAUSE OF THAT EVEN THOUGH
THEIR MISDEMEANOR. TRUANT
THAT'S A TUITION IS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE SOME
COUNTIES ARE DOING A GREAT JOB
OTHER COUNTIES NOT SO MUCH.
THAT'S THE HEART OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANY DISCUSSIONS ARE
CONCERNED. BYE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. ARE WE HAVE A WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR SKINNER WE
HAVE A TO PASS- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION- SOONER I'M
ASSUMING THAT STONE WHICH ELECT
CLOSE I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS
THANK YOU Q. ARE. COUNCIL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON AB FIVE
OLD THREE TO PASS AB FIVE OH
THREE BRADFORD BRADFORD I'D
SHOW VOGUE NO JO'BURG NO COM
LONGER HI I'M LONGER AYE
SKINNER. SKINNER I. THE MEASURE
HAS THREE. ONE NO WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR THANK
YOU NOW MR CUNNINGHAM WHO'S
WAITED SO PATIENTLY ALL THIS
TIME. HE HAS AB SEVEN HUNDRED.
AND IMPROVE SURE PRETTY SURE
WILL BE OUT HERE IN THE NEXT
TWO HOURS SO YOU CAN BEGIN YOUR
PRESENTATION. OKAY GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SENATORS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB SEVEN HUNDRED-
CURRENTLY DEFENDANTS IN FELONY
CASES IN OUR COURTS SYSTEM ARE
GENERALLY REQUIRED BY LAW TO BE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT IN THE
COURTROOM. DURING TWO TYPES OF
PROCEEDINGS TRIAL AND
PRELIMINARY EXAMINATION.
HOWEVER UNDER CURRENT LAW IN
CERTAIN INSTANCES A TRIAL CAN
PROCEED IN THE DEFENDANT'S
ABSENCE. BUT A DEFENDANT MUST
BE ABSENT ABSENT QUOTE AFTER
THE TRIAL OR PRELIMINARY
EXAMINATION HAS COMMENCED IN
THEIR PRESENCE. THIS HAS
CREATED A PROBLEM PARTICULARLY
DURING THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND SEE SCENARIOS
WHERE DEFENDANTS ARE IN CUSTODY
AND NOT PRESENT FOR THE
COMMENCEMENT OF THE TRIAL
PRELIMINARY EXAM. EXAMINATION
FORD EVER WHATEVER REASON IT
ALSO CREATES A CONFLICT AND A
PROBLEM FOR THE JUDGES
ADMINISTERING THE COURT
BECAUSE- IN PARTICULAR WHERE
DEFENDANT HAS NOT WAIVED THEIR
SPEEDY TRIAL RIGHTS FOR EITHER
PRELIM OR TRIAL. BUT YET THEY
CANNOT BECAUSE OF SICKNESS OR
OTHER VOLUNTARY REASONS STATE
CANNOT BE BROUGHT TO COURT THE
JUDGES IN AN UNTENABLE
SITUATION EITHER HAVE TO- NOT
ABIDE BY THE SPEEDY TRIAL
RIGHTS THAT THE CALL THE
DEFENDANTS HAVE. ORDER THEM
BROUGHT FROM A CUSTODY AGAINST
THEIR WILL INTO COURT WHICH OF
COURSE CREATES ALL SORTS OF
PROBLEMS FOR ALL SORTS OF
PEOPLE INCLUDING THE
DEFENDANTS- SO THIS BILL WOULD
FIX THIS ISSUE BY ALLOWING A
PRELIM OR TRIAL TO PROCEED IN A
DEFENDANT'S ABSENCE AT YOU BUT-
ONLY UNDER CERTAIN NARROW
CIRCUMSTANCES. THE DEFENDANT
HAS TO BE IN CUSTODY ONE. THE
COURT HAS TO MAKE FINDINGS ON
THE RECORD INCLUDING THERE'S
CLEAR AND CONVINCING EVIDENCE
THAT THE DEFENDANT IS
VOLUNTARILY CHOOSING. TO NOT
APPEAR IN COURT TO. DEFEND IT
MUST BE REPRESENTED BY COUNSEL
WHO MUST BE PRESENT IN THE
COURTROOM PHYSICALLY THREE. AND
THE DEFENDANT MUST HAVE AND
THIS IS KEY MUST HAVE
VOLUNTARILY CONSENTED TO
CONDUCT THE COMMENCEMENT OF THE
PROCEEDING. AFTER BEING FORM
INFORMED OF THEIR RIGHTS BY
COUNSEL AND THE COURT- I THINK
THAT STRIKES A GOOD BALANCE WE
TOOK AMENDMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S AND THE ACLU- THAT I
BELIEVE TRULY DID STRENGTH IN
THE BILL CONSIDERABLY I THINK
IT IT MAY BE WORTH OF COURSE
NOT BINDING TO THIS COMMITTEE
BUT IT DID PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
SEVENTY EIGHT TO ZERO ON THE
FLOOR- THE BILL IS SUPPORTED BY
THE CDA AND WITH ME I THINK
UNLESS HE HADTO GO TO DINNER-
ON THE PHONE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS LAURIE MORSE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION OR GO TO
BED. SILVA FIVE HERE I'M HERE
I'M HERE SENATOR AND
ASSEMBLYMAN BARRYMORE'S. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
MR- CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
DEPENDENCE IS YOU KNOW HAVE
BOTH THE CONSTITUTIONAL AND
STATUTORY RIGHTS TO BE PRESENT
IN COURT DURING CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS. COURTS HAVE LONG
HELD DEFENDANTS MAY VOLUNTARILY
WAIVE THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO BE PRESENT IN COURT.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY ARE
PRESENT IN COURT AT THE TIME OF
THE WAY. HOWEVER UNDER THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATUTE GOVERNING A
DEFENDANT'S PRESENCE. FOR A
DEFENDANT TO VOLUNTARILY WAIVE
THEIR STATUTORY RIGHT TO BE
PRESENT IN COURT FOR TRIAL AND
PRELIMINARY EXAMINATION. THE
DEFENDANT MUST BE PRESENT IN
COURT AT THE COMMENCEMENT OF
THE TRIAL OF PRELIMINARY
HEARING. WILL BETTER OR WORSE
EVERY YEAR THERE ARE NUMBER OF
DEFENDANTS WHO DO NOT WISH TO
BE BROUGHT INTO COURT. EVEN FOR
THE COMMENCEMENT OF TRIAL OF
FREEDOM. BECAUSE OF THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE IN THE STATUTE COURTS
ARE CAUGHT BETWEEN A ROCK AND A
HARD PLACE. IF THEY WANT TO
PROCEED BECAUSE THERE ARE
WITNESSES WHO MAY NOT BE LATER
AVAILABLE. AND FURTHER BENT THE
DELAYING THE CASE BENEFITS NO
ONE THE COURT MUST BE EITHER
ONE OR THE DEFENDANT FORCIBLY
BE BROUGHT TO COURT
ENDANGERING. THE DEFENDANT THE
BAILIFFS AND ANYONE ELSE IN THE
PRESENCE OR TO VIOLATE THE
STATUTE. SIMILAR PROBLEM ARISES
WHEN A PERSON CHARGED WITH A
MISDEMEANOR IS IN CUSTODY AND
DOES NOT WISH TO APPEAR IN
COURT FOR CERTAIN SPECIFIED
HEARINGS. THIS BILL SOLVES
THESE ONGOING PROBLEM WITHOUT
TRAMPLING WITH EXISTING LAW
GOVERNING WHAT MUST HAPPEN WHEN
THE DEFENDANT IS PHYSICALLY
PRESENT IN COURT. AND MOTIONS
TO WAIVE THEIR SUBSEQUENT
PRESENTS. THIS BILL WHICH
THANKS TO MODIFICATIONS
REQUESTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION.
HAS GREATER PROTECTIONS THAN
PROVIDED BY ANY STATE. OR
ENSURING- REPRESENTED DEFENDANT
IN CUSTODY WHO DOES NOT WISH TO
BE PHYSICALLY DRAGGED IN THE
COURTS. CAN WAIVE HIS PRESENCE
BUT ONLY AFTER YEARS SHE HAS
BEEN FULLY INFORMED. OF ALL
RELEVANT RIGHTS AND WHAT WE
WHAT HAPPENS IF THEY- NOT TO BE.
WE RISK ASK ME SUPPORT AND PASS
AS WELL MY BITS. IMPORTANT
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE PENAL
CODE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU NOW
WILL MOVE TO WITNESSES HERE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE WHO WISH
TESTIFYING IN BEHALF OF- SB
SEVEN HUNDRED CHINO WITNESSES
NOW WILL GO TO TWENTY FORTY
THIRD NO WITNESSES THERE ARE AS
WELL. MODERATOR ARE THEIR
COLORS CUTE DESIRING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN HUNDRED.
FOR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN HUNDRED PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO I COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO COMMENTS
COMING THROUGH AT THIS TIME.
THE LOGON OF THE TWO ALL RIGHT
NOW WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION-
WILL GO TO OPPOSITION I SEE
THERE'S NO LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION ARE CORRECT. ON THIS
MEASURE. I DON'T COME TO DO WE
NOT HAVE A LIEN IS NOT
POSITIONS FROM MAKE SURE OKAY-
DO WE AND WE HAVE NO ONE HERE
IN FORTY TWO OH THREE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION WE
HAVE NO ONE IN TWENTY FORTY
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION MONTEREY OR WOULD
NOT GO TO OUR PHONE LINES AND
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVEN HUNDRED. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN HUNDRED.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AND WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF NASA HERNANDEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE.
CONCERN FOR HOW CONSENT- WOULD
BE OBTAINED IN A NUMBER OF
OTHER REASONS AND- AVAILABLE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
N. O. LINE. TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO SHALL
MATURE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT-
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU. AND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU WILL BRING
YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE OTHER
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS OF THE
RELIGIOUS RIGHT OR SENATE CALM
WATER. THANK YOU IS A CHAIR
THAT WAS MY QUESTION TOO ABOUT-
THE CONSENT IF YOU COULD-
ANSWER THAT ARE HAVE YEAR-
WITNESSES. HELP ANSWER THE
QUESTION BECAUSE SOMETIMES
FOLKS DON'T SHOW UP MAYBE.
BECAUSE OF PHYSICAL ILLNESS
BECAUSE OF MENTAL ILLNESS MAYBE
THEY'RE BEING RAILROADED BY
THEIR OWN- COUNCIL OR THEY'RE
BEING INTIMIDATED OR BULLIED IN
PRISON OR IN I MEAN IN JAIL.
AND SO A LOT OF THINGS CAN-
COMPLICATE FOLKS IS ABILITY TO
SHOW UP- OR EVEN WANT TO SHOW
UP SO. JUST WANTED ANY CLARITY
FROM YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ABOUT
HOW THE CONSENT HAPPENED.
CHURCHILL'S INDULGENCE
FINANCERS. QUESTION SO AS IT'S
DRAFTED NOW AS WE HAVE AMENDED
IT THROUGH THE PROCESS IN THE
ASSEMBLY THERE ARE SIX FINDINGS
THAT MUST BE MADE BY THE COURT
BY CLEAR AND CONVINCING
EVIDENCE WITH RESPECT TO EACH
FACTOR ONE IS THAT THE
DEFENDANT MUST BE IN CUSTODY-
AND BE REFUSING WITHOUT GOOD
CAUSE TO APPEAR IN COURT THAT
DAY FOR TRIAL THE SECOND IS THE
DEFENDER MUST BE INFORMED OF
THEIR RIGHT NOW THE GEISHA TO
BE PERSONALLY PRESENT. THREE
THE DEFENDANT MUST BE INFORMED
THAT THE TRIAL WILL PROCEED
WITHOUT THE DEFENDANT BEING
PRESENT FOR THE DEFENDANT MUST
BE INFORMED THAT THEY HAVE A
RIGHT TO REMAIN SILENT DURING
THE TRIAL FIVE THE DEFENDANT
HAS BEEN INFORMED THAT THEIR
ABSENCE WITHOUT GOOD CAUSE WILL
CONSTITUTE A VOLUNTARY WAIVER
OF ANY CONSTITUTIONAL
CONSTITUTIONAL OR STATUTORY
RIGHT TO CONFRONT WITNESSES
AGAINST THEM OR TESTIFY ON
THEIR BEHALF SIX THE DEFENDANT
HAS BEEN INFORMED WHETHER OR
NOT DEFENSE COUNSEL WILL BE
PRESENT AND WHAT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE IS THAT
THESE. SIX FACTORS THAT MUST
EACH BE FOUND BY CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE BY THE
COURT MUST BE FOUND ON THE
RECORD THE COURT HAS TO STATE
THE REASONS FOR EACH OF THE
FINDINGS UNDER THE FACTORS AND
THEN IF THE TRIAL LAST MORE
THAN ONE DAY OR THE PRELIM LAST
MORE THAN ONE DAY THE COURT IS
REQUIRED TO MAKE THESE FINDINGS
THE NEW ON EACH DAY AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PROCEEDINGS SO
IT'S NOT A ONE AND DONE
SITUATION THE SIX FACTORS MUST
BE STATE ON THE RECORD BY CLEAR
AND CONVINCING EVERY SINGLE DAY
THE DEFENDANT. CONTINUES TO BE
ABSENT. THANK YOU. TO SOME
QUESTIONS OR ONCERNS FIVE
MEMBERS AT THE SUN. KERN CHERRY
NINE- WE HAVE A- TO PASS.
RECOMMENDATION IS THERE A
MOTION FOR THE MEASURE. SOME OF
THAT CAN MOVE BY SENATOR COM
AUGER. CANCEL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON A. B. SEVEN HUNDRED SB
SEVEN HUNDRED BRADFORD HI RIGHT
FOR DIETRO BOGUE HI JOE BOAKAI
COM LONGER AND COME LATER AYE
SKINNER SKINNER I WINNER WINNER
I'D FIVE ZERO. TO MOVE
CUNNINGHAM THAT MEASURES OUT
FIVE ZERO CONGRATULATIONS YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU CENTERS
NEXT UP IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
HE HAS AB.
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SANDERS- GOOD EVENING I LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
THE LOS ANGELES AND SANTA CLARA
COUNTY PROBATION OFFICERS
WORKING WITH MY TEAM ON OUR NEW
LANGUAGE AND I GLADLY ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDS TODAY. I
PLAN TO CONTINUE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
PROBATION OFFICERS TO ADDRESS
ANY OUTSTANDING CONCERNS THEY
MAY HAVE ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT SIX TO ESTABLISH A
PROCEDURE TO RELEASE
INDIVIDUALS FROM THE TENSION
THAT ONLY FACE A VIOLATION OF
PROBATION. TYPICALLY WHEN YOU
ARRESTED AND CHARGED WITH A
CRIME YOU ARE ENTITLED TO SOME
FOR FREE CHAO PRE TRIAL RELEASE
HOWEVER THIS IS NOT THE CASE
WHEN IT COMES TO INDIVIDUALS
ARRESTED FOR A VIOLATION OF
PROBATION. EXISTING LAWS ON
CLEAR ON WHETHER OR NOT A
PERSON DETAINED FOLLOWING
ALLEGATION OF VIOLATING
PROBATION. HAS THE RIGHT TO
BAIL AND OPTIONS FOR RELEASE.
ARE NOT DESCRIBED MY BILL SEEKS
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE BY
DIRECTING THE COURT TO RELEASE
PEOPLE DETAINED ON A VIOLATION
OF PROBATION. UNLESS THEY FIND
AT THE INDIVIDUAL WOULD POSE A
THREAT TO PUBLIC SAFETY OR
DETERMINE THEIR FLIGHT RISK. AB
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT ALSO ALIGNS
WITH THE MOST RECENT HUMPHREY'S
DECISION BY THE SUPREME COURT.
AND STATE THAT HAVE BILLS SAID
IT MUST BE SET AT A LEVEL THE
PERSON CAN REASONABLY AFFORD.
SO I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING THIS REASONABLY FOR
REASONABLE REFORM TO UPHOLD THE
CORNERSTONE OF OUR CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM. WHICH IS THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE PEOPLE
WHO ARE ACCUSED OF ANY
WRONGDOING SHOULD BE ALLOWED
THE OPTION TO CONTINUE THEIR
LIVES OUTSIDE DETENTION UNTIL A
COURT CAN APPROPRIATELY
DETERMINE. WHETHER A VIOLATION
OCCURRED AND WHAT IF ANY
ADDITIONAL PROBATION TERMS ARE
NECESSARY- PLEASE INTRODUCE MY
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT
DAVID BRINGS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR CALL
JUSTICE AND ASK FOR YOUR ITEM.
VERY MUCH THIS BRIDGE WHEN
YOU'RE READY YOU CAN BEGIN YOUR
TESTIMONY OF THREE MINUTES.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON THE
LISTED CARE AND SENATORS- MY
NAME IS DAVID BRIGGS I'M A
ATTORNEY HAVE BEEN IN PRACTICE
NOW FOR ALMOST FORTY YEARS.
DOING CRIMINAL DEFENSE WORK.
AND I'M THE CO CHAIR OF.
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE WE ARE THE
SPONSOR OF A A. B. TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT- AB TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT WOULD MAKE MUCH NEEDED
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE WAY
CALIFORNIA COURTS HANDLE
ALLEGATIONS THAT A PERSON HAS
VIOLATED PROBATION.
PROBATIONERS ARE PEOPLE A JUDGE
HAS DETERMINED DESERVE TO BE
RELEASED INTO SOCIETY DESPITE
HAVING COMMITTED A CRIME.
GENERALLY THE CRIMES INVOLVED
OR MISDEMEANORS OR NONVIOLENT
SOMEONE'S. BEIJING IMPOSES
CONDITIONS INTENDED TO
REHABILITATE THE PROBATIONER
SUCH AS DRUG TESTING FAMILY
COUNSELING AND REPORTING TO A
PROBATION OFFICER. HOWEVER A
PROBATIONERS LIFE CAN BE
DIFFICULT AND PROBATIONERS NOT
INFREQUENTLY VIOLATE THE
CONDITIONS UP THEIR PROBATION.
PLEASE VIOLATIONS CAN BE
RELATIVELY MINOR SUCH AS
MISSING A SCHEDULED APPOINTMENT
WITH THE PROBATION OFFICER. SB
SEVERE SUCH AS COMMISSION OF A
NEW CRIME. AB TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT DOES NOT DEAL WITH NEW
CRIMES IN A PLACES NO
LIMITATION ON A PROSECUTOR'S
DISCRETION TO FILE A CHARGE
BASED ON THEIR CRIME. ANY SUCH
CHARGE WOULD OF COURSE
IMPLICATE THE DEFENDANT
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS TO DUE
PROCESS ON THE SPEEDY JURY
TRIAL. AB TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT
ADDRESSES PROBATION VIOLATIONS
OR THERE'S NO RIGHT TO A JURY
TRIAL. IN THE QUEUES OF
VIOLATING PROBATION CAN CONTEST
THE CHARGE ONLY IN A NON JURY
HERE. AND THERE'S NO FOR A
LIMIT ON HOW LONG THE PERSON
MUST WAIT FOR THIS HEARING.
CURRENTLY NO BAIL PROBATION
HOLES ARE STANDARD PROCEDURE
FOR FELONY CASES IN COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. I'M IN
MISDEMEANOR CASES ALSO PLEASE
HOLD FORCED PROBATIONERS INTO
JAIL FOR WEEKS OR EVEN MONTHS
ON UNPROVED CHARGES. THE BILL
TO CONSIDER THE DEGREE TO WHICH
INCARCERATIONS WILL INTERFERE
WITH THE PROBATIONERS
REHABILITATION. AND THEY TAKE
NO ACCOUNT OF THE SEVERITY OF
THE ALLEGED VIOLATION. AB
TWELVE TWENTY IT WOULD REPLACE
THE SYSTEM WITH ONE BASED ON
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT'S
RECENT DECISION IN IN RE HOME
FOR. IN MOST CASES IT WOULD
REQUIRE THAT IF ANY BAIL IS SET
IT MUST BE SAID IN AN AMOUNT
THE PROBATIONER CAN REASONABLY
AFFORD. IT WOULD REQUIRE JUDGES
TO KEEP PROBATIONER OUT OF JAIL
BEFORE THEIR HEARING UNLESS
JAIL IS THE ONLY MEASURE WHICH
WOULD REASONABLY PROTECT THE
PUBLIC AND REASONABLY ASSURE.
THE PERSON'S FUTURE APPEARANCE
IN COURT. AB TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT WOULD KEEP PROBATIONERS
HOME WITH THEIR FAMILIES
WORKING OTHER JOBS AND
PARTICIPATING IN A DRUG
TREATMENT PROGRAMS. BY URGING
TO FURTHER THE REHABILITATION
OF PROBATIONERS. BY VOTING
ONLINE ON A. B. TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE
BACK TO THE ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE THERE'S NO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OF AB TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT WE'LL GO TO OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM HOUSTON WHEN THEY'RE AS
WELL MODERATOR OR THEIR
WITNESSES SO I WOULDN'T JUST
DESIRING TO TESTIFY. ON BEHALF
OF AB TWELVE TWENTY. IN SPORT.
YES SIR WE HAVE LEVINE EIGHTY
NINE GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON HEARING SENATOR
MARCHING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE ONE TWENTY TWO.
GERYGONE ON BEHALF OF INITIATE
JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT. NINE
TWO ZERO FOUR. PLEASE HOLD
WHILE HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. NINE
ONE EIGHTY SIX. K. ONE BEING A
BILLIONAIRE CALIFORNIA ACTION-
IN STRONG SUPPORT. BUT WHAT
ELSE WOULD YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OKAY NOW WILL MOVE TO OUR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES LISTED
MODERATOR IF DANIEL SANCHEZ IS
READY WE CAN HEAR TESTIMONY.
ABOUT THREE MINUTES. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DANIEL SANCHEZ I'M THE OPPOSITE
SHE PROBATION OFFICERS
CURRENTLY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT BUT I DO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEAD I HAD FOR
THE OPENNESS TO THE DISCUSSION
WITH US ON THIS ISSUE
PROVISIONS YOU STRONGLY SUPPORT
FOSTERING ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION AND WE HAVE
STRONGLY SUPPORTED REFORMS
WHICH FOCUS ON APPROPRIATE
RELEASED PRIOR TO CONVICTION.
HOWEVER THIS BILL DIFFERS
SIGNIFICANTLY AS IT APPLIES TO
AN INDIVIDUAL AFTER THEY HAVE
BEEN CONVICTED AND SUBSEQUENTLY
VIOLATED THE TERMS OF THEIR
SENTENCE- WHICH ARE TERMS OF
COURSE THAT HAVE BEEN AGREED TO
AS DETERMINED BY THE COURT- I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT PROBATION. VERY MUCH
UNDERSTAND THAT CHANGE IS A
PROCESS AND IN THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CASES IT IS NOT
IMMEDIATE- IN WORKING WITH-
INDIVIDUALS- PROBATION UTILIZES
RESEARCH BASED GRADUATED
RESPONSES TO ADDRESS VIOLATIONS
OF THE TERMS AND CONDITIONS
PROVISION ALSO UTILIZES YOUR
MORE THAN INCENTIVES TO HELP
INCENTIVIZE ENGAGEMENT
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAM. HE'S
GRADUATED RESPONSES TO
VIOLATIONS ARE STRUCTURED
INCREMENTAL AND PROPORTIONAL
AND INTENDED TO REFLECT A
RESEARCH ON THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF. RESPONSES TO ADDRESSING
BEHAVIORS. FURTHER GRADUATE
RESPONSE. I USED BEFORE
DETENTION WHEN AN INDIVIDUAL
VIOLATE THEIR PROBATION
SENTENCE. PROVISION USE OF
OPTION SHORT OF FILING A
REVOCATION WHEN AT ALL POSSIBLE
AND WE AGREE THAT INCARCERATION
SHOULD BE A LAST RESORT BUT WE
DO RECOGNIZE IT AS A NECESSARY
RESPONSE WITH SERIOUS RISKS ARE
PRESENT. WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
THIS BILL WILL HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES BY SETTING UP A
PRESUMPTION FOR RELEASE. IN
INSTANCES WHERE A VIOLATION OF
THE COURT'S ORDERS HAVE
OCCURRED AND ONE OTHER
GRADUATED SANCTIONS HAVE BEEN
EXHAUSTED TO ADDRESS VIOLATIONS
AND OR SERIOUS ARREST PRESENTED
TO THE INDIVIDUAL OR THE
COMMUNITY. AND THERE ARE SOME-
IMPLEMENTATION- QUESTIONS AND
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE'VE HAD WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO TALK TO RUN WORK
THROUGH AS WELL. WE WORK EVERY
DAY TO HELP OUR CLIENTS
MEANINGFULLY ENGAGE WITH
EVIDENCE BASED REHABILITATION
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ADDICTION TREATMENT COUNSELING
EDUCATION. JOB TRAINING AND
STABLE HOUSING. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE MUST I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT ACTIVE TIME BASED
ON SOME OF THE- IMPACTS AND
THIS RELATES TO ADDRESSING
VIOLATIONS OF THE COURTS
CONDITIONS. AND WE DO CERTAINLY
LOOK FORWARD- IN LIGHT OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE ARE BEING
DISCUSSED IN PROPOSED WITH FOR
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT PRIMARY
WITNESS AN OPPOSITION TH.
MISTER SMITH. YES THANK YOU I'M
SORRY MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MEDIA SMITH PRESIDENT
OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY PEACE
OFFICERS LOCAL FIFTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN ASKED ME AND I SPEAK ON
SPEAK TODAY ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY PROBATION
OFFICERS LOCAL. SIX EIGHTY
FIVE. AND IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN ALSO ASKED ME. AS AMENDED
WE MOVE OUR OPPOSITION TO
NEUTRAL AND WITH THE COMMITMENT
BY THE AUTHOR TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH US AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NOW WILL MOVE TO FORTY TWO OR
THREE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
IS THERE ANYONE WISHING TO
WILL GO TO TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NO ONE THERE AS WELL MY TO
WRITER LET'S GO TO PHONE LINE
TWO THIRDS WITNESSES AND Q.
DESIRING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION- AB TWELVE TWENTY.
EIGHT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
BILL OPEN ONLINE TO CHEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. NINE TO TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD. ONCE
AGAIN NINE TO TEN YOU HAVE AN
OPEN MIND. CICRET STUPOR AT THE
STATE COALITION INFORMATION
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE SECOND
ACCOUNT INFORMATION ASSOCIATION
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR-
FOR WORKING WITH US AT THIS
POINT TIME WE ARE IN THE SAME
POSITION AND SEE PARKING THAT
WE HAVE SEVERAL MOMENTS THAT WE
STILL. BELIEVE NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT BEFORE WE COULD
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION SO WE ARE
STILL IN A POSE UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
DISCUSSION OR ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS AS IT RELATES TO AB
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT FOR SOME
NIGHT. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR WIENER. NO FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS CINNAMON LEE WITH
SELECT QUOTE S. I JUST LIKE TO
THANK- THEY MEMBERS OPPOSITION
INFORMATION OFF IS WORKING WITH
US CHANGES INDEED A PROCESS AND
I KNOW THAT WE HAVE A SHARED
THAT- FOLKS OPERATION- ARE
RECEIVING- A RECEIVING AS MANY
ALL ALTERNATIVES INCARCERATIONS
POSSIBLE INYO READING READING
CARDS RATIONS OF COURSE THE
LAST RESORT AND IT'S NOT
SOMETHING I THINK WE ARE
INTERESTED IN SO I THINK I AM
HOPEFUL WE WORK ON CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE SURE WE
ARRIVE AT THE SAME GOAL AND
I'VE BEEN VERY- PLEASED TO WORK
WITH THEM QUITE CLOSELY ON THIS
BILL SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT. AND- DR- CAN YOU STATED
YOU WERE. TAKING THE MOMENTUM
CARE ACT. OKAY- CANCEL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL IS TO PASS TO.
RESUMEN THE TO APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT BRADFORD REFERRED
I'D SHOW BOTH NO SO ABOVE NO
COME AUGER HI MY GROWING
SKINNER SKINNER I WIENER.
WIENER AYE. BOREDOM I'M SORRY
IT'S FORTY ONE CERTAINLY YOUR
BILLS ALL FORTY ONE- AT THIS
POINT CAN WE LOOK TO CALL ON
THOSE OUTSTANDING ITEMS. A. B.
AB. ONE TEN- THE VOTE IS TWO
ZERO SKINNER. AB ONE TIMED ITEM
ONE AYE SKINNER I WINNER WINNER
EYES FOUR ZERO. FOUR ZERO. AB
FOUR EIGHTY ONE ITEM THREE VOTE
IS TWO TO ONE SKINNER. HI
SKINNER I WINNER WINNER I'D.
FOUR ONE ZERO FOUR ONE AB TEN
ZERO THREE- THE VOTE IS TWO TWO
ZERO KAMLAGER HI COMMA- I
SKINNER SKINNER I WIENER.
WIENER AYE. FIVE TO ZERO FOUR
ZERO. THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE
VOTE IS THREE TWO ZERO SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE WINNER WIENER AYE
SECULARS OUT FIVE ZERO EIGHTY
SEVEN THIRTY ONE BY OUR- THE
VOTE IS TWO TWO ZERO SKINNER.
HI SKINNER I WINNER. WIENER AYE
VOTE IS FOUR TWO ZERO. REPORTER.
ZERO- AB FOURTEEN R. FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO BRAD BIRD IS THREE
TWO ZERO KAMLAGER. NOT VOTING
CAMARGO HAPPENING SKINNER
SKINNER NOT VOTING THE VOTERS
THREE TO ZERO. YOUR. THE FOR
THE BILLS OUT BERMAN AB TWENTY
SIX THE VOTE IS TWO TO ONE COM
AUGER HI FROM EITHER I'D WINNER.
WIENER AYE FOUR TO ONE. FOUR
ONE. AB TWO FIFTY SIX- THE VOTE
IS TWO TO ONE SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE WIENER. WIENER AYE
FOUR TO ONE. THE ONE MEASURES
OUT- AB FIVE OH THREE OF VOTE
IS. READ ONE WIENER WIENER-
WIENER AYE. FOR ONE ZERO FOUR
ONE- NOT ONE SO. ANALYSTS AB
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE VOTE IS
THREE TWO ZERO SKINNER SKINNER
AYE WIENER WIENER AYE. FIVE TO
ZERO. IT WAS POLL WELL LET ME
SEE HOLD ON LET ME DOUBLE CHECK.
I BELIEVE THAT WAS WONDERFUL-
YES IT WAS CALLED. TILL NEXT
WEEK. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE RODRIGUEZ WERE
READY FOR YOU AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY THIS IS OUR LAST ITEM
THIS EVENING SHOW. WHEN YOU'RE
READY YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU
RICHARD JR MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT A.
B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY WHICH WOULD
PERMIT LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
TO REQUEST AND RECEIVE ARREST
INFORMATION FOR SPECIFIC NON
SWORN EMPLOYEES. LIKE TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD NARROW THE REST OR
DETENTIONS SUBJECT TO
DISCLOSURE TO SERIOUS AND-
BELLAMY FELONIES THOSE DEFINED
AS CRIMES INVOLVING DISHONESTY
OR INSTRUCTION OF LEGAL
PROCESSES. KERN ALLOW CURRENT
LAW ALLOWS A CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AGENCY TO COMPLETE THE
BACKGROUND CHECK ON APPLICANTS
FOR NON SWORN POSITIONS AND
OUTS AND INDIVIDUAL ABOUT PRIOR
ARREST. HOWEVER DUE TO A
LOOPHOLE IN THE LAW ONCE AN
APPLICANT IS HIRED THE AGENCY
CANNOT REQUEST OR RECEIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT A NON SWORN
EMPLOYEES ABOUT ANY FUTURE
ARREST. THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
WOULD ALLOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO INVESTIGATE WHEN
NON SWORN EMPLOYEES ARE RESTED
WHICH WOULD HELP SAFEGUARD THE
INTEGRITY OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. WITH ME THAT
TODAY TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND
HELP ANSWER QUESTIONS IS- CHAU
MUTCHLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. MOST OF YOU READY
YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS LUCIA
MUTCHLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
EIGHTY I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
FONTAINE THIS LEGISLATION. AS
WE MENTIONED AT THIS BILL WOULD
CLOSE IT CLOSE A LOOPHOLE IN
CURRENT LAW SO THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO REQUEST
AND RECEIVE AROUND INFORMATION
FOR CERTAIN NON SWORN EMPLOYEES
OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE AGENCIES-
WE DO ONE AT BANK- DOCTOR AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR
WORKING WITH US COLLABORATIVE
LEAD TO- COME UP WITH THESE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND- WE ARE
PLEASED THAT THE BILL I WILL BE
MOVING FORWARD HOPEFULLY REPEAT
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS- WE THINK
THAT IN THE SPIRIT OF CONSTANT
TRANSPARENCY AND ENSURING THAT
EMPLOYEES REMAIN OF THE HIGHEST
INTEGRITY. AND MAINTAINING
COMMUNITY TRYING AND THE ETHICS
OF THE PUBLIC SERVANTS WHO WORK
TO PROTECT OUR NEIGHBORHOODS IT
IS APPROPRIATE TO MAKE
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO LAW.
ENFORCEMENT EMPLOYEES EMPLOYERS
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE ASK
FOR YOUR. LIFE VOTE ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NOW
WE MOVE TO THE HEARING ROOM
FORTY OR THREE AYE SHE THERE'S
A WITNESSES HERE WISHING TO SO
ON BEHALF THIS MEASURE WILL GO
TO TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO
ONE'S WITNESS THEIR MODERATOR
CAN YOU OPEN A PHONE LINE TO
SEE IF THERE'S WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OF AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS
FROM ONE AND ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THE
TIME. THANK YOU WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I SEE THERE'S NO
LEAD OPPOSITION LISTED HERE SO
I WILL GO TO THE COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
I SEE NO ONE MOVING TO TESTIFY
SOLUTION ONE HERE. NOR IS THERE
ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR AGAIN I WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES INTO IT THERE'S
WITNESSES TO DESIRING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. OF AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY. FOR COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. OKAY ARE WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THEIR
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS IT
RELATES TO THIS MAJOR CENTERS
SKINNER. I'M I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS- I'M MUCH
MORE COMFORTABLE WITH THE BILL
IN ITS NARROWED FORM. AND SO I
WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY AND- I WILLING TO MOVE IT.
VERY ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
THE QUESTION TURNS ROGER. HARD
TO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS WILLINGNESS TO ACCEPT THOSE
AMENDMENTS I THINK INITIALLY
THERE WAS A LITTLE BIT OF
CONCERN WALL A GREAT DEAL OF
CONCERN AS TO. THE CAMEL'S NOSE
UNDER THE TENT SO TO SPEAK AND-
BEING ABLE TO LOOK AT NON SWORN
ON- RECORDS EVEN THOUGH IT
DIDN'T LEAD TO ARREST OR
CONVICTION SO I THINK THIS
GIVES A- LITTLE MORE CONFIDENCE
AND TRUST IN THE PROCESS AND
MAKING SURE. ALL THE SPHERE SO
ON THAT NOTE I WE HAVE A MOTION
FOR- AND SUPPORT. WE HAVE A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF MY CORRECT.
AND I DON'T AND IT. AS AMENDED
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND IF THERE'S
NO FURTHER COMMENT- SIX COUNCIL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY BRADFORD ART
FOR DIETRO BOTH BY OBOE GUY
COMMAGER I THOUGHT KAMLAGER I
SKINNER. IN OUR EYES WINNER
WINNER I'D FIVE ZERO. RODRIGUEZ
YOUR MEASURES OUT FIVE ZERO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY MEMBERS THAT
CONCLUDES ALL OF THE ACTIVITY
THE WE HEAR ON OUR AGENDA TODAY
WE DISPOSE OF ALL OUR ITEMS AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU. I ALSO
WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
FOR WHATEVER REASONS TODAY.
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
ORVISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION AND
TODAY'S SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
AND THIS CONCLUDES OUR HEARING.